TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET YEAR
THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING
THIS OVERVIEW THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL. SUBSEQUENT
TODAY TO TODAY'S HEARING WILL
CONDUCT ADDITIONAL FULL
COMMITTEE INFORMATIONAL HEARING
TO THE COMING WEEKS TODAY TO
TAKE DEEPER DIVES INTO SPECIFIC
BUDGET PROPOSALS ARE ISSUES
THAT WILL BE DELIBERATED
THROUGHOUT THE SPRING. THE
FIRST OF THESE HEARINGS WILL
TAKE PLACE ON FEBRUARY
THIRTEENTH AND WILL COVER THE
GOVERNOR'S CLIMATE PROPOSALS.
AFTER THESE FULL COMMITTEE
HEARINGS ARE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEES WILL BEGIN THEIR
REGULAR SCHEDULE AT THE
BEGINNING OF MARCH. HOWEVER
THERE BEEN A COUPLE OF SCHEDULE
SUBCOMMITTEE OVERSIGHT HEARING
STEP THREE MET YESTERDAY
REGARDING THE DDS RATE STUDY
AND SUBCOMMITTEE ONE WILL SOON-
JOINED FORCES WITH THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE IN REGARDS
TO THE ONLINE THE COLLEGE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING I LOOK FORWARD
TO DISCUSSING THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT TARGETS IMPORTANT
INVESTMENTS IN AREAS THAT MANY
OF US AGREE SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED EXAMPLES EARLY
EDUCATION K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION. ADDITIONAL LCF THE
FUNDING AN INCREASE SUPPORT FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION. IN THE AREA
OF HIGHER ED ONGOING INCREASES
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES YOU
SINCE THE ISSUE. HEALTH
EXTENDING MEDI CAL TO ELIGIBLE
SENIORS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND A BRA
PROPOSAL TO REDUCE PRESCRIPTION
DRUG PRICES. PUBLIC SAFETY
INCREASE OVER OF J. PROBE REFER
AND THAT. UP FOR THOSE WITH THE
IN STATE PRISON WALLS. AND
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT INTO A
NEW FUND TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
AN INCREASE HOUSING UNITS
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSIONS OF WHOLE
PERSON CARE APPROACHES. AND
ANOTHER ROUND OF LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS THESE ARE
JUST A FEW OF THE MANY
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. AS YOU ALL HOPE ARE
WELL AWARE THROUGHOUT THE
SPRING THE LEGISLATURE WILL
REVIEW THESE PROPOSALS AS WELL
AS DISCUSS ADDITIONAL
PRIORITIES THAT WE MAY TWO FOUR
IDENTIFY. WITH THAT SAID OF THE
TWO NIELSEN ON IF YOU HAVE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS. JUST BRIEFLY
THE- AND THIS IS A GOOD START.
ON THE YEAR AND I'M ENCOURAGED
BY THE GOVERNOR'S FOCUS IN
TERMS OF HOMELESSNESS NOT
SIMPLY ON PROVIDING SHELTER BUT
IN ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT CAUSE PEOPLE TO
BE ENDEMIC PLEA HOMELESS THE WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT IF
REALLY GOING TO DEAL WITH THE
HOMELESS PROBLEM. AND ANOTHER
TH COLLECTION THAT JUST AS WITH
RECENT BUDGET THOUGH CREATE A
BIT OF A SURPLUS IT'S VERY THIN
AND I WILL STILL ARGUE THAT OUR
BUDGET IS PRECARIOUSLY BALANCED
AND WE BEST BE MINDFUL OF THAT
AND CAREFUL ABOUT THE PLACE
BUILDING EXPENDITURES HUGE NEW
IDEAS OR EXPENDITURES AND AN
ADDITION. WHEN WE'RE DOING A
NEW AGENCY CREATIONS
CONSOLIDATIONS LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT THE FORMER AGENCY FROM
WHICH- THE- HAVE BEEN TRYING.
THAT THEIR BUDGET DOES NOT
INCREASE WHEN THEY LOOSE WIRES
THANK YOU. I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
HE CHIEF DEPUTY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON AND
ARE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
MISTER THAT THIS ONE OFTEN AND-
GAY PANIC THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING WE'LL
HEAR FIRSTHAND PART IN FINANCE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WHAT I'LL DO TODAY'S BRIEFLY
DESCRIBE THE OVERALL STRUCTURE
OF THE BUDGET. AS WELL AS SOME
KEY HIGHLIGHTS AND THEN AFTER
THAT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED A SPENDING PLAN THAT
TOTALSTWO HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS. OF
WHICH APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS IS
GENERAL FUND. THAT BUDGET THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSES
BALANCED THIS YEAR AS WELL AS
OVER THE FORECAST PERIOD
MEANING THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
SO THERE ARE OPERATING
SURPLUSES MEANING THAT REVENUES
EXCEED EXPENDITURES IN EACH OF
THOSE FOLLOWING FOR YEARS. AT
THE SAME TIME WE ARE
FORECASTING SLOWER GROWTH AND
THERE ARERISKS AHEAD AND FOR
THAT REASON- WE ARE CONTINUING
TO BUILD RESERVES IN THIS
BUDGET. GOTTEN IS PROJECTING
THAT BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE PEOPLE HAVE TWENTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
RESERVES. OF WHICH EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS WILL BE IN THE
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT
ALSO KNOWN AS THE RAINY DAY
FUND. ANOTHER ONE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN OUR SPECIAL
FUND FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT. AND THEN FINALLY NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
SIXTY RESERVE. MISSION BUILDING
ON A SOME OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PENSION PAY THAT WERE LAST YEAR.
IN THE BUDGET THAT THE ONCE
ENACT LAST YEAR- WE HAD TWO
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN A
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS TO
CALPERS AS WELL AS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS THIS BUDGET
PROPOSES TO ACCELERATE THAT
FULL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PAYMENT. INTO THE
CURRENT YEAR. YOU MAY RECALL
FROM THE BUDGET ACT LAST YEAR
THAT THERE WERE SUSPENSIONS
BUILT INTO THE BUDGET. OF
CERTAIN PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO
KEEP THE BUDGET IN STRUCTURAL
BALANCE. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THIS YEAR CONTINUES THE
SUSPENSIONS BUT DELAYS THEM BY
EIGHTEEN MONTHS SO THAT THEY
WOULD NOT TAKE EFFECT UNTIL THE
SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
IN ADDITION I KNOW THAT IN THIS
COMMITTEE THERE WAS A ROBUST
DISCUSSION OF THE MCO TAX
PROPOSAL- DEMONSTRATION
CONTINUES TO ASSUME APPROVAL OF
THE- NCO TAX CONSISTENT WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW- BUT
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE NOT YET
HEARD BACK FROM THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES NOT ASSUME THOSE
REVENUES IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
ASSUMES THOSE REVENUES IN THE
YEARS FOLLOWING THAT. FINALLY
TODAY SENATOR NIELSEN'S POINT
ON THE SURPLUS WE ARE AT
PROJECTING A SURPLUS. F FIVE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS THIS
YEAR WHILE NOT AS BIG AS THE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY ONE
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS THAT WE
HAD LAST YEAR. STILL IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT- BUT TO YOUR
POINT- WE EXPECT THAT MOST THAT
SURPLUS IS ONE TIME IN NATURE.
AND THAT IS WHY THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES ALLOCATING NEARLY 80%
OF THAT SURPLUS TO TEMPORARY OR
ONE TIME PURPOSES. SO THAT'S
THE OVERALL STRUCTURE THE BUT
BUDGET I WILL JUST- TAKE OFF A
COUPLE KEY HIGHLIGHTS AND HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS AFTER LA- IN
ANY OF THESE AREAS. THE FIRST
IS IN EDUCATION- SO EARLY
CHILDHOOD IS A PRIORITY FOR THE
GOVERNOR- THIS INCLUDES
BUILDING ON LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
AN ADDITIONAL TEN THOUSAND
SLOTS- FOR STATE PRESCHOOL
THESE ARE FULL DAY. FULL YEAR
SLOTS AND MOVES US CLOSER TO
THE GOVERNOR'S CALL FOR
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL FOR ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE CHILDREN AND
THAT WILL COME AT A COST OF
APPROXIMATELY. ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS. IN ADDITION
THE BUDGET CHANGES THE CAL CAL
WORKS CHILD SUPPORT PASSED
THROUGH SO THAT. FAMILIES
RECEIVING CHILD SUPPORT- WHO
ARE ON CAL WORKS INSTEAD OF
RECEIVING JUST FIFTY DOLLARS
BEING PASSED FOR IT WILL BE A
HUNDRED DOLLARS. AND THAT WILL
BE TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A- MORE.
CHILD IN THE VAN. IN ADDITION
BUILDING ON THE- OF THE
SURGEONS. OFFICE LAST YEAR.
THERE'S TEN MILLION. FOR ACROSS
PUBLIC AWARENESS AND TRAINING
CAMPAIGN. TO BUILD AWARENESS OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD- ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AND
MAKING SURE THE KIDS GET THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED-
BUILDING ON LAST YEAR'S
EXPANSION OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE-
WE ARE PROPOSING ADDITIONAL
CHOP PROTECTIONS TO MAKE SURE
THAT MORE PEOPLE. CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT WE'VE- AND
THEN FINALLY AS YOU ALL KNOW
THE MASTER PLAN FOR EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CONTINUING
THAT EFFORT TO COME UP WITH A
BROADER PLAN TO INTEGRATE ALL
THESE EFFORTS. WHEN IT COMES TO
K. TWELVE OR RATHER K.
FOURTEEN- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES THE HIGHEST EVER
VIABLE. PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT SPENDING. IT'S EIGHTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
APPROXIMATELY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS MORE THAN LAST YEAR.
AND WITHIN THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE THEIR
IMPORTANT INCREASES- AS THE
CHAIR MENTION IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND ADDITIONAL
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE DOLLARS. THERE'S A NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN THIS WILL GO OVER
SEVERAL SEVERAL YEARS. BUT FOR
TEACHER PREPARATION AND TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS. THERE'S
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON SCHOOLS
WITH THE GREATEST NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES. THERE ARE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AFTER
COMMUNITY SCHOOL GRANTS AND
THESE ARE SCHOOLS THAT
INTEGRATED EDUCATIONAL. AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WHICH I
ALSO KNOW IT'S BEEN A- SUBJECT
OF A LOT OF DISCUSSION IN THIS
COMMITTEE- AND THEN FINALLY
THERE'S AN INCREASE IN. MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SCHOOLS BY
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. MAIN TO INCREASE.
SUBSIDY FOR FREE REDUCED PRICE
AND FIRST. AND ALSO SO MONEY
FOR TO FOR CASH. WORKERS TO
HELP THEM LEARN HOW TO BETTER
PREPARE HEALTHIER MEALS- FOR
THE SCHOOL. AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO THAT THERE IS SOME
MONEY FOR COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION WHICH IS ALSO
PRIORITY OF THE GOVERNOR.
MOVING ON TO HIGHER EDUCATION-
THERE ARE 5% INCREASES FOR
ABOUT UC AND CSU. THAT ARE
BUILT INTO THE BUDGET- THERE'S
ALSO SPECIFIC ON GOING MONEY
FOR THE UC RIVERSIDE MEDICAL
SCHOOL- AS WELL AS FOR THE UC
AT UCSF FRESNO BRANCH CAMPUS
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THAT CAMPUS. TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ON GOING
FOR UC RIVERSIDE- AND IN
ADDITION ON THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL THERE'S EIGHTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS THIS IS
WITHIN PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT. FOR APPRENTICESHIPS AS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BROADER
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENDA.
AND THEN FINALLY- BECAUSE SO
MUCH THERE'S SO MUCH DISCUSSION
AROUND STUDENT AT. THE BUDGET
INCLUDES FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO MAKE
SURE MORE PEOPLE MORE BORROWERS
WERE STUDENTS KNOW ABOUT THEIR
DEBT REPAYMENT OPTIONS AND THAT
WE HAVE OUTREACH TO THOSE
PEOPLE. SO THAT THEY CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
AVAILABLE. AND THEN AS WE ALL
KNOW FINALLY THERE IS A SCHOOL
BOND. THAT WILL BE ON THE
BALLOT IN APPROXIMATELY FIVE OR
SIX WEEKS. THAT'S FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH NINE
BILLION IS FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE- AND THEN TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
TWO BILLION FOR YOU SEE AND TWO
BILLION FOR CSU. MOVING ON TO
HEALTH CARE THE FLAGSHIP IN
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING IS KNOWN AS THE
HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
INITIATIVE. AND THIS INITIATIVE
PROPOSES TO TRANSFORM OUR MEDI
CAL PROGRAMS FOCUS ON
INTEGRATING SERVICES. INCLUDING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE TREATING
THE WHOLE PERSON FOCUSING ON
VALUE BASED CARE AND-
DELIVERING ON PAYMENT REFORM.
AND WITHIN THAT THIS BUDGET
PUTS A LOT OF EMPHASIS ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- EVERYTHING
FROM SETTING UP A TASK FORCE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE- ALL
MOVING FORWARD TOGETHER-
PROVIDING THE RESOURCES TO
COUNTIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR EFFORTS ARE ALIGNED WITH
THE STATE'S HELP YOUR
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. EFFORTS
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN THE I.
S. T. THAT'S DEEMED COMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL POPULATION WHERE
THERE IS OFTEN OVERLAP WITH
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND
HOMELESSNESS NEEDS- AND THEN
FINALLY- THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL PROPOSE THIS SPRING- SOME
REFORMS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN TREAT THAT. A RANGE OF
PEOPLE PROVIDE THEM ALL THE
SERVICES THEY NEED. THE
MINISTER IS ALSO PROPOSED AND
NOT OF CON. IN THE AREA
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS- RANGING
FROM THE MEDI CAL BEST PRICE
ALLOWING MEDICAL TO CONSIDER
INTERNATIONAL PRICES WHEN THEY
DO THEIR BARGAINING. TO THE
STATE ESTABLISHING ITS OWN CAL
OUR ACTS PRESCRIPTION DRUG
LABEL- TO CONTRACT WITH A
MANUFACTURER IS FOR THE
PROVISION OF GENERIC DRUGS.
SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS ARE
REALLY FIRST IN THE NATION
CALIFORNIA'S TAKING THE LEAD
CERTAINLY ON THE SCALE. SO THE
MINISTRATION- WE WILL REQUIRE
SOME ADDITIONAL TIME TO FLESH
OUT SOME OF THE DETAILS BUT WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE. TO PUT
THAT OUT THERE AND HAVE YOUR
FEEDBACK AND DISCUSS THIS WITH
ALL OF YOU. AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCES. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
PROPOSING AT TAX ON DATING THIS
TO BE. A TWO DOLLAR TAX PER
FORTY MILLIGRAMS. AND THIS IS
TO COME BACK THE DATING APP
ATOMIC THAT SO MANY OF YOU ARE
AWARE US. MOVING ON TO THE AREA
OF FOOD AND SECURITY. WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
CHANGES AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THAT IMPACTS OUR CALPERS
PROGRAM AND SOME RULES BEING
ISSUED OR ABOUT TO BE ISSUED.
SO FOR THAT REASON THIS BUDGET
PROPOSES TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME FOR FOOD BANKS TO
HELP- WITH SOME OF THAT PEOPLE
WHO MAY NOT BE RESERVING THE
SERVICES THAT THEY WERE
PREVIOUSLY RECEIVING. A AND
THEN IN ADDITION FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO IMPROVE THE
CALIFORNIA WEBSITE. SO THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ENROLL MORE OF THE
POPULATION THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR THESE FEDERAL BENEFITS.
THIS BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES A
GREAT BIG EXPANSION OF THE MEDI
CAL PROGRAM. TO INCLUDE
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS WERE
AGED SIXTY FIVE AND ABOVE. I
KNOW THAT'S BEEN A PRIORITY OF
MANY MEMBERS INCLUDING ON THIS
COMMITTEE. AND SO THAT THIS
BUDGET OUTSIDE AND AT A COST OF
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. IN THE YEAR
AND THAT WILL GROW THIS IS
GENERAL FUND WILL GROW TO
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE DOLLARS ON IT ON.
THE BASIS IN THE OUT YEARS. AND
THEN FINALLY IS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED THAT THERE WAS A
HEARING ON DDS YESTERDAY.
BUDGET TEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR AND- FOR THREE
ADDITIONAL SERVICE CODES. AS
WELL AS SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THAT PERFORMANCE GRANT
FUNDING AND MORE DETAILS. OF
THOSE PROPOSALS WILL BE
AVAILABLE IN THE WEEKS TO COME.
ON HOMELESSNESS WAS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED THIS IS BECAUSE THIS
IS A BIG PRIORITY FOR THE
GOVERNOR AND HE'S BEEN OUT ON
THE ROAD INCLUDING TODAY- ON
THIS ISSUE- THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
THAT CAME OUT THE FIRST WEEK OF
JANUARY- TALKED ABOUT THE-
DEPLOYMENT OF TRAILERS AND
MEDICAL TENDS. TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING ALL THE RESOURCES
OUT THERE THAT WE CAN. BUY IN
ADDITION AS THE TURN NOTED THIS
BUDGET PROPOSES A CALIFORNIA
ACCESS TO HOUSING AND SERVICES
FIND FUNDED WITH SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN MONEY
TO PROVIDE A REGIONAL APPROACH
AT THE MINISTRY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND THIS WOULD BE TO STABILIZE
BOARD IN CARE HOMES DEVELOP
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS
AND THEN FINALLY PROVIDE RENTAL
SUBSIDIES TO PEOPLE IN NEED.
THIS BUDGET ALSO DOUBLES DOWN
ON SOME OF THE BIG HOUSING
INVESTMENTS THAT WERE- IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET INCLUDING ANOTHER
ROUND OF FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN TAX CREDITS. DESPITE
THE GOVERNOR IS ALSO GONE OUT
AND SECURED FUNDING HELP THAT
ARE CAUSING CRISIS. NOW TO
ABOUT FOUR AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS AND THEN PUSHING FOR IN
TERMS OF THAT ACCESS LAND IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE USE THAT
ACCESS STATE LAND FOR HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS WAS THIS NEED.
THE GOVERNOR'S ALSO SIGNALED
THAT HE'S OPEN TO THE CREATION
OF A UNIFIED HOUSING AND HOME
SAFETY SO THAT ALL OF OUR- IN
THIS AREA EVEN FOR A WIND. SURE
THAT WILL BE A DISK WITH ALL IN
THE WEEKS AND MONTHS TO COME.
WAY UP. WANT TO. CLIMATE TWELVE
FIRE IN EMERGENCIES THERE'S A
LOT IN THIS AREA ALL JUST TALK
ON THE VERY BRIEF HIGHER THEY-
GOVERNOR PROPOSED WHAT CALLING
A- BY. OF TWELVE AND A HALF.
DOLLARS OVERALL THIS IS A THREE
PART STRUCTURE PART ONE IS-
FOUR POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. CLIMATE RESILIENCE
BOND WITH THE MAJORITY OF THAT
BOND FOCUSED ON WATER NEEDS
WHETHER FLOOD. DROUGHT DRINKING
WATER- BUT ALSO SEE LEVEL RICE
AND EXTREME HEAT AND DEALING
WITH ALL THOSE CHALLENGES. THE
GOVERNOR'S ALSO PROPOSED OVER
THE NEXT FOUR YEARS INVESTING
ONE BILLION DOLLARS CLIMATE
CATALYST FUND- AND THIS IS TO
INVEST IN SPECIFIC PRIORITIES.
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION WASTE
DIVERSION AND SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE WHERE WE THINK
THERE ARE GAPS IN THE MARKET
THERE ARE PROVING
COMMERCIALISED TECHNOLOGIES.
THAT ARE GETTING THE FINANCING
THAT THEY NEED. FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS AND THAT CAN HELP A
SECURE CLIMATE GOALS. AND THEN
FINALLY OUR- CAP AND TRADE
PLAN- WE ARE PROJECTING LOWER
CAP AND TRADE REVENUE THAN WE
DID THE PREVIOUS YEAR. BUT EVEN
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING A CAP AND
TRADE DISCRETIONARY PLAN OF
NEARLY ONE BILLION DOLLARS. A
AND IN ADDITION TO THIS THE
BUDGET INCLUDES INVESTMENTS IN
WATER RESULT OF RESILIENCE AND
SIGMA SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT. IMPLEMENTATION
DGSE REFORM AS WELL AS ACCESS
TO PARKS IN EQUITY GRANTS FOR
PARKS AS WELL AS FUNDING TO
PURCHASE A NEW STATE PARK AND
EXPAND OUR STATE PARKS IT.
SPEAK TO ON LAW FIRE BUT- IT'S
A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE DOLLARS
FOR COPS. HE TOWARDS PASS. AS
WELL YOU'RE STAFF. RELIEF FOR.
ZERO ENGINE. I WAS EIGHT FIND
OUT. WHY CHECK NOT TO HELP WITH
ALL. THAT MANAGEMENT. THERE'S
ALSO THE WALL FARM PRODUCTION
FOR. ON TOP OF- YOU FUNDING FOR
YES AND FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE ASSISTS FOR POWER
SHUT OFFS LIKE THE TYPE WE
EXPERIENCED LAST FALL. AND THIS
WILL HELP US MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE GETTING ALL THE INFORMATION
INTO ONE SINGLE HOT. AND THAT
THE STATE CAN RESPOND AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AND THEN
ON EMERGENCIES THERE'S ALSO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR CYBER
SECURITY WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE GOVERNOR
SPECIFICALLY THE CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER. AND THE
JOINT INCIDENTS RESPONSE TEAM
AS WELL AS SEISMIC SAFETY FOR
EARTHQUAKES AND THIS BUDGET
INCLUDES SOME MONEY TO MOVE
THAT SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION.
INTO THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES SO THAT THERE'S
GREATER ALIGNMENT. THE LAST TWO
AREAS I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
NUMBER ONE IS CRIMINAL JUSTICE-
THAT. GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED
THAT IF CURRENT POPULATION
TRENDS CONTINUE. HE INTENDS TO
CLOSE A STATE PRISON WITHIN THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. AND IN ORDER
TO DELIVER ON THAT GOAL IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THAT
BUDGET FOCUS ON REHABILITATION
EFFORTS INTO THE BUDGET
INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES. IN THAT REGARD
ESPECIALLY FOR YOUNGER
OFFENDERS THOSE UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY SIX TO CLUSTER THEM
IN SPECIFIC AREAS WHERE THEY
CAN RECEIVE INTENSIVE SERVICES.
THE BUDGET CONTINUES ON THE
LAST COMMITMENT. TO MOVE THAT
DEPART DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE CHANGES TO DEPARTMENT
OF YOU THINK ANY RESTORATION
MOVING TO HHS- THAT SHOULD GO
INTO EFFECT ON JULY FIRST OF
THIS YEAR. THERE'S ALSO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH CSU IN HIGHER
EDUCATION AND OUR STATE PRISON
SYSTEM. AS WELL AS TECHNOLOGY
FOR INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
AND FINALLY TRAINING FOR STAFF
TO THE C. R. AS WELL. AN
IMPORTANT PRIORITY OF THIS
BUDGET. IS TO EXPAND LAST
YEAR'S PILOT ON FINES AND FEES
AND REDUCING THE BURDEN
SPECIFICALLY ON LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS WERE INTERACTING
WITH THE COURT SYSTEM. SO THIS
BUDGET PROPOSES ELEVEN AND A
HALF NO DOLLARS. TO EXPAND THAT
PROGRAM STATEWIDE AND EXPANDED
ON SIMPLY TRAFFIC FINES AND
FEES. WEEKS THAT'LL HAPPEN FIND
OUR- FORECAST. PRO TO. FIFTY
SIX POINT. THE OUT YEARS AND
THAT IS FINE WITH THAT BAKER
INVEST IN THE TRIAL COURT'S IS
CHEN OVER A HUNDRED. MILLION
DOLLAR. THE RESULT A BOLD
PROPOSE ON THIS BUDGET ON
PROBATION WHICH IS A
COMBINATION OF SHORTENING
PROBATION TERMS TO TWO YEARS.
BUT ALSO PUTTING IN- SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN EACH OF THE
NEXT THREE YEARS FOR INTENSIVE
SERVICES BECAUSE EVIDENCE SHOWS
THAT THAT IS REALLY WHERE. YOU
WANT TO FOCUS IF YOU WANT TO
REDUCE RATES OF RECIDIVISM AND
DELIVER SERVICES TO PEOPLE WHEN
THEY NEED THEM. THERE'S ALSO
ADDITIONAL MONEY IN THIS BUDGET
FOR POST RELEASE COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION- AND THEN THE FINAL
AREAS ALL TALK ABOUT IN PUBLIC
SAFETY MORE TALK MORE BROADLY
ARE NUMBER ONE. THE CREATION OF
A CALIFORNIA CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION LAW THE GOVERNOR IS
WORRIED THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS STEPPED BACK IN
THIS AREA WHEN IT COMES TO
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION.
AND THE FEDERAL CFPB SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING AUGMENTING
DEPARTMENT AT THE OVERSIGHT.
GREEN. THING AT THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL PROTECTION. STATION BUT
MORE THAN THE REMAINING. ADDING
ADDITIONAL. A KEEP. AND GIVING
THAT ASIAN THAT DEPARTMENT THE
AUTHORITY TO REGULATE DEBT
COLLECTORS- SO WE THINK THIS IS
AN AREA WHERE CALIFORNIA CAN
REALLY LEAD THE WAY. IN ABSENCE
OF FEDERAL EFFORT. AND THEN
FINALLY IN CANNABIS- THERE IS-
REORGANIZATION PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. RIGHT NOW
SOME OF THE REGULATORY AND
ENFORCEMENT FUNCTIONS ARE
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE BUREAU
OF CANNABIS CONTROL. THAT
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- THIS PROPOSAL PROPOSES
BRING ALL OF THOSE INTO A
SINGLE DEPARTMENT. WITHIN THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY. AND THEN WHEN
IT COMES TO JOB CREATION- THE
GOVERNOR'S BEEN OUT THERE AND
WE ALL KNOW THAT OUR BUDGET-
DEPENDS ON CONTINUALLY GROWING
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND IT'S
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION. THAT THAT
GROWTH BE SEEN IN ALL PARTS OF
THE STATE STATE NOT SIMPLY ON
THE COAST. SO THE GOVERNOR HAS
TO PROPOSALS HERE ONE IS TO PUT
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT STAFF.
IN AREAS OF THE STATE WHERE WE
GENERALLY SEEN ECONOMIC GROWTH
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN LESS THAN
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN OUR
WEALTHIER COASTAL AREAS. SO
WE'RE GONNA PUT STAFF IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN THE ILAND
EMPIRE ON THE CENTRAL COAST AND
IN THE NORTH OF CALIFORNIA
NORTH OF HERE. TO HELP MAKE THE
CASE FOR WHY BUSINESSES SHOULD
RELOCATE AND TRAIN AND HIRE
WORKERS OVER THERE. IN ADDITION
TO PROMOTE SMALL BUSINESS
CREATION THIS BUDGET INCLUDES
OF. EXEMPTION FROM THE STATE'S
MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX SO THAT'S
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE NOT CORPORATIONS
BECAUSE CORPORATION ALREADY TO
RECEIVE THIS EXEMPTION. SEVERAL
LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANIES AND
PARTNERSHIPS THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO GET THE BEST. OFF THE ABOUT
THIS EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLAR
CHARGE. IN THE VERY NEAR. OF
THESE PIECES BUT PEACE WITH
GOVERNOR FIVE YOUR- PLAN WHICH
AMONG OTHER THINGS. PUTS NEW
PUTS MONEY INTO BROADBAND SO
THAT WERE NAPPING STATED
ACTIVITY ALL ACROSS THE STATE
IN THE SURE THAT. STOCK IS TO
THIS SOUL RESEARCH. TO THE KEY
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE BUDGET ONCE
JUST SIMPLY. SOME OF THE
GOVERNOR PRIORITIES I KNOW
THERE MAY BE OTHERS BUT- AFTER
LA HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
I THAT YES COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
TO HOLD OUR- AND THE LA HIS AT
THE- PRESENT TO PRESENT AND
BEFORE YOU GET. SIR IF YOU
WOULD ALLOW US TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTERS MITCHELL HERE. NIELSEN
YOUR SELF. A COUPLE AIR. DOLLY.
FOR TITLE JONES. LEYVA MCGUIRE
MORNING YOUR MORE LOCK. PAN
HERE ROTH YOUR SKINNER HERE
STERN HERE'S A BURKE. AYE
CASKEY. IF. DID YOU GET THROUGH
THE BILL HE HE WITH HIS RIGHT
BEHIND YOU UNCHARACTERISTICALLY
QUIET I HEARD YOU I HEARD YOU
BUT I WASN'T SURE SHE DID HE'S
HERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ESTABLISH A QUORUM- CEPEK HAPPY
NEW YEAR AND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM CHAIR
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANKS
FOR HAVING ME HERE THIS MORNING
TODAY WHAT I WAS HOPING TO DO
IS. CONCENTRATE MY REMARKS IN
THREE MAIN AREAS TO HELP THINK
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL THAT- WE
JUST. HEARD A DESCRIPTION OF.
TO THE FIRST WOULD BE- I WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE A COMMON ON
KIND OF THE OVERALL BUDGET
STRUCTURE INCLUDING THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
BUDGET. UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. THE SECOND AREA IT IS
TO OFFER SOME COMMENTS ON SOME
OF THE KEY CHOICES AS WE SEE
THEM- WITHIN THE BUDGET
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO THE
STATE'S ESTIMATED DISCRETIONARY
RESOURCES. AND THEN THIRD- I
WOULD JUST OFFER A VIEW OF.
WHAT THE WHOLE PACKAGE AND WHAT
ITS IMPLICATIONS ARE FOR THE
STATE'S BUDGET CONDITION AND
ITS MULTI YEAR FISCAL OUTLOOK.
SO WITH THAT IF YOU HAVE THE
HANDOUT. HELLO MOVE ON TO THE
FIRST PAGE. AND HERE I'LL BEGIN
WITH PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
NO ADDRESS IT SEPARATELY
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW
PROPOSITION. NINETY EIGHT UNDER
THE STATE CONSTITUTION
ESTABLISHES THE MINIMUM FUNDING
LEVEL FOR SCHOOLS. AND AS WE
ALREADY HEARD- IN THE IN THE
COMING BUDGET YEAR THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES EIGHTY FOUR BILLION
FOR THE TOTAL PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT BUDGET. NOW OF
THIS THERE'S ABOUT DID THIS
REPRESENTS A TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE FROM
THE CURRENT YEAR. AND OF THAT
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES. ALLOCATING
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION TO NEW
ONGOING SPENDING PRIMARILY TO
FIND THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT. IN THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. AND
THEN HE HOLDS ONE POINT ONE
BILLION IN ALLOCATE STAFF FOR
ONE TIME PURPOSES. WE THINK
THAT THAT SPLIT IS PRUDENT.
BECAUSE IT WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
BUDGET THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT BUDGET TO ACCOMMODATE A
DECLINE IN THE GUARANTEE LEVEL-
WITHOUT NECESSARILY NEEDING TO
MAKE CUTS TO ONGOING PROGRAMS.
A COUPLE OF OTHER COMMENTS THAT
WE HAVE IS THAT ALTHOUGH. MANY
OF THE PROPOSALS ARE IN THE ONE
TIME- CATEGORY. B. ADDRESS IN
MANY CASES THEY ADDRESS SOME
LONG STANDING ISSUES FACING
EDUCATION AND FACING THE STATE.
AND SO YOU KNOW WE JUST THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO CONSIDER WHETHER SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT THEY- HAVE PROPOSED
TO ADDRESS. ARE ACTUALLY BETTER
SUITED FOR- TO BE SUPPORTED BY
A ONGOING FUNDING. THE SECOND.
AREA THAT I WOULD MENTION IN
THIS- PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT.
SECTION IS JUST EXCUSE ME. THIS
IS JUST THE- WHETHER OR NOT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD PREFER TO
REPURPOSE SOME OF THE ONE TIME
FUNDING IN THE AREAS OF THE
STATES THAT THE DISTRICTS IN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS LONG TERM
LIABILITIES AND THAT WOULD BE
ONE CONSIDERATION IF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTED TO MAXIMIZE
THE FISCAL IMPACT FOR THE
DISTRICTS OVER THE LONGER TERM.
YOU CAN SO MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT SLIDE HERE REALLY MOVING
PAST THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT- PORTION OF THE OF THE
BUDGET SOME REALLY TALKING
ABOUT EVERYTHING ELSE WITHIN
THE PROPOSITION- WITHIN THE
WITHIN THE BUDGET YOU'LL NOTE
HERE AT THE TOP OF THE SLIDE WE
REFER TO A SIX BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS. AND IN THIS CONTEXT
WHEN I SEE SURPLUS WHAT I MEAN
BY THAT IS THE AMOUNT OF
ESTIMATED RESOURCES. ABOVE WHAT
THE STATE WILL NEED TO FIND ITS
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS.
AND IT'S EXISTING PROGRAM
COMMITMENTS. SO ONE THING ABOUT
THAT IS THAT IT'S VERY SIMILAR
TO THE SURPLUS THAT WE ESTIMATE
FOR THE COMING YEAR- IN THE
REASON THAT IT'S SO SIMILAR IS
THAT WE HAVE VERY SIMILAR
REVENUE ESTIMATES IN FACT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS ONLY
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR MILLION IN%
HIGHER REVENUES IN THE BIG
THREE REVENUES THAT OUR OFFICE
SO THEY'RE VERY SIMILAR
CELESTIN. POINT 1% OF- GEN OF
THOSE REVENUES. ONE OTHER
OBSERVATION THAT YOU'LL NOTE IN
THE BUDGET IS THAT THERE ARE
RELATIVELY HIGH NUMBER OF SMALL
PROGRAM SO WHEN I SAY SMALL
PROGRAMS IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
BUDGET. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PROGRAMS WERE A PROPOSALS WORTH
LESS THAN A HUNDRED BILLION
HUNDRED MILLION. AND OVER 95%
OF THE PROPOSALS ARE ACTUALLY
FOR LESS THAN THAT AMOUNT SO
THAT'S A NOTABLE FEATURE OF THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL. GOING TO THE
NEXT SLIDE HERE WERE DISPLAYING
IN THE FIGURE OUT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES TO ALLOCATE FOUR POINT
ONE BILLION. IN THE SURPLUS
ACROSS VARIOUS PROGRAM AREAS.
AND YOU'LL SEE THAT AT A HIGH
LEVEL. MUCH OF THE ONE TIME
ALLOCATIONS ARE GOING TOWARD
ADDRESSING THE HOMELESSNESS-
ISSUE AS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR. WE'RE AS MUCH OF THE
ONGOING FUNDING GOES FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION AND HEALTH CARE. AND
IF YOU THINK ABOUT MY POINT ON
THE PREVIOUS SLIDE. THAT
THEY'RE A HIGH NUMBER OF
RELATIVELY SMALL PROPOSALS.
THIS PRISON THIS RAISES
SOMEWHAT OF A TRADE OFF FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER WHETHER
IT WOULD FIRST PREFER TO PURSUE
THAT APPROACH OR IF YOU WOULD
RATHER DIRECT. YOU KNOW MORE OF
ITS RESOURCES TO A FEWER NUMBER
OF BIGGER TICKET ITEMS AND SO
THAT SORT OF ONE OF THE BIGGER
CHOICES FACING THE LEGISLATURE
IS A COASTER THAT GOES THROUGH
THIS BUDGET. ANOTHER POINT IS
THAT WHEN YOU TAKE THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL IN ITS ENTIRETY WE
BELIEVE THAT IT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO EXERT UPWARD
PRESSURE ON THE STATE'S COST
STRUCTURE OVER THE LONG TERM.
IN WAYS THAT GO BEYOND WATER
INCLUDED IN THESE ESTIMATES. SO
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION IN NEW ONGOING
SPENDING AND WE CAN ESTIMATE
THAT WOULD INCREASE TO ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION OVER TIME.
BUT THEN HE DOES ALSO PROPOSE
FOR THE STATE TO ENGAGE IN NEW
ACTIVITIES AND AS- AN AS WE
HEARD SOME OF SOME OF THESE
ARE- REALLY BOLD AND IT WILL IN
A WAY AND GO BEYOND. WHAT OTHER
STATES HAVE EVEN DONE IN THE
AREA OF PRESCRIPTION DRUGS FOR
EXAMPLE. NOW MANY OF THESE
IDEAS MAY HAVE MERIT. AND THEY
MAY BE. WORTH CONSIDERING BUT
WE JUST THINK THAT THERE'S THE
POTENTIAL THAT THEY WOULD
INCREASE COSTS TO THE STATE ON
AN ONGOING BASIS OVER THE LONG
TERM AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU SHOULD BE AWARE OF. AND WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION
AT THIS POINT TO. DETERMINE THE
PRECISE AMOUNT. NOW IN THE NEXT
SLIDE WHAT I'M SHOWING HERE IS
A CHART THAT- DISPLAYS. THE
GOVERNOR'S. PLAN OVER A MULTI
YEAR OUTLOOK. AND WHAT YOU
WOULD SEE FROM THIS IF I COULD
DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
DARKER SHADED PARTS OF THE BLUE
BARS YOU WOULD SEE THAT THERE
ARE SURPLUSES IN THE FUTURE
YEARS BUT THE SURPLUS IS A
RELATIVELY SMALL. FURTHERMORE
THEY DEPEND ON THREE KEY
ASSUMPTIONS ONE IS THAT THE
ECONOMY CONTINUES TO GROW. THE
SECOND IS THAT THE MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION TAX IS APPROVED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT-
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND THEN FINALLY
THAT THE SUSPENDED PROGRAMS
THAT WERE ALREADY MENTIONED
THAT THOSE SUSPENSIONS DO TAKE
A FACT IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. AND IN FACT IF YOU. YES
IF THOSE SUSPENSIONS DID NOT
TAKE AFFECTING AS YOU RECALL
FROM LAST BUDGET PROCESS WE
QUESTIONED WHETHER THE PROGRAMS
THAT WERE FUNDED WITH THE
SUSPENSION PROVISIONS WERE
REALLY- APPROPRIATE TO HAVE-
THE SUSPENSION LANGUAGE IN THEM
AND IF THOSE SUSPENSIONS DID
NOT TAKE EFFECT AND THE OUT
YEAR WOULD ACTUALLY SHOW
DEFICIT SO THAT'S SOMETHING TO
BE AWARE OF. SO ON THE FINAL
PAGE ALEVIATE YOU WITH A
COUPLE OF THOUGHTS THE FIRST IS
JUST THAT- IF YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT THE
TOTAL LEVEL OF RESERVES. SHOWN
IN THE BUDGET OUR. WHETHER THE
TOTAL LEVEL ELEVEN RESERVE
SHOWN IN THE BUDGET ARE. IT'S
SATISFACTORY TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S. PREFERENCES FOR
ONE THING THE GOVERNOR DOES NOT
ADD TO THE DISCRETIONARY LEVEL
OF RESERVES IN THIS BUDGET AND
ALTHOUGH THERE IS AN INCREASE
UNDER THE PROPOSITION TO A
REQUIREMENTS THERE'S NO ADDED
LEVEL OF RESERVE IN THE
DISCRETIONARY PORTION. SO
ANOTHER WAY TO BUILD BUDGET
RESILIENCE WOULD BE TO INCREASE
THE STATE'S OPERATING SURPLUS
FROM WHAT IS CURRENTLY PROPOSED
WE MENTIONED IN NOVEMBER THAT
NO MORE THAN ONE BILLION SHOULD
SEE SHOULD BE SPENT ON. NEW
ONGOING PURPOSES GIVEN OUR
OUTLOOK AND THE GOVERNOR SPEND
A BIT MORE THAN THAT AND WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT THE RISK OF A
RECESSION COMING IN THE- OVER
THE OUTLOOK PERIOD WE THINK IT
IS SOMEWHAT ELEVATED GIVEN SOME
OF THE INDICATIONS THAT WE SEE
NOW AND THE FACT THAT THE MID
THE ECONOMIC EXPANSION IS QUITE
MATURE AT THIS POINT. AND SO
GIVEN THAT WE THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER LARGER RESERVES FOR
THE LARGER OPERATING SURPLUS
EITHER WAY WE THINK THIS THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER
CONTINUING TO BUILD THE STATE'S
FISCAL RESILIENCE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I SEE SENATOR RALPH
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR MORLOCK
SENATOR OFF. THE MANAGER OF CAN
EITHER OF YOU- FIGURE THIS OUT
CAN EITHER OF YOU TELL ME WHAT
THE FISCAL IMPACT OF THE
FAILURE PROVES THE EXTENSION OF
THE MCO. TAX IS ON THE BUDGET
IN TERMS OF DOLLARS. YEAH I'M
HAPPY TO DO THAT IT WOULD BE SO
WE ARE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS YEAH
SO- WE'RE NOT ASSUMING IT FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR ABOUT WERE IT
NOT TO BE APPROVED- IT WOULD BE
IN EXCESS OF A BILLION DOLLARS
ON IN ANY. AND THEN SHIFTING
GEARS TO. K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION YOU KNOW CONSIDERING
THE COLA THE SIZE OF THE COLA
OR SOME WOULD SAY THE LACK OF
THE SIZE THE COLA AND THE
ROUGHLY NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS PROGRAM TO PROPOSED
FOR- TEACHER RECRUITMENT IN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
OTHER THINGS OVER OVER TIME.
AND TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACED NOW
AND WILL BE PHASED IN THE
FUTURE BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WHICH WITH REGARD TO. DISTRICTS
PORTION OF THE UNFUNDED PENSION
LIABILITY. WAS ANY THOUGHT
GIVEN TO INCREASING THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY FLOWING TO DISTRICTS
OR TWO COASTERS FOR OF.
UNFUNDED LIABILITY BY DOWN. YES
ALL MAKE A ONE OR TWO POINTS
AND MY COLLEAGUE JESSICA MAIL
OPERATE AS WELL I THINK THE
FIRST THING IS THAT THE PAYMENT
THAT WAS MADE LAST YEAR OF
APPROXIMATELY AT THREE A LITTLE
OVER THREE TWO THREE BILLION
DOLLARS ON THAT WAS INTENDED TO
FLOW AND THAT IF IT DISTRICTS
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS AND NOT
JUST IN INTENT THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE HOPE WILL HAPPEN BUT IN THE
WAY THAT IT WAS STRUCTURED IN
SO THE WAY THAT THREE POINT ONE
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS WAS WAS TO
HELP BY DOWN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CONTRIBUTIONS. IN THE CURRENT
YEAR OR THE YEAR WE'RE IN RIGHT
NOW BUT THEN ALSO A PORTION OF
THAT OF SEVERAL HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WAS TO BE FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR SO FOR THIS YEAR TO
CALM AND VAST MAJORITY OF THAT
MONEY TWO POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS WAS DEPOSITED TO CAL
STIRS FOR THE LONG TERM SO THAT
SHOULD REDUCE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CONTRIBUTIONS WHENEVER YOU'RE
TO CALM OVER THE NEXT TWENTY
YEARS AND SO WE PUT THAT THAT
PROVIDE SOME RELIEF AND IT YOU
KNOW. WAIT FOR LAW SCHOOL
DISTRICT DOESN'T COULD NOT BUT
THINK MAKE A DIFFERENCE OVER
THE LONG TERM I THINK THE
SECOND THING IS- THIS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT LEVEL-
IT HAS THAT CALL UP VER 2%
THAT YOU MENTION FOR LCS FAST
AND WE PUT IT ALL TOGETHER-
EVEN AGAINST THE ADJUSTED
LEVELS LAST YEAR IT'S
ADDITIONAL TWO AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS SO WE THINK
THAT MAKES A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT.
THERE WAS MY FOR TO WHAT YEAR
AND THEN THE SEDITION ALL NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THIS
YEAR AND THEN THE LAST THING
I'LLMENTION- BECAUSE WE DID IT
LAST YEAR BUT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT FOR THIS YEAR IS THIS
EXPANSION OF STATE SCHOOL
PROGRAM- IT'S FOR NON ALLEY A
SPORTS FULL DAY FOR YOUR
PRESCHOOL- THAT WAS PULLED OUT
OF THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE LAST YEAR- AND SO
THAT IT TOO TIONAL TEN THOUSAND
SLOTS THAT WE'RE PROPOSING TO
FUNDS THIS YEAR WHICH COMES AT
A COST OF OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. ON THAT WILL
BE IN ADDITION TO THE IGHTY
FOUR GOING DOLLARS IN PROPERTY
NINE EIGHT FUNDING SO WE THAT
MY IS TIGHT AS FOR MANY
DISTRICTS BUT WE THINK ALL THE
IN TO GET WHAT CAN AND YOU WANT.
I JUST CALLED. PERMANENT
FINANCING. THE CAR. AND ROTH I
WOULD ALSO ADD. HEAD TO THE X.
AS IN THAT IN A TO THOSE IN THE-
WE ALSO. ROLLING OVER THIS
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION WE
PROVIDED YEAR FOR ED. INTO
INCREASING THE BASE GRAND FOR
ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS- IN
ADDITION WE'RE ADDING ANOTHER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
ON TOP OF THAT FOR ON THE
EARLIEST LEARNERS BUT
DISABILITIES. I'M SO THOSE ARE
INCREASES FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT SHOULD HELP THEM ADDRESS
SOME OF THE COSTS THAT THEY'RE
SEEING WITH SPECIAL EDUCATION.
I THINK THE OTHER THING THAT WE
HAD IN MIND IN TERMS OF
BUILDING AND QUITE A BIT OF ONE
TIME- INTO OUR ON GOING WAS AS
AND FEEDBACK WE GOT FROM
DISTRICTS AROUND WHAT
INFORMATION IT IS THAT WE PUT
OUT ABOUT COLA- AT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND HOW AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE PUT OUT A COLA
ON THE SAY LIKE WHAT WITH
SOMEONE CALL A SUPER COLA
LARGER THAN THAT THE STATUTORY
COLA. ON TO THE EXTENT THAT
THAT IS THEN CUT MI REVISION-
WHEN REVENUES IF REVENUES DROP-
THAT THAT IS IT MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND TO BUDGET BECAUSE OF THE
TIMING OF EVERYTHING. SO THOSE
WERE OTHER THINGS THAT WE WERE
KEEPING IN MIND WE WERE
BUILDING THIS BUDGET. WELL I
REALIZE IT'S NEVER ENOUGH
MONEY. THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE SAY
AND IT'S PROBABLY TRUE WHEN IT
COMES TO SEVERAL THINGS IN
CALIFORNIA BUDGET WILL CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION CERTAINLY ONE
AREA WHERE WE CAN. THIS IS COOL
TRICKS UP AND DOWN THE STATE IS
IN. CONTINUE INCREASED FUND FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND- I
SUSPECT THAT IT IS TRUE AND
THEY TELL ME THAT YOU KNOW THE
FUNDING THAT THEY RECEIVE IS
ONLY ABOUT 40% DEPEND ON THE
DISTRICT OF THE- PER. SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. YOUNG PEOPLE SO. TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE IS
ADDITIONAL MONEY AVAILABLE IN
THE BUDGET THAT WE CAN RE
DIRECT. TO DISTRICTS. TO HELP
THEM COVER THE COST OF. SPECIAL
EDUCATION WHICH THEY OTHERWISE
HAVE TO PULL OUT OF THERE.
GENERAL FUND- WILL HELP AS WELL
SO WILL CONTINUE TO THE
CONVERSATION I. APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSE IN THE PRESENTATION
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SIR SENATOR MORE LOT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR JUST A FEW QUICK
QUESTIONS IF I. IF I COULD-
JUST GOING HISTORICALLY WEAK WE
KEEP REFERRING TO THE POTENTIAL
OF A RECESSION. AND WHEN WE
WENT THROUGH. OTHER
RECESSIONARY PERIODS LIKE THE
GREAT RECESSION THE STATE. HAD
A HABIT OF TAKING MONEY FROM
LOCAL- CITIES AND COUNTIES.
KIND OF A DYSFUNCTIONAL HABIT
BUT THAT'S JUST HOW IT HAPPENED
THROUGH. EITHER TAKING OF FUNDS
OR- REALIGNMENT HER OTHER.
STRATEGIES SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
ARE HAVE HAS THIS STATE REALLY
PAID. ALL OF OUR CITIES IN CAP
THIS. HE AT HAVE OCCURRED. TEN
YEARS AGO DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION. YOU'RE TALKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT BORROWING
FROM CITIES AND COUNTIES RIGHT
YES SO- I WILL NEED TO DOUBLE
THAT DEBT REPAYMENTS THAT
OCCURRED OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS WITH THE WALL JACK
INCLUDING IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET- THERE MAY BE SOME
OUTSTANDING- MANDATE SIR YOU
KNOW AND CERTAIN PAYMENT SO
I'LL HAVE TO DOUBLE CHECK ON
THAT ISSUE AND GET BACK TO YOU.
I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
PROTECT FOR PROVIDING AT IN
THIS. STUDY THAT THE DEFINITION
OF WHAT A SURPLUS IS AND SO I
JUST KIND OF LOOKING AT
SACRAMENTO ON THEM LOOKING AT
ALL THE CITIES AND COUNTIES.
THEY HAVE ISSUES OF DEBT- THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AND- HE IT
WAS SORT OF MENTIONED IN TRYING
TO DO MORE IN YOUR OTHER
REPORTS. FOR SCHOOLS WERE
ACTUALLY FOR THE STATE IN
SCHOOLS TO PUT MORE MONEY IN
THE PENSION PLANS SO I WAS JUST
WONDERING IS AS THE STATE
ENJOYS A- SURPLUS. WHY DON'T WE
HAVE LIKE A AN ALLOCATION TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES. AND THEN.
REQUIRE THAT THEY GET OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE SHARE BASED ON A
FORMULA POPULATION OR WHATEVER
AND THEN THAT MONEY JUST GOES
INTO THEIR PENSION PLAN SO THAT
IN GOOD TIMES WERE SORT OF
HELPING OUT CITIES AND COUNTIES
SO THAT. WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO COME TO THEM IN BAD
TIMES. IF WE NEED. SOME KIND OF
CASH TO GET THROUGH A RECESSION
BECAUSE OUR- TAXING SYSTEM IS
MUCH MORE VOLATILE THAN A
PROPERTY TAX SYSTEM. RESERVE
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT WHY AREN'T
WE- BECAUSE IT IT SEEMS LIKE
THE STATE IS TALKING SURPLUS
AND CITIES. ARE ARE TALKING
FINANCIAL SCARCITY I MEAN WE'VE
WE HAD A BILL THAT ASKS FOR
EMERYVILLE IN SCOTTS VALLEY TO
INCREASE THEIR SALES TAX WHICH
THE GOVERNOR VETOED BUT- THOSE
CITIES OUR MESSAGING. SOME AND
WE GOT A BUT YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
HELP OUT. I'LL MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS AND I KNOW I WAY I MAY
HAVE SOME AS WELL I THINK FIRST
IS THAT- WITH THE SURPLUS BOTH
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR- THERE
CERTAINLY WAS. IN ADDITION TO
THE CONSTITUTIONAL AND
GOVERNANCE OF RELATIONS BETWEEN
THE STATE AND CITIES AND
COUNTIES- WITH REGARD TO
REALIGNMENT THAT YOU MENTIONED
THERE WAS AN ADDITIONAL MONEY
IN THE BUDGET THAT FLOW
DIRECTLY TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
IN SPECIFICALLY. ON THE ISSUE
OF HOMELESSNESS ALONE IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS OVER ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS. WENT
SPECIFICALLY TO CITIES COUNTIES
IN CONTINUUM'S OF CARE FOR
THESE TYPES OF SERVICES SO YOU
KNOW WHAT OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A
SHARED PRIORITY AND WE HOPE
THAT THAT WILL PROVIDE SOME
RELIEF BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND
THE PRESSURE THAT LOCALITIES
ARE UNDER. ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THAT IS ON LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
OR- THAT COUNTY I AM- WE FOR
AYE HSS- AND THAT WAS A RE
NEGOTIATION WITH THE STATE AND
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN THE
STATE IS PUTTING AND- SEVERAL
HUNDRED EXTRA MILLION DOLLARS
IN ADDITIONAL AND THAT SHOULD
PROVIDE SOME RELIEF. AS WELL
FOR A PROGRAM WHERE WE KNOW
WE'RE FACING. RISING COSTS- BUT
ON THE BROADER ISSUE OF THE
SURPLUS- THE STATE OF COURSE-
HAS THIS RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES BUT THE
STATE AS YOU KNOW ALSO HAS ITS
OWN OBLIGATIONS AND THAT WE
KNOW WHAT OUR PENSION AND
RETIREE HEALTH CARE
OBLIGATIONS. WE NEED TO PUT MY
AS WELL IT'S WHERE THOSE
OPTIONS AT THE STATE ITSELF IS
ON THE HOOK FOR AND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE DID- A GREAT DEAL ON A
LAST YEAR'S ENACTED BUDGET. BUT
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO SO FAR TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE HAVE DISCRETIONARY
RESOURCES- FOR THE STATE'S
SURPLUS- IT'S ONLY- RIGHT I
THINK IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
POSITION. THAT THAT MONEY GO TO
WORK STATE UNFUNDED OBLIGATIONS
FIRST. IN THE U. BROUGHT UP
ALMOST AS AND THAT'S WHERE
WHERE TO GO NEXT AND THAT'S
WHERE I DO SEE THE STATE
HELPING. CITIES AND COUNTIES-
BUT IT SEEMS SILO TO ME SO
WE'VE GOT ONE PROGRAM FROM LAST
YEAR NEW PROGRAM FROM THIS YEAR
WE HAVE PROPOSITION TWO. WHICH
PROVIDES THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME.
IN A FUNDING AND- WE'VE HAD A
YEAR NOW SINCE. MEASURE PASS.
HOW ARE WE DOING ON GRANT FOR.
HOW COUNTY. DOING AND WHAT MY
HAS BEEN TO. DISCUSS YES ALL
FIRST ABOUT JAY. GOV AND IN
TERMS OF THE FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY SO. FOR
GOVERNANCE- THIS IS BEEN A
PRIORITY SINCE THE GOVERNOR
TOOK OFFICE BUT EVEN IN THE
LAST COUPLE WEEKS AND MONTHS.
YOU'RE SEEING THAT MINISTRATION
FURTHER STEP UP IN THIS AREA SO
THE GOVERNOR. HAS APPOINTED AND
HIS OFFICE IS SENIOR COUNSELOR
SPECIFICALLY ON HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. HE SAID ONLY HALF
JOKINGLY DURING HIS OWN BUDGET
PRESS CONFERENCE THAT HE
HIMSELF WAS THE HOMELESSNESS
ARE. ON AND THEN HE SIGNALED
THE AND THE GUY AND- BUDGET
EIGHT PAGES THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPLORE THE CREATION OF A
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS.
DEPARTMENT OR AGENCY- TO
FURTHER A LINE THESE EFFORTS-
SO THERE IS A REAL FOCUS ON
MAKING SURE NOT ONLY THAT WERE.
INVESTING THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE REQUIRED. BUT THAT THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE INTEGRATED
ACROSS THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS OF THE STATE.
THAT ARE DEALING WITH THIS AND
THIS SPECIFICALLY IS A
PRIORITY. OF OUR HHS PROPOSAL
AND OF COURSE A LOT OF OUR
HOMELESSNESS EFFORTS. ARE
WITHIN THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY.
BUT AS WE NOW- PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
OFTEN EXPERIENCING HEALTH
CHALLENGES BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES. SO IT'S ACTUALLY
VERY IMPORTANT THAT ANYTHING WE
DO IN THE HHS SPACES ALSO
COORDINATED. SO THAT'S ON THE
GOVERNMENT SIDE WHEN IT COMES
TO PACIFIC WHICH TO THE
FUNDING. AT THE GOVERNOR- IS-
BELIEVES THAT THAT MONEY THAT
NOW OVER BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS. THE FIRST
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
CHARGE WAS TO BUDGET AX AGO.
AND THEN THE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE THE- TIME FROM LAST YEAR
THAT IS ACT. IT'S GOING OUT
RIGHT NOW. ON AND I KNOW CAN BE
FRUSTRATING WHEN IT TAKES A
COUPLE MONTHS FOR THE MONEY TO
GO OUT. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS GOING TO THE RIGHT
AND TO BE THE- PLANS IN PLACE.
TO I IT CAN THANK EFFECTIVELY.
BECAUSE THE ADVOCACY OF THAT
SPENDING IS KEEN READING OF
WHETHER WE DECIDE TO INVEST
FURTHER SOURCES. IN THE FUTURE.
HE'S GOING TO SEE AND COUNTIES
THE- TAX ARE MONTH THAT'S A
SEVEN FIFTY NINE TO. IN TERMS
OF THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME. THAT
FINISHED AT THE UNITED THAT WAS
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS I
BELIEVE THE FIRST TRY CHAT HAS
GONE OUT A RISK. OUT AND THERE
IS NO OF FUNDING AVAILABLE. FOR
THE SECOND CRUNCH OF THAT AND
MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS CAN ALSO
SPEAK. TO THAT- THAT THAT'S
ALSO A PLACE WHERE WE WANT TO
GET THOSE RESOURCES OUT BUT
AGAIN WE DON'T WANT TO SPEND IT
ALL IN ONE SHOT. BEFORE PEOPLE
ARE READY AND WE GET A SENSE OF
HOW TO MOST EFFECTIVELY SPEND
IT AND WHAT WORKS. AND THEN THE
FINAL POINT THAT'LL MAKE IS
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
CALIFORNIA. HOUSE ACCESS TO
HOUSING AND SERVICES FUND WHICH
THAT YOU'RE MENTIONED IN HER
OPENING. REMARKS THIS IS
DESIGNED TO SUPPLEMENT AND NOT
SUPPLANT THE EFFORTS THAT ARE
GOING ON AT THE CITY AND COUNTY
LEVELS SO. WHILE THAT SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE DOLLARS FROM
LAST YEAR'S PROJECT IS GOING
OUT. WE'RE ALSO PROPOSING WITH
THIS FUND AND WE'RE HOPING FOR
EARLY ACTION ALTHOUGH WE KNOW
THAT WILL BE A CONVERSATION
WITH ALL OF YOU. IN THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT THAT WE'LL
GET TO THESE OTHER PRIORITIES
IN CONCERT WITH CITIES AND
COUNTIES SPECIFICALLY FOR
STABILIZING THESE PORTENT CRE
HOMES WHICH WE ALL KNOW. FROM
EXPERIENCE ARE FROM READING
NEWS COVERAGE ARE AT RISK AND
DO NEED TO BE STABILIZED. WE
NEED MORE FLEXIBLE NIMBLE
APPROACH FOR GETTING RENTAL
SUBSIDIES TO PEOPLE WHO NEED
THEM. AND THERE'S MORE THAT WE
CAN DO ON DEVELOPING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS AND NOT SIMPLY
TAKING. A STATE YOU KNOW. OUCH
WHERE IT'S ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
BUT AT THIS. TIME NOT LETTING
EVERY. ASSN CITY ITS OWN THING
WITHOUT ANY SORT OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. SO WE ARE
PROPOSING A REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATOR MODEL. LOOKING AT
BEST PRACTICES IN BUILDING AND
ACCOUNTABILITY INTO THAT
SYSTEM. AND I THINK WHEN YOU
PUT ALL THESE THINGS TOGETHER.
THIS IS NOT A CHALLENGE THAT
CAN BE SOLVED IN ONE YEAR OR
TWO YEARS. BUT WE HOPE THAT NOT
ONLY THIS INVESTMENT OF
RESOURCES BUT HOW IT'S A WIND
AND HOW THE GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE IS. WILL MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE GETTING THE BEST
RETURN ON OUR INVESTMENT. IN
SENATOR MORE LIKE. YOU KNOW WE
ALSO HAVE SOME THOUGHTS OR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL-
IN PARTICULAR WITH REGARD TO
HOMELESSNESS- YOU KNOW THE-
ONE. WOULD YOU THE QUESTION
ABOUT RESOURCES FOR CITIES. WE
NOTED THAT IN THE PRESS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET. THERE WERE
RESOURCES GIVEN DIRECTLY TO THE
CITIES BUT IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET PROPOSAL BEFORE US THERE
IS A SHIFT A CHANGE IN THE WAY
THAT THE- HOMELESSNESS DOLLARS
ARE ADMINISTERED AND WE DO
THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME.
REASONABLE QUESTIONS ABOUT. YOU
KNOW WHAT IS THE DATE- WHAT ARE
THE WHAT KIND OF INFORMATION
LED TO THAT SORT OF CHANGE. AND
WHY. CHANNELING THOSE INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
VERSES THAT THE PRIOR MODEL.
AND SO THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
QUESTIONS WE THINK ARE
PROBABLY- PRODUCTIVE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIND OUT
THROUGHOUT THIS BUDGET PROCESS.
THANK YOU FOR THE THOROUGHNESS
OF YOUR RESPONSES ARE
APPRECIATED I DO NOT FOR TODAY
BUT FOR THE FUTURE- I'D LIKE TO
DISCUSS ARENA. NUMBERS THEY
HAVE BECOME SO LARGE- FOR
CITIES THAT THEY'RE CHOKING-
WERE WERE ASKING CERTAIN CITIES
TO BUILD. A NUMBER OF UNITS
THAT THEY HAVEN'T BUILT IN
FORTY YEARS. OF HISTORY
SOLDIERS JUST. JUST I'M JUST
TRYING TO. SEE WHAT WE CAN DO
IT ARE CAN. OUR STAR CITY- IN
OUR IN OUR DISTRICT HOW WE GET
SOME BALANCE. IN ANOTHER
SUBJECT I'D LIKE TO DISCUSS THE
FUTURE IS WHAT WE'RE DOING THE
FAIRVIEW DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER-
AND DO WE KNOW WE APPROVED.
DOING ASIDE STUDY BUT THERE WAS
ALSO ABOUT A TWELVE MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION LECTURE BUT
I. I'D LIKE TO SEE WHAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE. AS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR COULD MORE. THANK YOU FOR
THE THOROUGHNESS OF YOUR
REPORTING IT'S VERY HELPFUL. I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS OF THE
PRIVATE FUNDING THAT THE
GOVERNOR SECURED FOR
HOMELESSNESS WHERE DID THAT
COME FROM WHO WHO DID HE SECURE
FROM. SURE SO IT WAS FOR- IT'S
FOR HOUSING OF COURSE THESE
ISSUES ARE INTERTWINED AND IT
TOTALS FOUR AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS. AND A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT SOURCES BUT THE BULK
OF IT IS- FROM THE STATE'S BIG
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES INCLUDING
APPLE GOOGLE AND FACEBOOK. AND
ARE THEY GIVING IT TO US OR WE
HAVE TO REPAY THAT BACK A CITY
SO IT'S A COMBINATION OF
GRANTS- AS WELL AS- SUPPORTING
OUR LOAN PROGRAM- AT BELOW
MARKET RATES. HE AND IT BELOW
MARKET RATES DO WE HAVE A
NUMBER FOR THAT WITH THAT WOULD
BE DON'T HAVE IT WITH ME WE CAN
WE CAN GET BACK TO YOU ON HOW
THOSE THAT WAS- SOMEWHAT
COMPLICATED STRUCTURE BUT I'M
SURE. YOU ON THAT. GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I ALSO HAVE. A
QUESTION ABOUT AB SIX
SEVENTEEN. OF THE COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION PROGRAM. MICHELINE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE PUT INTO THIS
PROGRAM AND IT'S NOW BEEN
REDUCED TO TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
WHICH FOR SOMEONE LIKE ME WHO'S
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE WE'RE
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR MORE
PROTECTION FOR OUR AIR QUALITY
AND HOW DO WE REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. HOW TO READ WE
REDUCES PARTICULATES JUST
CURIOUS WHY IT WAS CUT FROM
FIFTY TO TWENTY FIVE. YES SO TO
ON THIS ISSUE ONE BE VERY CLEAR
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION DOES
THINKING COMMITTEE- PROTECTION
IS A KEY PRIORITY- AND SAID
THIS WAS. NOTHING TO DO WITH ME
EVERY ACTION BEING LESSEN
PRIORITY AND MUCH MORE THE FACT
THAT OVERALL FUNDING FOR CAP
AND TRADE. IS NOT WHAT WE WE'RE
NOT PROJECTING IT AT A LEVEL
THIS YEAR WHAT WE PRINT WHAT WE
HAD FOR LAST YEAR SO SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS IN CAP AND TRADE.
HOW TO TAKE THEIR CUT OR EVEN
BEING BROUGHT DOWN SEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN THAT-
AND SO WE'RE HOPING THAT COME A
OR YOU KNOW THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS WILL GET A BETTER SENSE
OF HOW OUR- TEAM CAP AND TRADE
REVENUES EVERY YEAR TO CALM
AND- IF THEY DO INCREASED AND
WE'LL HAVE. MORE RESOURCES TO
PUT INTO POSSIBLY BASE AS WELL
AS OTHER PROGRAMS THAT TOOK A
HAIR CUT. BUT THAT'S THE REASON
FOR IT NOT ANY DEITIES IS ON
THE- OF THAT PROGRAM OKAY SO
JUST PUT A PLUG FOR. WHEN
THEY'RE MORE MY REACT. THAT
BACKS SO WE HAVE THE MILLION I
THERE'S- A THAT OUT. TO THAT IS
CLEAN AND LET FREE I THINK
BREED AIR THE DAY HOUSE IT'S MY
SHOULD BE OUR TOP PRIORITIES.
ARE WILL WE LOOK AT PROP
NINETY. FUNDING AS CHAIR OF-
SENATE ED. I WOULD JUST KIND OF
GENTLY CAUTION US WHEN WE SAY
THAT EIGHTY FOUR BILLION IS THE
MOST WE'VE EVER PUT INTO PROP.
NINETY EIGHT WHILE I KNOW THAT
IS TRUE. TRUE I THINK THERE ARE
MANY OF US THAT. THAT ARE STILL
FUND EDGE. AND WE CAL IT IN THE
WAY. I'M A PEOPLE WILL THINK OF
IT- WE'VE DONE JOB WE'VE GOT
ALL THE MONEY WE NEED AN
EDUCATION. SO I WOULD JUST
CAUTION US THERE- AND THEN THE
NINE HUNDRED MILLION FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION. IS THERE
SOME SPECIFICITY TO THAT DO WE
KNOW EXACTLY WHERE THAT MONEY'S
GOING TO GO OR PROGRAMS THAT
WILL GO TO. YES SIR THIS IS A
PHASED APPROACH ABOUT ONE OF
THAT COMMITMENTS- IN THE BUDGET
THAT THE LEGISLATURE NOTCHED
LAST YEAR WAS WE HAD A- BIG
INCREASE IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING. LAST YEAR BUT IT WAS
CONTINGENT IN FUTURE YEARS ON
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSING AND
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
ON AN UPDATED FUNDING FORMULA
TO MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING THE BEST OUTCOMES FOR
THOSE DOLLARS AND HELPING AS
MANY PEOPLE IN THE BEST WAYS.
AS POSSIBLE SO THE NINE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR OR THERE ABOUTS
REFLECTS NUMBER ONE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE OF AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE DOLLARS. BUT MORE THAN
THAT AND YOU WAY OF ALLOCATING
THE MONEY AND THIS WILL HAPPEN
OVER A COUPLE YEARS BUT MY
COLLEAGUES ASK I CAN TALK
ABOUT. SOME TO KEEP TEAMS IN
TERMS OF HOW WE'RE ALLOCATING
THAT MONEY. WOULD BE GREAT THE
S. JUST COMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT WE PROVIDED
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
MILLION IN ADDITIONAL FUNDS
FOR- SPECIAL EDUCATION OF THAT
SIX HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION.
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
MILLION WENT TO INCREASE THE
BASE RATES. OF A CELL BUSINESS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT HAD RATES
THAT WERE BELOW. ON THE
STATEWIDE TARGET RATE FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY THREE MILLION
WENT- TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
THE- EXPECTATION THAT WAS USED
FOR. THREE AND FOUR AND FIVE
YEAR OLDS ANALYST WITH
DISABILITIES THAT ARE. TO BE BY.
WHAT WE'RE DOING THIS YEAR. WE
ARE PRETTY BAD. A NEW. FORMULA
THE EIGHT IS THE OVER SEVEN
YEARS. WE COMPLETE. CAN BE. BY
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING.
INCLUDE ALL THAT'S COMPONENT
BUT WE'RE- WITH THIS YEAR. IT
IS THE BASE FUNDING FORMULA.
AND THEN PLANNING ON LOOKING AT
ALL THE DIFFERENT SPECIAL
EDUCATION CATEGORICAL CENTER
ADDED ONTO. TOP OF THAT FUTURE
YEARS SO THE BASE. WOULD TAKE
THREE YEAR ROLLING OUT. OF
SCHOOL THIS. EIGHTY AS OPPOSED%
TO THE ONE YEAR. ON EIGHTY
EIGHT- OF THE CELL BUT THAT'S
CURRENTLY USED- AND THE THREE
RULING EVER TO HELP KIND OF.
EVEN OUT AND DIPS AND PEAKS IN
THE FUNDING- AND THEN THE FUN
WOULD STILL GO THROUGH
SELFLESS- BUT THE BASE RATE
WOULD BE INCREASE FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
TAKING THAT SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE MILLION THAT WE
PROVIDED LAST YEAR. AND RULING
THAT INTO THE NEW BASE RATE. IN
ADDITION THE TUNER FIFTY
MILLION THAT- MISTER MISTER NOT
BEEN. A REFERENCE WOULD BE FOR-
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES. GRAY THAT ALL
SOUNDS REALLY GOOD ALL OF IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
ACCOUNTABILITY HOW DO HOW WILL
WE MAKE SURE THAT DISTRICTS ARE
DOING WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE DOING WITH THE MONEY. THAT'S
AN EXCELLENT QUESTION- ED I
THINK ONE OF THE KEY ISSUES
THAT FOLKS ABOUT UP TO US-
WE'VE BEEN TALKING WITH PEOPLE
IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS ABOUT
SOCIAL EDUCATION IS THE FACT
THAT WE HOLD SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACCOUNTABLE- FOR THEIR STUDENT
OUTCOMES IN SPECIAL EDUCATION-
BUT THE FUNDING DECISIONS ARE
MADE AT THE TOP LEVEL. AND SO
WE ARE PROPOSING- AN ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATION OF A FEW HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. I'M TO
CREATE. A WORK GROUP ON AND
GOVERNANCE- FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING- AT FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND- FISCAL
YEAR- TO PROVIDE US WITH SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT HOW WE
CAN IMPROVE AND STRENGTHEN THE
ACCOUNTABILITY- AROUND. THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION OUTCOMES AND
USE OF FUNDS- AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD. THAT SOUNDS GREAT IF I
CAN BE HELPFUL IN ANY WAY
PLEASE LET ME KNOW ONE LAST
QUESTION. DID I READ CORRECTLY
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE A NEW.
CHILD CARE. ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE ALSO THERE IS A NEW
DEPARTMENT OF EARLY.
DEVELOPMENT OKAY YES AND THAT
WOULD BE WITHIN HHS AGENCY AND
BASICALLY RESULTED FROM THE
SENSE THAT SOME OF THESE
DEPARTMENTS WERE SCATTERED OR
IN DIFFERENT PLACES SO WE WANT
TO BRING. MOST OF THOSE CHILD
CARE FUNCTIONS UNDER ONE ROOF
AND THE EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION WILL BE SPENT FOR THAT
DEPARTMENT I BELIEVE SO YES I
CAN DOUBLE CHECK THE FIGURE BUT
IT'S T GET THAT- GET THAT
DEPARTMENT GOING. IN AND I JUST
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES YOU
DEPARTMENTS ARE GREAT AND MUCH
NEEDED BUT I WONDER IF THAT
EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION COULD
BE BETTER SPENT- FIXING THE
DEPARTMENT WE ALREADY HAVE I
DON'T KNOW- BUT I JUST WANT TO
BE CAUTIOUS THAT WE'RE NOT
SPENDING MONEY. THAT THEY COULD
MAKE THE DEPARTMENT BETTER AND
THEN WE'RE CREATING ANOTHER
BUREAUCRACY SELF JUST A
COMMENT. THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH VERY HELPFUL INFORMATION
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU JUST BEFORE I GO ON- TO
CENTER NIELSEN IF I COULD
FOLLOW UP ON THE- ECT QUESTION-
ASK BY- SENATOR LEYVA- WHILE I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL TEN THOUSAND SLOTS
FOR PRESCHOOL. YOU KNOW FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. AS I RECALL. BOB
PRESCHOOL. IS ONE YEAR- AND AS
WE KNOW INFANT CARE IS PREMIUM-
IT'S THE MOST EXPENSIVE AND
HARDEST TO FIND ACROSS THE
STATE. AND SO IN THE INTENTION
ON CONTINUING TO LOOK AT
ADDITIONAL SLOTS FOR ZERO TO
THREE BECAUSE- YOU KNOW I THINK
OUR GOAL IS THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE TO MAKE SURE CHILDREN ARE
SCHOOL READY. AND YOU COULD
HAVE THE ABSOLUTE BEST
PRESCHOOL EXPERIENCE. UP
POSSIBLE BUT IF YOU HAVE NOT
INVESTED ZERO THREE YOU CAN
CATCH UP IN ONE YEAR. AND SO
ANY ADDITIONAL AND- IDEAS OR
CONCEPTS AROUND. THE EXPANSION
OF SLOTS FOR ZERO TO THREE. SO
THAT WILL- GENERALLY DEPEND ON
AVAILABLE REVENUE SO WE'LL TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT IT IN MAY.
THANK YOU. SENATOR NELSON. THE
HOMELESS INITIATIVE AND FOCUS
IT IS REPORTED THAT THERE WILL
BE SOME TRACKING IS THAT BEEN
DECIDED HOW THAT WILL BE DONE
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IF
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS HAVING OR-
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT. YES THAT'S
CORRECT WE'RE GONNA LOOK
CLOSELY BOTH THAT THE SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE DOLLARS
THAT'S FLOWING TEARS CITIES
COUNTIES CONTINUUM'S OF CARE
THAT IS ONE TIME FUNDING SO-
BEFORE THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT FLOWS THAT WAY
SPECIFICALLY TO THOSE ENTITIES
WE WANT TO SEE HOW WE'RE
SPENDING THIS MONEY. ON HOW YOU
MEASURE IT THOUGH SAY AGAIN HOW
DO YOU MEASURE IT HOW YOU
MEASURE A SO THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT OUTCOMES BUT IN
TERMS OF WHETHER PEOPLE ARE
GETTING SHELTERED WHETHER
THEY'RE TRANSITIONING TO
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING-
WE OF COURSE NEED A DOCTOR THIS
MORNING WAS OUT ON THE STREET
IN AT FOUR IN THE MORNING YOU
KNOW. GETTING THE P. I. TO
DETECT COUNT- SO THEIR NUMBER
OF IMPORTANT METRICS THAT WE
WOULD BE LOOKING AT. ANOTHER
ASPECT OF IT AS I UNDERSTAND.
THAT IF VOCAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD
DO NOT MEET THE EXPECTATIONS OF
THE STATE THAT WILL BE SOME
SANCTIONS IMPOSED OF THOSE BEEN
DECIDED WHAT SANCTIONS WILL BE
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. SO I
THINK YOU MAY BE REFERRING- TO
A PROPOSAL- FROM- THAT THAT
GOVERNOR'S DISCUSSED WITH SOME
OF THE ADVISORS- TO HIM ON
HOMELESSNESS REGARDING- PUTTING
IN OBLIGATIONS- FOR. LOCAL AND
OUR STATE AND TO DECIDE TO.
HOUSE THE HOMELESSNESS OR AND
DEAL WITH THIS CRISIS IN A
SIGNIFICANT WAY- THE GOVERNOR
HAS- EMBRACE THE GENERAL IDEA
OF DOING SOMETHING BIG HERE BUT
HE'S ALSO BAGHDAD THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO TAKE
A LOOK AT WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
SO I THINK THERE WILL BE MORE
DETAILS TO COME ON THAT I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE THERE'S
A BIT OF AN- IRONY HERE. A PART
OF OUR PROBLEM OUR LOCAL CAN
STUDENT BY THE TICKET LET
BRANCH OF ON. TO REALIGN. AND
THEN PUNISH THEM FOR NOT
MEETING OUR- OF WHAT WE HAVE
PUBLISHED ON THAT'S A LITTLE
BIT OF A BURDEN I THINK OF THIS
HE MENTIONED A BIT OF A DOLLAR
FOR POST REACH LEAST. NOW
THERE'S VERY LITTLE OR MUCH
POST. REALLY SUPER NOW BOTH
REALIGN. THE SO WHAT
PHARMACISTS TO TAKE IS THIS
MORE TO THE PROBE. DEPARTMENTS
IN THE COUNTIES. YES SO- I LIKE
SHALL HAVE A COLLEAGUE OF MINE
SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO THAT IT'S
A THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL IT'S ON TOP OF THAT
PROBATION PROPOSALS THAT I WAS
DISCUSSING- BUT THEY CAN TALK
ABOUT IT A LITTLE MORE IF YOU
WOULD BE TO. THE SKY. KERN
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO- THE THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IS A REFLECTION THAT-
AT THE STATE LEVEL WHEN THERE
ARE POPULATION CHANGES- MORE
PEOPLE ARE RELEASED AND
THEREFORE THERE'S MORE PEOPLE
IN POST RELEASE COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION SO THAT THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. IS REFLECTIVE
OF A SHORT TERM BUBBLE THAT WAS
CREATED BY PROP FIFTY SEVEN BY.
PEOPLE EARNING MORE CREDITS AND
THEN THOSE RELEASES GENERATING
MORE PEOPLE ON HERE CS SO THIS
IS A CONTINUATION OF A MULTI
YEAR EFFORT TO FIND THAT
MOBILE. FOR COUNTIES- AT SOME
POINT IN THE FUTURE IT'LL SORT
OF PLATEAU AND WE'LL GO BACK TO
A NORMAL HOMEOSTASIS LEVEL.
OKAY WELL THE JUST BE ADVISED I
HAVE SOME RESERVATIONS ABOUT
THIS REDUCING THE PROBATION
PERIODS AT CETERA- I DON'T BY
THE LOGIC THAT'S THAT'S GOING
TO RESULT IN. BETTER
REHABILITATION OR SUCCESS. ON
FOR BUT THAT'S UP ON PROBATION
THAT THAT'S THAT'S A PLACE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THREE
RESPONSE THERE. OF THE IN THIS
BUDGET THERE'S A BIT LESS MONEY
FOR WHAT WE CALL DEBT REDUCTION
IS THAT BECAUSE THE- EXTRA
MONEY IS BLESSED AND IN THIS
BUDGET THAN SOME PREVIOUS ONES.
IT SEEMS LIKE. AND YOU DID
MENTION FOR EXAMPLE THAT TO
ACCELERATING THE OF PENSION
REDUCTIONS THAT WOULD BE. PRIOR
DONE ALREADY SO NOTHING NEW-
BUT DESERVED IT IS THAT THE
REASON THAT WE YOU'RE
ANTICIPATING LESS SURPLUS
MONEY. I THINK I NUMBER ONE IT
IS TRUE THAT WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANTLY SMALLER ALTHOUGH
STILL NOT INSIGNIFICANT-
SURPLUS OVERALL- BUT NUMBER TWO
IS THE FACT THAT- YOU TO
PROPOSITION TWO IS STILL IN
EFFECT SO WE'VE STILL GOT. BOTH
OUR DEPOSIT OF TWO BILLION
DOLLARS INTO THE RAINY DAY FUND
AS WELL AS OUR- TO DEBT
PAYMENTS AND WE'RE ACTUALLY
PROJECTING. OVER THE FORECAST
PERIOD- IN THE YEAR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR UNDER
PROPOSITION TWO THERE WILL BE
AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT ONE.
BILLION DOLLARS SO IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT TO THAT WOULD BE
TO CALPERS A SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT. SO IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
AT THE SCALE THAT WE SAW LAST
YEAR BUT OF COURSE THE PAYMENTS
THAT WE MADE LAST YEAR WILL
BENEFIT THE STATE FOR YEARS TO
COME. AND WE ARE CONTINUING TO
BUILD. PRESERVE SOCIETY
REMBRANDT BY. I SHOULD ACT LAST
YEAR. WE ARE PROJECT AROUND
NINE. DON'T DOLLARS OF RESEARCH
IN THIS YEAR WE'RE- TO ONE
DOLLAR DOLLARS IN THANK YOU. UP
PS PS. THIS JUST MY OPINION. BE
A WAY OF LIFE NEW NORM AND CAL.
IT'S TO JUST FOR. OF THE-
PUBLIC. BUT THAT SAID- OUR
SPECIAL DISH. BASED TO BE- NOT
MENTIONED IN TERMS OF THESE
PUBLIC SAFETY THE NOTIFICATION
MONIES THAT ARE COMING FOR
PROFESSIONAL DISTANCE MONEY
WILL GO TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
BUT IT IS ARE GOING TO BE ANY
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE SUCH
SPECIAL DISTRICTS BEING A PART
OF THAT. SAW SPEAK GENERALLY
TERRA HOW THE ADMINISTRATION'S
THINKING ABOUT THAT MONEY AND
THEN MY TALK TO RESET MAIL
EVERY AS WELL AS SO IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET YET SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS A AND THIS YEAR
IT'S AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR WHAT WE'RE
CALLING. COMMUNITY RESILIENCE-
WHICH IS P. S. P. S. AS YOU
MENTIONED AND I THINK THE FIRST
THING I'LL SAY IS THAT
GOVERNOR'S MADE CLEAR HE
AGREES. WITH YOUR SENTIMENT
THAT THIS CANNOT BE A WAY OF
LIFE AND SO HE'S SPENDING HOURS
AND HOURS WITH HIS SENIOR
ADVISERS THINKING ABOUT THE P.
JEANNIE BANKRUPTCY AND HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE UTILITIES
EMERGES PROVIDE SAFER FIVE
AFFORDABLE RELIABLE AND CLEAN
ENERGY- AND SO WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S- EVEN IF IT'S GOING
TO CONTINUE TO BE A CHALLENGE
FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
CANNOT BE WAY OF LIFE. AND THEN
THE SECOND THING BECAUSE IT IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE A
CHALLENGE THIS YEAR IN THE
BUDGET YEAR- THE BUDGET
INCLUDES AT FIFTY NINE DOLLARS
WITH A SPECIAL FOCUS ON SCHOOLS
COUNTY VOTED VOTING OFFICES IN
CASE- WE WERE TO EXPERIENCE
THAT. YES YES. THE FACT. AND IT
FINALLY FOR BANKS IN FOOD STORE
BECAUSE KNOW THAT'S IN. OF NEED
PARTICULARLY DURING THAT TYPE
OF THAT SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
OUR SWEETS. DO NOT TAKE. AT THE
MOMENT WHEN WE NEED THEM MOST.
AND MY COLLEAGUE THERESA MAY
COLLABORATE AS WELL THANK YOU.
THIRTY SIX HOUR WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IN OUR BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FOR THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. IT IS SPECIFIED THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS INCLUDING
SPECIAL DISTRICTS WOULD- BE-
CONSIDER FOR THESE FUNDS SO IN
A LANGUAGE THE- IT WILL BE
MENTIONED SPECIAL DISTRICTS OF
WORDS WILL OCCUR. IN THE IN
THE- LANGUAGE AND OPEN THE
TRAILER BILL OR IN THE BUDGET.
RIGHT IN THE IN THE BUDGETING
PROPOSAL THAT ACCOMPANIES THIS-
REQUEST IT IS MENTIONED THERE.
WE DON'T HAVE ASSOCIATED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AT THIS
TIME BUT- OUR PROPOSAL DOES
INCLUDE SPECIAL DISTRICTS. NOW
IS MONEY FLOWS TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OF FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS ALSO INCLUDED THE- FOR
MONIES. I AM NOT SURE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS ARE CONSIDERED SPECIAL
DISTRICTS WILL HAVE TO LOOK
INTO THAT TIME THAT SPECIFIC I
DON'T THINK THEY ARE BUT I
WOULD JUST DIG KNOWLEDGE THAT
THEY ARE VERY HELPFUL AND VERY
IMPORTANT. AS WE MOVE INTO THIS
PARTICULAR AREA. OF THE I
MENTIONED IN MY- BRIEF
INTRODUCTORY. ABOUT THE
CONSOLIDATIONS OF THE CREATION
OF NEW DEPARTMENTS. OF IS IT
ANTICIPATED THAT THERE WILL BE
NO NET INCREASE IN P. WHY IS
WITH THESE REORGANIZATIONS IF
YOU WILL OR THE CREATION OF NEW
ENTITIES OR THE RENAMING OF
ENTITIES. HOW WHAT WHAT SAID IN
A LOOK LIKE IN TERMS OF. JUST
THE- NUMBER OF STATE EMPLOYEES.
YES SO SOME OF THESE ARE
CONSOLIDATIONS BUT AT THE SAME
TIME SOME OF THEM ARE NEW LINES
OF THAT BUSINESS OF LIKE THE
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
WORK THAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
TO DO FOR EXAMPLE OR INCREASES
TO OUR CYBER SECURITY
CAPABILITIES- OR THE WILD FIRES
RIGHT INTELLIGENCE IN
INTEGRATION CENTER. TO SOME OF
THESE ENTITIES WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS AND
SPENDING- AT THE SAME TIME WE
HOPE THAT SOME OF THESE
CONSOLIDATIONS- YOU MAY HAVE A
VERY SIMILAR LEVELS EMPLOYEES
AND SPENDING TO WHAT YOU HAD
BEFORE. BUT HOPEFULLY A BETTER
LEVEL OF SERVICE SO THAT
CERTAINLY THE IDEA YES IS
BETTER YEAH I WAS JUST GOING TO
A SUPPLEMENT THAT CENTER MEALS
AND WITH- THE FACT THAT WE
THINK THIS IS ACTUALLY ONE OF
THE MORE IMPORTANT- BLINDS OF
DISCUSSION THE YOU MAY HAVE
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET PROCESS
THAT. THE ADDITION OF SOME
DEPARTMENTS CONSOLIDATIONS. ALL
OF THE ESTIMATES THAT I TALKED
ABOUT WITH REGARD TO THE FUTURE
OF OPERATING POSITION OF THE
STATE'S BUDGET DO NOT REALLY
TAKE THOSE INTO ACCOUNT AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THEY WOULD ADD
TO ONGOING COST THEY'RE NOT
REFLECTED IN THAT. AND SO WHAT
ELSE MANY OF THEM HAVE GOOD
IDEAS BEHIND THEM WE THINK THAT
THAT'S GOING TO BE AN IMPORTANT
PART OF IT FROM A FISCAL
STANDPOINT TO TAKE TO TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT. THE END I WOULD
VICE AT THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
SHOULD AS WELL THE- THERE'S NOT.
IS BEEN DURING IS A NEWLY
CREATE. STATE AGENCY. END OF
THE THAT'S JUST SOMETHING WE
HAVE TO ACCEPT SO WE HAVE TO
BE. I I'M ARGUING TO BE
CAUTIOUS ABOUT THAT- DIMENSION
BROADBAND EXPANSION- VERY
PLEASED TO HEAR THAT BUT WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S. PROPOSAL YESTERDAY
THE BROADBAND PLAN IS IN WITHIN
OUR FIVE YEAR INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN AND THAT MOST OF THE MONEY
FOR THIS COMES FROM SPECIAL
FUNDS THAT'S NOT COMING FROM.
GENERAL FUND TAX PROCEEDS BUT%
FUNDS- WITHIN THE QC OR RELATED
ENTITIES AND BASICALLY. IT'S
ABOUT NAPPING THE STATE OF
CONNECTIVE ITTY IN ALL AREAS OF
THE STATE- AND THEN MAKING SURE
THAT WERE DEPLOYING RESOURCES
INCLUDING A BIG INVESTMENT FOR
SCHOOLS BECAUSE THAT SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PART OF BROADBAND
CANNOT CONNECTIVITY. BUT ALSO
IN OTHER AREAS WHERE WE THINK
THE FUNDING TO MAKE THE BIGGEST
IMPACT AND PLEASE ANYONE
ELABORATE YES. THE MIDDLE PART
OF FINANCES THE BUDDING A-
DOLLARS LESS THAN NINE HUNDRED
MILLION OVER FIVE YEARS FOR
BROADBAND PURPOSES. OKAY THAT'S
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL AND I THANK
YOU WE'VE HAD SOME DIFFICULTIES
WITH THAT AND RURAL AREAS FOR
SURE. LASTLY LOCAL JAILS. THE
REALIGNMENT AND OTHER THINGS
INCLUDING INITIATIVES HAVE
RESULTED IN A HUGE IMPACT ON
OUR LOCAL JAILS. BUT ONE ON
Sí
MOMENT. IS THE IMPACT OF INMATE
LAWSUITS THAT HAVE MARCHED FROM
THE STATE PRISONS OUT INTO OUR
LOCAL JAILS FRESNO COUNTY WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST HIT RIGHT
AFTER REALIGNMENT. AND THE
JAILS ARE NOW BEING REQUIRED OR
BEING ASKED TO. DO THINGS THAT
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN DESIGNED TO
DO. HOW OR VISIT MINISTRATION
LOOKING AT THAT THE LOOMING
CRISIS IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
DEALING WITH THESE POPULATIONS
IN OUR JAILS AND THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE HOUSING
AND MANAGER OF THOSE
POPULATIONS. YES ALL MENTION
TWO THINGS BRIEFLY BUT THEN- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WILL OPERATE I THINK
THE FIRST IS THAT- THE GOVERNOR
SIGNAL BOTH IN THE BUDGET EIGHT
PAGES AND PRESS CONFERENCE AT
LOCAL JAIL OVERSIGHT WILL BE A
PRIORITY OF HIS- AND THEN
SECOND- WHEN IT COMES TO HER
PROBATION REFORM SPECIFICALLY-
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING OUT OF JAILS- AS- ALONG
SIDE STATE PRISON. YOU ARE NOT
CYCLING BACK INTO THE SYSTEM-
BUT THE FOR DELIBERATE. PLEASE
THANK YOU ROBERT NELSON PART OF
FINANCE. THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS IS
CURRENTLY EVALUATING. WASTE
INCREASED OVERSIGHT. THIS
REVIEW INCLUDES WAY IS THAT CAN
BE DONE ADMINISTRATIVELY LIKE
WHAT YOU PROVIDED A SHAWL
GUIDANCE. ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT-
RE REPORTS THEY'RE BORED
ENHANCE FOLLOW UP WITH
FACILITIES. AS WELL AS LORD YOU
SEE BORDERED WITH BORDER
CORRECTIONS. YES FOR
CORRECTIONS SORRY BUT COMMITTED
IS STRANGELY INCREASE
INSPECTION REPORTS- BREEN
REPORTS TO THE BOARD MEETINGS
HAS ALSO IF ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED. WE DON'T
HAVE A PROPOSAL AS THEY
CONTINUE THEIR EVALUATION WILL
BRING THAT FORWARD AND DISCUSS
THAT. WELL I'D SUBMIT RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED THE SPECTER LA- HAVE
YOU LOOKED AT THIS JAIL
SITUATION AT ALL YET YOUR
DEPARTMENT- WE- WE- LOW- MY
COLLEAGUE DREW IS PROBABLY.
FESTIVAL TO A. SO TOWARD
LEGISLATIVE IN WE ARE IN THE OF
LOOKING AT THE LEVEL OF JAIL
OVERSIGHT THAT'S CURRENTLY IN
PLACE FOR JAILS AND MODELS THAT
EXISTS AROUND THE STATE TO HELP
ADVISE THE LEGISLATURE ON
WHATEVER PROPOSAL THE
ADMINISTRATION COMES FORWARD
THE OTHER THING THAT I'D ADD
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTICE THE
STATE HAS PROVIDED HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. IN FUNDING
FOR JAIL CONSTRUCTION COM TO
COUNTIES ALL OVER THE STATE A
LOT OF THIS FUNDING WAS
INTENDED TO HELP RETROFIT JAILS
TO- MAKE THE MORE APPROPRIATE
FOR LONGER TERM PLACEMENTS THAT
STARTED OCCURRING AFTER THE
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT. BUT
I'D ARGUE THAT THE IMPACTS ARE
ACCELERATING VIA THE LAWSUITS
AND MY POINT IS WE NEED TO BE
ATTENDED TO THAT. THE TWO OF
THE- THANK YOU MANAGER. CENTER
LIKE ASKING. PICKING UP ON THE
CONSOLIDATION REORGANIZATION
SINCE I USED TO DO THAT BEFORE
I GOT HERE MISTER PECK. CAN YOU
GIVE US SOME ADVICE HERE
BECAUSE HIS FAVORITE THROUGH
THE INITIAL DOCUMENT IT SEEMS
SOME OF THIS IS IN FACT. REALLY
GOVERNMENT EXPANSION I MEAN THE
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
WHICH I HAVE A BILL ON
LICENSING DEBT COLLECTOR SOME
HAVE SOME INTEREST IN THIS
SUBJECT MATTER LOOKS LIKE A
GROWING. STATE GOVERNMENT IN
ITS FORTY FOUR POSITIONS- THIS
FIRST YEAR NINETY POSITIONS IN
NEXT YEAR BUT SOME OF IT REALLY
LOOKS LIKE CHANGING THE LAWN
FURNITURE MOVING IT FROM HERE
TO THERE AND IT'S JUST IT'S AND
IT HAS A HUGE COST. HAS HUGE
COST THE GOVERNMENT HOW WOULD
YOU ADVISE US CANCERS HELIO ON
TO LOOK AT EACH AND EVERYONE OF
THESE CONSOLIDATIONS
REORGANIZATIONS RENAMING SOME
OF IT JUST LOOKS LIKE. WE'RE
<c.green>HANGING THE PAINT AND PUTTING</c>
IT'S THE SAME FUNCTION. YES
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI I MEAN WE-
WITH RESPECT WE ALSO HAD
QUESTIONS. AND I THINK THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT. WILL BE AT THE
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW AS I MENTIONED IN THE
MULTI YEAR OUTLET- THE
ESTIMATES REALLY DON'T ACCOUNT
FOR THAT SO THERE COULD BE
HIGHER COST AND WHAT WERE SEEN
SO WE THINK THERE. I KNOW YOU
MAY HAVE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS BUT
I THINK THERE'S SOME KIND OF
GLOBAL FIGHTS THE YOU MAY WANT
TO KEEP IN MIND AS YOU THINK
THROUGH THIS ONE IS YOU KNOW
WITH THE REORGANIZATION LEAD TO
MORE EFFECTIVENESS OR BETTER
SERVICES. WOULD IT- INCREASE
EFFICIENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO MAKE THE CHANGES IN WHATEVER
PARTICULAR- DEPARTMENT THE
THIRD DISCUSSING- YOU KNOW.
WITH THAT AND THERE'S ALSO A
PUBLIC RELATIONS ELEMENT TO IT
HOW WITH THE PUBLIC RELATE TO
THEIR STATE GOVERNMENT WOULD IT
WOULDN'T ALTER THAT- CONNECTION
THAT THEY HAVE IN A WAY THAT
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND AND SO
THEY'RE SORT OF A- A PUBLIC
FACING ELEMENT TO THIS. AND
THEN- THE- WE ALSO THINK THAT
THERE'S A CO ABOUT HOW DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION PLAN TO
EFFECTUATE THESE CHANGES WOULD
BE THROUGH TRAILER BILL-LANGUAGE OR WOULD IT BE THROUGH.
FROM FROM THE- THE INTENT OF
THE REORGANIZATION OR THE NEW
DEPARTMENTS THE- OBJECTIVES
THAT ARE- HOPE TO BE ACHIEVED
WITH IT. AND THEN ALSO HOW IT
WOULD BE PUT INTO A FACT THESE
ARE ALL IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
THAT I THINK SHOULD PROBABLY-
SERVICE THE BACKDROP TO ANY OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS. ANYTHING
THAT MR THIS MORNING OFTEN. IS
THE MAIN THING IS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS ISSUE I WILL
SAY THAT- FOR SOME THE ENTITIES
LIKE THAT PROPOSED CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION THAT YOU
MENTIONED- THOSE WOULD BE
FUNDED OUT OF PECIAL FUNDS- SO
WOULDN'T IT WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY BE COMPETING. WITH
OTHER GENERAL FUND RESOURCES-
AND THEN I THINK THAT TWO OTHER
POINTS ALL MAKE MORE BROADLY
ARE NUMBER ONE YEAH I CERTAINLY
I THINK EVERY PROPOSAL OF OURS
AND SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARD TO
THE ORGANIZATION- DESERVE
SCRUTINY. I DO THINK THAT FOR
SOME OF THE KEY PRIORITY AREAS
FOR EXAMPLE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT OR CANNABIS WERE
RIGHT OR SETTING UP A NEW
REGIME- OR SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY RECENT OR SOMETHING WHERE
THE ECONOMY IN THE WORLD IS
CHANGING AND WE WANT TO ADOPT
WITH THAT- WE DO THINK THAT IT
MAKES SENSE. EVEN IF IT DOES
INVOLVE MOVING DEPARTMENTS-
FROM OR DIVISIONS FROM ONE
PLACE TO ANOTHER AND I GUESS
THAT'S WHERE THE BROADER POINT-
WHICH CENTER NIELSEN AND ALSO
MENTIONED IN ITS OWN WAY IT
OFTEN AND GOVERNMENTS WHEN YOU
CREATE SOMETHING. IT STAYS
THERE AND WE CERTAINLY DON'T
WANNA SHUFFLED DEPARTMENTS ARE
A AT AROUND FOR DIVISIONS FOR
THE SECOND SHUFFLING BUT IF IT
DOES MAKE SENSE TO OBJECT
GOVERNMENT FOR THE NEEDS OF THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AD. THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD WANT
TO PROPOSE. CAN THE CONCERN
FIND. OUR PROTECTION BUREAU
USED REGULATION HE WON'T HAVE
MORE REGULATION THIS OBVIOUSLY
I HAVE AN INTEREST IN LICENSING
DIED AND TO INTRODUCE BILL THE
THAT BUT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT REGISTRATION WHAT DO YOU
GUYS AND THE THIS IS THE EARLY
STAGES ON WHAT. DEREGULATION
SCARE SOME PEOPLE OF HER ENOUGH.
MORE REGULATION I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S ACTUALLY GOOD OR WHAT'S
THE GOAL. I SEE MORE LOOKING AT
THE CONSUMER RIGHT YES AND SO
THE FIRST BROADER POINT I'LL
MAKE FOR THIS SPECIFIC ENTITIES
THAT ACTION THIS CASE ALTHOUGH
IT ISN'T THAT I MENTIONED IT
MYSELF ANALOGOUS TO THE CFPB IN
MANY AYS. THE CFPB IS AN
INDEPENDENT FEDERAL BUREAU IN
THIS CASE WE'RE NOT PROPOSING
CREATING A BRAND NEW- AGENCY OR
DEPARTMENT THIS WOULD BE WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT RATHER IT'S GIVING
THAT NEW POSITIONS FORTY FOUR
AS YOU MENTIONED. AND NEW
POWERS WHEN IT COMES TO
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THOSE POWERS
ARE AT I THINK I WOULD SUB
SEPARATE THEM INTO FOUR GENERAL
AREAS IN ONE CERTAINLY IS THIS-
ENFORCEMENT THAT YOU'RE
DISCUSSING AND REGULATION AND
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE OFTEN THINK
ABOUT TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
OCCASION AND- HOLDING PEOPLE TO
ACCOUNT. AND THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT BUT THAT CERTAINLY
NOT THE WHOLE EXTENT OF WHAT
THE GOVERNOR IS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE IN ADDITION-
THERE IS THE AREA OF
SUPERVISION WHICH I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND LICENSING.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH THAT CITY SO THAT
THEY ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAW THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO GO
AFTER THEM WHEN THEY'RE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW- THE
THIRD AREA IS ANALYSIS BECAUSE
THEY'RE A LOT OF PLACES YOU
KNOW. THERE'S FINANCIAL
INNOVATION BUT THERE'S ALSO
FINANCIAL FRAUD INNOVATION AND
PARTICULARLY IN AN ERA THAT WE
LIVE IN WHICH YOU KNOW BLOCK
CHAIN AND FINANCIAL
TECHNOLOGIES WE NEED A
GOVERNMENT- FUNCTION THAT IS
LOOKING AT WE ARE ALL THIS IS
GOING IN ANALYZING WHERE WE
NEED TO PUT MORE RESOURCES AND
NEW TYPES OF PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE TO ATTACK. AND THEN
FINALLY THE LAST AREA BUT
CERTAINLY WE SEE PUBLIC
AWARENESS WHICH IS EASY TO.
DOWN BUT CERTAINLY PEOPLE ARE
APPLYING FOR LOANS ARE APPLYING
FOR FINANCIAL PRODUCTS YOU WANT
TO REGULATE AND SUPERVISE- THE
ENTITY THAT IS PROVIDING THOSE
PRODUCTS BUT IT ALSO HELPS IF
THE CONSUMER THEMSELVES AS AS
EDUCATED AS POSSIBLE AND AS
WARY- AS TO WHAT NOT TOUCH THE
PRICE MIGHT BE VULNERABLE. SO
WE SEE ALL THOSE FUNCTIONS
RELEVANT THIS NEW THE WITHIN TO
BE. OUT SO WHAT'S- THE-
GOVERNOR'S ROCK CLIMB BUDGET SO
WE'RE AT TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR YOUR- FUNNY THING. IS MY-
YEAR. IN THE ON THE BUDGET. AND
EACH YEAR WHETHER WAS BROWN TO
MINUTES. THE NEW SEMESTER. THEY
PROPOSE. REVENUES FROM CAPTAIN
TREAT BEING ABOUT TWO POINT
THREE TWO POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS AND EVERY YEAR SINCE
I'VE BEEN ON THIS BUDGET
COMMITTEE IT COMES IN BETWEEN
THREE POINT FOUR AND THREE
POINT SIX. SO FOR THE MISTER
PATRICK- WHAT ARE YOUR
EXPECTATIONS ON REVENUES
BECAUSE I DIDN'T HEAR ANYTHING
OR READ ANYTHING THAT SOMETHING
IN THE MARKETS CHANGING THAT
WOULD GIVEN THE SIXTEEN DOLLARS
AND SEVENTY THREE CENTS
WHATEVER THE- WHATEVER THE FLOW
OF THE- ALLOWANCES FOR THE COST
IS ON THE BUDGET ONE. IS TO THE
CHANGE THAT WOULD MAKE THE
REVENUES GO DOWN WELL I MEAN I
THINK OUR NUMBERS ARE FAIRLY
SIMILAR TO THE ADMINISTRATION
BRIAN- BRIAN BROWN MY PEOPLE TO
HELP. GOOD MORNING BRIAN. GOOD
MORNING BRIAN BROWN WITH THE LA
L. I OUR- REVENUE ESTIMATES FOR
CAP AND TRADE. ARE PRETTY
SIMILAR TO THE ADMINISTRATION I
THINK WE MIGHT HAVE SOME SLIGHT
DIFFERENCES IN OUR ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT THE- ALLOWANCE PRICES-
BUT BOTH OF OUR MODELS ASSUME
THAT ALL OUR TO SELL- AND THE
CURRENT PRICE IS PRETTY CLOSE
TO THE FLOOR. THERE WERE SOME
HANDS AT LEAST FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR IN THE BUDGET YOU WERE
PRETTY CLOSE. WHAT COULD CHANGE
GOING FORWARD IS REALLY- THE
THAT THAT PRICE SO IF ALLOWING
PRICES GO UP SIGNIFICANTLY THAT
WILL GENERATE MORE REVENUE. OF
COURSE REMIND MEMBERS SAY 60%
OF. CAP AND TRADE REVENUES ARE
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED SO
WHATEVER ADDITIONAL REVENUES
COME IN IT LESS THAN HALF THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR. THOSE
THE DISCRETIONARY-
EXPENDITURES- WE WILL HAVE TO
MORE OPTIONS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR SO WE WILL KNOW BEFORE THE
END OF THE FISCAL YEAR WHAT THE
EXACT. LEVEL REVENUE IS- THAT'S
AVAILABLE- GOING INTO THE NEW
FISCAL YEAR BUT OF COURSE IT IS
A PROJECTION GOING FORWARD
AFTER THAT. YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE IN THEIR WISDOM
WHEN THEY SET UP THE CAPTAIN
TREAT THEY GAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH. DEAR
RESOURCE BOARD RIGHT NOW HAS
THE AUTHORITY TODAY TO SET THE
PRICE OF THE ALLOWANCES BUT
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS BUDGET
THAT WOULD SUGGEST. A SIGNAL TO
THE MARKET THAT WE MAY BE
CHANGED RAISING THE PRICE OF
THE ALL OF THE OPTIONS. YOU
KNOW THERE'S A BIG DISCUSSION
OUT THERE ON THE PRICE OF
CARBON SOME WOULD ARGUE THAT
16% ISN'T BEERS AT SIXTEEN
DOLLARS IS EMBARRASSINGLY LOW.
YOU'VE HEARD REPORTS WITH THE
LA- THAT HAVE SUGGEST THAT WE
SHOULD BE IN THE FIFTY TO
SIXTY. DOLLARS HOW DO YOU HAVE
A CLIMATE POLICY OVER FIVE
YEARS FOR TWELVE. MILLION THE
TO GIVE US A HAND. OF WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO DO WITH SETTING
THE PRICE. SO THAT'S JUST A
QUESTION BECAUSE YOU COULD COME
BACK FOR ON THIS CLIMATE AND
YOU COULD COME BACK TO SEPT TWO
BUT THERE'S IT IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S A MEAGER AMOUNT OF
REVENUE WHICH YOU CONTROL.
RIGHT NOW YOU COULD SAY TWENTY
ONE DOLLARS AND THE NEXT
OPTION. WOULD NOT ACCEPTING ANY
BITS AND THAT WOULD SEND THE
PRICE THE MARKET WOULD ALSO
SEND THE PRICE FOR WHAT THE
REVENUES MAY BE FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THE
20% AND ALL THESE OTHER LITTLE.
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO INCREASE
FOR THE LAST EIGHTY BE LITTLE
QUESTION. PUBLIC THE FINES IN
TRAFFIC- FOR THE INDIGENT
HERE'S LOOKING AT ELEVEN
MILLION. DOLLARS I THINK WAS
THAT ALL THE DOLLARS SOB BUT
IT'S LIKE. THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE THAT THE COURTS.
COLLECT IS GIGANTIC I MEAN IT'S-
I DIDN'T SEE THAT THE OFFSET
THE LOSS THAT THE IF THE- ALLOW
INDIGENT PEOPLE NOT TO PAY
THEIR FINES WITCH HUNTS GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY. IT'S MUCH MORE
THAN ELEVEN MILLION WE'RE WHAT
IS THE COURTS TO WHAT THE.
MISSING GAP OF WHAT THEY'RE
WHAT THEY'RE NOT COLLECTING IN
THE ELEVEN MILLION THIS PEN
IDENTIFIED YES SO I WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT PROGRAM WE'RE
PROPOSING AND THEN MY COLLEAGUE
ANNE JARVIS- MAY AT SOME
COMMENTS AS WELL SO. YOU ARE
RIGHT WHEN YOU ADD UP ALL THESE
FINES AND FEES FOR YOU KNOW
WE'RE TALKING IN EXCESS OF A
BILLION DOLLARS RIGHT IN SO
THIS IS YOU KNOW A SMALL PART
OF THAT I THINK OF WHAT WE
GOVERNOR'S POPOSING IS NUMBER
ONE EXPANDING A PILOT WHICH WAS
A PILOT PROGRAMS. THAT STARTED
LAST YEAR IT WAS FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS AND THE FINES AND
FEES ASSOCIATED WITH THAT FOR
LOW INCOME AN INDIVIDUAL
INDIGENT INDIVIDUALS OR
INTERACTING WITH THE COURT
SYSTEM- SO THIS WOULD EXPAND
THAT PILOTS STATEWIDE- EXPANDED
TO INCLUDE SOME NON TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS CONTINUE TO FOCUS
ON. LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS- BUT
THIS IS CERTAINLY NOT A
PROPOSAL- TO WHITE SUEDE
COMPLETELY CLEAN WHEN IT COMES
TO THOSE FINES AND FEES-
BECAUSE THAT WOULD TAKE THE
LEVEL FUNDING THAT YOU WERE
DESCRIBING IT'S RATHER TO EASE
THE BURDEN AND INCREASE THE
RELIEF THAT WE'RE PROVIDING TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS OVER TIME.
SIR SERVICE TO. FINANCE AND-
THE ONLY OTHER THING I WANTED
TO ADD WAS THAT THAT ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IS THE PORTION
RELATIVE TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND IT DOES GO TO FIFTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. AND OVER AT
OVER THE FORECAST PERIOD AND WE
DO THINK THAT THIS IS- OR THE
NUMBER I'M SORRY THE REVENUE
BACK FILL IS BASED ON THE PILOT
TODAY AND ITS OPERATING ONLY IN
FOR COURT SO- HARD TO. JUDGE
WHETHER OR NOT AND- THIS IS THE
RIGHT AMOUNT BUT WILL ADJUST AS
WE GO FORWARD BUT SINCE FOR
EXPANDING TO ALL COURTS AND WE-
THE- IT. PHASES ANIMALS OUT
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
THAT'S THE BACK FILL OR
EXPECTING. THANK YOU SIR
SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR HI AND WELCOME BACK MR
RESPONSE ON AND- MISTER PECK
THANK YOU FOR THE FEEDBACK. TWO
ISSUES I WANT TO FOCUS ON FIRST.
ONE IS FOR THE CONTINUE TO
CLIMB A CONVERSATION THAT
CENTER Y. CASKEY STARTED- WITH
A LITTLE DIFFERENT LANES I KNOW
LAST. LAST YEAR WE HAD IT IS
THE SAME OVERVIEW HEARING IN.
MY QUESTION IS STILL THE SAME.
WHICH IS VIEWING CLIMATE IN A
FISCAL LENDS NOT JUST AS A
CATEGORY FOR EXPENDITURES HER
FOR MITIGATION BUT LOOKING AT
IT AS A LIABILITY I CAN TO
OTHER LIABILITIES AND DEBTS WE
HAVE IS A STATE THAT. WILL IN
THEORY GROW SUBSTANTIALLY OVER
TIME I KNOW WE DO A PRETTY
THOROUGH ANALYSIS ON OUR
PENSIONS AND RETIREMENT- OTHER
DEBTS THAT- ME A CREW OVER
OVER- COURSE OF DECADES. BUT MY
BIG CONCERN IS THAT. WE'VE NOT
YET TO MY KNOWLEDGE ANALYZED
WHAT CLIMATE WRIT LARGE COULD
POSE TO THE STATE BUDGET- I
KNOW THAT THE FOURTH CLIMATE
ASSESSMENT DID SORT OF LOOK AT
SOME VERY HIGH LEVEL NUMBERS IS
A STATE FOR WHAT WE COULD BE
SEEING SAY OUT TO TWENTY FIFTY
OR EVEN THE TWENTY ONE HUNDRED-
BUT I'M WONDERING IF ANY
FURTHER ANALYSIS HAS BEEN DONE-
SAY ON THE- THIS YEAR BASIS BUT
MAYBE ON A FIVE OR TEN YEAR
PROJECTION OF. WHAT KIND OF
UNFORESEEN EXPENDITURES WE
MIGHT BE FACING IF WE DON'T
JUST GET YOUR FIRES BUT WE ALSO
GET A YEAR OF FIRES AND A YEAR
WITH A SUPER FLOOD- ON TOP OF
THAT DROUGHT. USGS I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'VE SEEN SOME OF THEIR
RECENT PROJECTIONS BUT YOU KNOW
THEIR MODEL THEY MODEL ARC
STORM RIGHT WHICH IS JUST ONE
FLOOD INCIDENT ALONE SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR EVENT MEANTIME AT THE
MOST CATASTROPHIC EVENT. IN THE
NATION IS SITTING RIGHT HERE
STARTING IN SACRAMENTO IF WE
GET THE WRONG KIND OF
ATMOSPHERE COLLISION ALL THE
SAME TIME. THAT'S AN EXTREME
EXAMPLE BUT IT'S A LIKELIHOOD
ACCORDING THEIR MODELING- AND
SO. WHAT WHAT EFFORTS HAVE WE
MADE THIS SORT OF ANALYZE WHAT
THOSE LONG TERM LIABILITIES
COULD BE AND PLAN FOR THEM
BECAUSE I'M LOOKING HERE. AT
THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT OR EVEN THE SFE YOU
RIGHT SPECIAL FUND FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES WHERE IT A
PROPOSED ONE POINT SIX BILLION
OVERALL SAFETY NET INCLUDED
ABOUT TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BILLION. OKAY YOU ADD FIRE AND
FLOOD ALONE HE WIPED THAT
FORGET RAINY DAY FUND FLOOD
FUND  WIPE
SO WE STARTED LOOKING AT THIS
QUESTION THROUGH A DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SURE SO I CAN SPEAK
TO THAT SO WE'RE CERTAINLY
THINKING SERIOUSLY ABOUT ALL
THE RISKS- I DON'T KNOW THAT WE
HAD THE KIND OF THAT
QUANTIFICATION EFFORT THAT I
KNOW GUY YOU'VE DISCUSSED BUT
ONE THING I WILL SAY THAT IS
DIFFERENT FOR THIS YEAR. IS
THAT I KNOW CENTER WHAT BECAUSE
HE TALKED ABOUT THE CLIMATE
BUDGET AND THAT SOME THAT'S NOT
A TERM THAT WE'VE USED LAST
YEAR THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE SEEN
BEFORE AND THE REASON WE WANTED
TO PUT ALL THOSE THINGS
TOGETHER IS BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW
THIS PRIORITIES IMPORTANT THAT
PRIORITIES IMPORTANT WE
ACTUALLY WANTED TO LOOK AT
EVERYTHING TOGETHER AND THAT
WAY. WE ARE BASICALLY IN OUR
PROPOSED SPENDING PLAN MAKING
AN ASSESSMENT OF WHAT THE RISKS
REALLY ARE AND WHERE WE'RE
PUTTING A LOT OF MONEY AND SO
THE THREE COMPONENTS OF THAT
ARE THAT CLIMATE CATALYST FIND
CAP AND TRADE AND THEN THE
PROPOSED CLIMATE RESILIENCE
BOND AND I KNOW THERE'S ALSO A
PROPOSAL IN THE SENATE FOR
SOMEWHERE BOND AND SO IF YOU
LOOK AT THE ALLOCATION. OF OUR
MONEY AMONG THOSE THREE POCKETS
THAT'S WHERE YOU GET THE SENSE
OF HOW THE MINISTRATION SEEING
THEIR BREASTS AND WHERE WE WANT
TO INVEST WE KNOW THAT THE
FINAL APPLICATION AS WELL AS
THE LEVEL OF THAT CLIMB RESULT
FUNDING PARTICULAR WILL DEPEND
ON THE- SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY.
COMMENTS HERE. ONE ONE THING I
DON'T THAT WE THE THIS TIME
NECESSARILY A GLOBAL LONG TERM
ESTIMATE OF THE LATE OF KIND
THAT YOU REFERRING TO BUT WHAT
A COUPLE OF POINTS I WOULD MAKE
IT- WE DID TAKE THAT THE
POTENTIAL FOR SOME KIND OF A
NATURAL DISASTER OCCURRING INTO
ACCOUNT WHEN WE DID OUR FISCAL
OUTLOOK IN NOVEMBER AND THERE
IS THE YOU KNOW THE LIKELIHOOD
OF GETTING- FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS TO FEMA SO WE
ADDED. A BILLION OR TWO TO THE
CAUSTIC COULD COME IN BE FELT
BY THE STATE GENERAL FUND AND
YOU KNOW I THINK JUST TO KIND
OF REITERATE- POINT THAT EVEN
ONE OR TWO OF THOSE KIND OF
EVENTS COULD JEOPARDIZE THE
OPERATING SURPLUS JUST IN THE
NEAR TERM AND THAT'S ONLY ONE.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE RISKS THAT
ARE OUT THERE- BUT CERTAINLY
YOU KNOW I THINK MORE
INFORMATION. OF THE KIND THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
PROBABLY YOU KNOW VERY
IMPORTANT. I THINK WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO DRILL DOWN FURTHER ON
THAT AND SUBSEQUENT HEARINGS
AND I KNOW OF I THINK OUR OUR
FIRST SPECIFIC HEARING WILL BE
ON CLIMATE SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN.
SO WILL DRILL DOWN MORE ON THAT
THEN BUT- I WOULD I WOULD JUST
CLOSE AT THAT POINT BY SAYING.
THE REACTIVE INSERT A
RESPONSIVE CAPACITY DO DISASTER
IS ONE THING ANSWER TO HAVING
THAT SURGE CAPACITY BUILT IN
SAY WE GET. AN INCIDENT I MEAN
I THINK WE DID FIVE BILLION
LAST YEAR IN WILD FIRE RESPONSE
OF WE GET HIT. OUT OF THE BLUE
WITH ANOTHER SERIES FIRES IN A
FLOOD. IF TO COME UP WITH
FIFTEEN BUT I'M REALLY
INTERESTING HOW WE BY DOWN THAT
RISK. RIGHT AND LOOKING AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BOND PROPOSAL
THROUGH THAT LENS THAT'S REALLY
HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE. TRYING
TO ANALYZE IT FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND I THINK THAT
REALLY OUGHT TO BE THE TEST. IF
YOU'RE GONNA SPEND FIVE BILLION
HOW MUCH RISK YOU ACTUALLY
GONNA BUY DOWN SEEM AS MATH IS
FOR EVERY DOLLAR SPENT N
DISASTER. AVOIDANCE YOU'RE
GOING TO SAVEABOUT SIX DOLLARS
ON THE BACK IT RIGHT IN
DISASTER RESPONSE MUCH EASIER
PREVENT ONE. THAT ACTUALLY
EXPERIENCE ONE SO- THANK YOU
FOR LOOKING FURTHER AT THAT
AND- YEAH WE'LL BE FOLLOWING UP
SOON AND I THINK YOU'VE GOT A
LETTER IN YOUR YOUR- I THINK IT
MS FOSLER ACTUALLY IS A LETTER
ON THIS FRONT WITH A LITTLE
MORE DETAIL. YEAH MISTER PECK
I'M SERIOUS NO I WAS JUST GOING
TO ADD I MEAN I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT- POINT THAT CONNECTS
BACK TO Y. THING TO THE YOU MAY
WANT TO THINK ABOUT THE-
WEATHER. YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE LEVEL RESERVES FOR
PROPOSED A THE GOVERNOR AND THE
BUDGET BECAUSE- RIGHT NOW OUR
TOTAL RESERVE LEVEL. IS NOT
REALLY DIFFERENTIATING AMONG
THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF RISKS
THAT THE STATE COULD FACE
WHETHER IT'S- CAN. FEDERAL
APPROVAL FOR. I'M CIOTAT YOU.
YOU KNOW. THE THAT THE KINDS OF
REST YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SENATOR YEAH AND EVEN JUST BILL
THAT CAN AND LIKE I SAW THAT
YOU ANALYZE TO. BASED ON SAVES
NCO TAX APPROVAL. WHAT IF
THERE'S FOR MORE FIRES AND
FLOODS YOU KNOW HOW DO WE SORT
OF AT LEAST GOING THROUGH THE
SENSITIVITY ANALYSIS- LAST
THING I WOULD JUST ADD AND
THANKS FOR THE INTELLIGENCE
MANAGER BUT- YES THERE IS A
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE OVERSIGHT
HEARING ALREADY- WITH DOCTOR
PANS. DOES SUBCOMMITTEE LOOKING
AT- DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICES AND I I'D I DON'T KNOW
DID MISTER DID YOU TESTIFY
THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN SOMEONE
ELSE SAID ADD. TO JUST WANT TO
GET YOUR HIGH LEVEL TAKE HIS
WRIST WANT ON ON- I THINK
DOCTOR PAN IT'S SORT OF ASKED
ABOUT THE FEASIBILITY OF
PUTTING TOGETHER- A PLAN. TO
LOOK AT THE RATE STUDY
IMPLEMENTATION AND HOW WE
ACTUALLY START TO MEET THIS.
HUGE GAP WERE FRANKLY FACING ON
DELIVERING THOSE SERVICES SO
JUST TO GET A SENSE- SO WE
DON'T SIR TO CHASE IT YEAR
AFTER YEAR BUT- WHEN YOU GET
YOUR FEEL FOR THE FEASIBILITY
OF PUTTING THAT KIND OF PLAN
TOGETHER TO GIVE OURSELVES- A
RUNWAY FOR HOW WE ACTUALLY FILL
THIS GAP AND- NOT. CREATE FALSE
HOPE IN A GOOD YEAR AND THEN
DASH EVERYONE'S HOPES IN IN IN
THE YEAR AFTER THIS VERY
VULNERABLE PEOPLE COUNTING ON
US HERE SO I'LL MAKE TWO
COMMENTS AND THEN MY CALLING
THE ELABORATE AS WELL I THINK
THE FIRST IS THAT. THE LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET ACT INCLUDED A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND IT'LL BE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS- FOR THESE
RATE INCREASES. AND THEN THERE
WERE THREE SERVICE CODES THAT
WERE NOT FUNDED TO THIS BUDGET
INCLUDES NEARLY ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON TOP OF THAT AND SO
THAT WILL HELP US MAKE PROGRESS
ON THE RATE- STUDY INCREASES
THAT YOU MENTIONED WE ALSO HAVE
ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR
PERFORMANCE BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
THAT'S ALL. THAT'S THE PURPOSE
OF INCREASING RATES AS WELL AS
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO SERVICES
AND GET BETTER PERFORMANCE
METRICS AND OUTCOMES FOR
PEOPLE- BUT THE SECOND THING ON
THE LONGER TERM YOU KNOW WE'RE
VERY CONSCIOUS OF THIS AND- YOU
KNOW WE KNOW WE HAVE THE
SUSPENSIONS IN THE BUDGET ACT
LAST YEAR. AND THOSE HAVE BEEN
DELAYED NOW BY EIGHTEEN MONTHS
TO THE SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE BUT WE CERTAINLY SEE THAT
ON THE CALENDAR AND WE WANT TO
FIND A WAY WHERE THAT STATE
GOVERNMENT WOULD NOT HAVE TO DO
THAT- SO WE'RE CONSTANTLY
UPDATING OUR PROJECTIONS BOTH
IN TERMS OF THE GENERAL MULTI
YEAR. AND SPECIFICALLY THIS
CATEGORY SPENDING TO SEE WHAT
WE CAN DO OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS AND TURN OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AS WELL. NOTHING FOR
THE TO ADD SPECIFIC JUST TO.
REITERATE THE POINT THAT THE
RATES THAT HE HAS ALREADY
INFORMED INVESTMENTS THAT WERE
MADE THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT AS WELL AS WITH PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND THE
RACE THAT HE HAS INFORMED THE
NEED TO. LOOK AT SYSTEM REFORM
HOLISTICALLY AND THAT'S WHAT
KIND OF. ENCOURAGE THE
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
THAT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER.
THANK YOU FOR THE TO SKINNER
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR PAN. THANK
YOU- MADAM CHAIR PRE SHE EIGHT
FIVE I KNOW ALL OF US ARE.
GETTING READY FOR OUR- GOOD AND
THOROUGH PROCESS OF REVIEWING
THIS THROUGH OUR SUBCOMMITTEES
AND THIS BUDGET COMMITTEE AS A
WHOLE AND APPRECIATE THIS
INITIAL OVERVIEW SO I WANT TO
THANK- ARE. DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE BUDGET FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MISTER VISITS WERE NOT
THEN AND ALSO- MISTER PATRICK
FROM OUR ILIO FOR YOUR
OVERVIEWS ADDITIONALLY AND I
JUST WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
KIND OF COMMENTS AND THEN. A
FEW SPECIFICS- SO I APPRECIATE
THE ALEJO'S WARNING ABOUT NEW
ON GOING SPENDING AND THE
ESTIMATE FOR- YOU KNOW THAT
SOME OF IT. MAY BE JUST WHAT IT
WOULD LOOK LIKE IN THE FUTURE
BUT WHAT I THINK WOULD ALSO BE
VERY HELPFUL. I CAN'T SPEAK FOR
THERE'S MY COLLEAGUES RELEASE
FOR ME IS THAT SOME OF THE
SPENDING. IS A POTENTIALLY
PREDICATED ON SOME REDUCTIONS
THAT WE WOULD BE CHIEF AND I
KNOW THAT THOSE AREN'T ALWAYS
IT'S HARD TO- IT'S MUCH EASIER
TO MAKE THE BALLOT SHEET
SHOWING THE EXPENDITURES VERSES
THE COST REDUCTIONS O I JUST
GIVE THE PRISON CLOSURE AS AN
EXAMPLE THERE MAY BE OTHERS BUT
I THINK IT'S WORTH IT FOR US TO
SEE AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE
BALANCING HEY WAIT A MINUTE MAY
WE SHOULDN'T PURSUE. NEW
SPENDING. IN WHAT WAYS ARE NEW
INVESTMENTS POTENTIALLY GOING
TO BRING DOWN OUR COSTS IN THE
FUTURE. AND THEN ADDITIONALLY
WHEN I LOOK AT SOME OF THE
PROPOSED NEW EXPENDITURES.
THERE REALLY VERY RESPONSIVE TO
CALIFORNIANS- YOU KNOW AT A
VERY STRONG DESIRES IF WE LOOK
AT POLLS IF WE LOOK AT OUR OWN
EXPERIENCE IN OUR DISTRICTS
WHETHER IT'S- THE- HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS WHICH AGAIN IS. ACROSS
THE STATE. REALLY BUT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE SAID LOUD AND
CLEAR WE WANT THIS FIXED WE
WANT THIS ADDRESSED. AND THEN I
THINK BACK WHILE ALIVE- WELL I
CAN'T TURN TO A PARTICULAR POLL
AT THIS MOMENT AROUND. DRUG
COSTS I THINK WE COLLECTIVELY
KNOWN IF WE WERE TO DO ONE
TOMORROW- NOBODY LOOKS THEIR
HIGH COST OF DRUGS. AND AIDING
WE KNOW THAT OUR OWN ANALYSIS
OF THE COSTA MEDI CAL. DUE TO
THESE REALLY OUTRAGEOUS
PRESCRIPTION COSTS AND WE'VE
NOT GOTTEN THE TYPE OF
REDUCTIONS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROMISED US WE'VE
NOT GOTTEN THOSE SO I THINK IT
IS VERY RESPONSIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA IF WE CAN ACHIEVE
IT. TO MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION
AND COULD GIVE US SOME COST
REDUCTIONS SO. I'VE THE
INTEREST I HAVE IS BOTH IN WHAT
WAYS MIGHT SOME OF THIS NEW
SPENDING BRING US DOWN COSTS
AND THEN ADDITIONALLY THE MAYBE
THIS ISN'T FOR IMMEDIATE. BUT
WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR A THIS NEWS.
COULD INCREASE ONGOING GENERAL
FUND THAT'S THE ASSUMPTION THAT
WE'RE JUST GOING TO KEEP ON
GOING GENERAL FUND AS IT IS AND
I THINK IT'S ALWAYS WORTH IT TO
LOOK BACK AT THERE COULD BE
SOME. SOME ONGOING GENERAL FUND
CLEARLY NOT IN K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS NOT IN A FEW OTHER
AREAS BUT THAT ARE KIND OF
REDUNDANT NOW OR NOT REALLY YOU
KNOW AS MUCH AS WE KNOW THAT WE
NEED SOME NEW SPENDING IN SOME
AREAS THAT RE REALLY. DIRE
NEEDS NOW MAYBE THERE'S SOME
SPENDING THAT ISN'T AND OF
COURSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
PRESSURE TO MAKE A CUT AT THE
MOMENT AS WE DID DURING THE
RECESSION BUT IDENTIFYING WHICH
ONES WHICH AREAS MAYBE DON'T
HAVE AS MUCH JUSTIFICATION NOW
SO AS WE THINK INTO THE FUTURE.
THAT WAY I THINK WOULD BE
HELPFUL. FIVE AND FOR ALL GIVE
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF WHAT I THINK.
THE A YOU KNOW AGAIN WE HAVE TO
GET IN OUR WHOLE DISCUSSION AS
A LEGISLATURE BUT I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT OF EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION. I THINK THAT THE
RESEARCH SHOWS US THAT
CALIFORNIA. DIRECTING BEING
SMARTER ABOUT INVESTMENTS THERE
WHILE IT WON'T GIVE US BUDGET
SAVINGS IN A SINGLE YEAR. COULD
IN FACT GIVE US GREAT
REDUCTIONS IN OUR IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION SPENDING FOR EXAMPLE
IF WE IF QUALITY EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION HELPS US IDENTIFY
KIDS SPECIAL NEED MOM FAR
EARLIER. COULD GIVE US GREAT
REDUCTIONS IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AGAIN WE KNOW THAT- MANY OF OUR
FOLKS WHETHER THEY'RE IN JAIL
OR PRISON. IF THEY HAD THE- FOR
EXAMPLE. CAN'T READ THEY DON'T
HAVE FULL LITERACY SO WHAT HOW
I MEAN HOW ONE COULD IMAGINE
BEING ABLE TO FUNCTION WELL IN
OUR CULTURE SO IF YOU IF YOU IF
OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM AND I'M NOT
TRYING TO POINT FINGERS AT OUR
SCHOOLS BUT AGAIN IF YOU HAD A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE. THAT WAS
NOT ADDRESSED OR TENDED TO
WHICH THEN BASICALLY YOUR
MASKING AND LEAD TO YOU CANNOT-
FUNCTION WITHIN OUR JOB TYPE
BASED ECONOMY AND EVERYTHING IN
A WAY THAT. YOU CAN PUT YOU IN
SITUATIONS THAT LATER COST US A
LOT. SO I THINK THAT THOSE
KINDS OF NEW DEPARTMENTS AND
AGAIN WE STILL HAVE TO DEBATED
WORKING THROUGH MIGHT BE
EXACTLY THE THING THAT THE
STATE NEEDS RIGHT NOW TO BE
MORE ATTUNED TO WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT. HUMAN DEVELOPMENT IN THE
BECAUSE OF CERTAIN OF OUR OTHER
LATER. LATER INCREASED EXPENSES
WHETHER IN SOCIAL SERVICE AREAS
EDUCATION AREAS OR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SERIOUS AND SIMILARLY.
ARE MOVE TOWARDS THE CHANGES IN
JUVENILE JUSTICE AGAIN WE WE'RE
WE ARE MAKING THE- ALL THEN
WHEN USE GAMBLE THOUGH I SAID
IT ALREADY. BUT WE THE RESEARCH
SHOWS US THAT A LOT OF YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE THEY ARE NOT
INCORRIGIBLE AND SO THE
APPROPRIATE INVESTMENTS TO MOVE
THEM AWAY FROM A BAD DECISION
THEY MAY HAVE MADE CAN
REPURPOSE GREAT BENEFITS INTO
THE FUTURE THAT'S WHAT THE
RESEARCH IN THE DATA SHOWS AND
THAT'S HOW I SEE THIS MOVEMENT
INVESTMENTS IN. THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM REFORMS THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING AND SWITCHING
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE TO HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE
BUT I THINK THAT THAT IT WOULD
HELP US TO HAVE SOME ANALYSIS
THAT IS MORE THAN JUST O. OKAY
LOOK BETTER WATCH. BY YOUR
INCREASED ONGOING EXPENDITURES
SO THAT'S KIND OF MY GENERAL
COMMENT THEN SOME SPECIFICS-
VERY HAPPY THAT OUR K. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS. HAVE GREAT
INCREASE SPENDING OF COURSE WE
KNOW EVEN WITH OUR YOU KNOW
EVEN WITH A GOOD GENERAL FUND
OUR PER PUPIL SPENDING IS STILL
NOT WHAT IS REALLY NEEDED I
DON'T KNOW HOW WE ADDRESS THAT
WITHOUT SOME REAL STRUCTURAL
CHANGES WITHIN OUR WHOLE
REVENUE SYSTEM BUT I'M VERY
HAPPY TO SEE THE INCREASES. AND
I WANT TO END THE INCREASE TO
SPECIAL ED. VERY IMPORTANT AND
THEN ADDITIONALLY WASN'T
MENTIONED IN OUR OVERVIEW BUT I
NOTICED THERE'S A PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AROUND.
AN INCREASE TO THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR SCHOOL
MEALS. AND I THINK AGAIN THAT
ONE IS- IS ONE OF THOSE WHERE
YEAH IT'S INCREASE SPENDING BUT
AGAIN WE KNOW THAT A LARGE
PERCENT OF OUR KIDS. GET MOST
OF THEIR MEALS AT SCHOOL SO
THEY'RE IN THE FACT RECEIVING
THEIR CALORIES AND NUTRITION AT
SCHOOL SO IF WE CAN. ENSURE
THAT THAT CALORIES IN THE
NUTRITION IS THE HIGHEST
QUALITY WE KNOW WE WILL GET
BETTER HEALTH AND EDUCATION
OUTCOME SO I JUST WANT TO KNOW
THAT I WAS REALLY HAPPY TO SEE
THAT- IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
IN OUR- RELY ON OUR ON BUDGET I
THINK SO OF ONE CHAIR TO BE
GETTING INTO SOME OF THESE
DETAILS BUT I NOTICED THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. AND FOR
ONE I'LL BE INTERESTED TO SEE
WHETHER THOSE WHERE THERE THAT
PROPOSAL IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
IS GEOGRAPHIC SPECIFIC OR JUST
ALL ACROSS THE STATE. AND I
NOTED BECAUSE- WE- LAST YEAR.
WE HAD WE LOTS OF JOB GROWTH
AND WHAT TO JOBS. IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE HAVE LOW UNEMPLOYMENT
BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
LOW WAGE JOBS AND THERE'S
GROWTH IN HIGHER WAGE JOBS AND
IF WE CAN TAILOR. AND I'M
ASSUMING THAT THAT'S WHAT THE
PURPOSE OF THESE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARE IF WE CAN TAILOR
MORE OF OUR- JOB TRAINING AND
APPRENTICESHIPS TOWARDS THOSE
HIGHER WAGE JOBS. THEN WE CAN
ASSIST. THE FOLKS IN OUR STATE
UNFORTUNATELY SO MANY THAT ARE
IN THESE LOW WAGE JOBS AND I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S SURGICAL. AND SO I'LL- IS
IT'S NOT MY SEVEN COMMITTEE I
WILL ASK MY- CHAIR OF THAT TO
DIG DOWN INTO THAT TO HELP SOME
OF US. IN A MAKING OUR DECISION
AROUND IT- AND THEN IN THE
CLIMATE BUDGET. AGAIN I'M NOT
OPPOSED TO NEW AREAS OF
SPENDING THEIR OR EVEN TO AN
INCREASE IN OUR AUCTION REVENUE
BUT I WAS A LITTLE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE REDUCTIONS IN AB SIX
SEVENTEEN FUNDING. THE
REDUCTIONS IN MONIES THAT WILL
HELP MOVE US OFF FOSSIL FUEL TO
DIESEL AND THE REDUCTIONS-
WHICH WHICH INCLUDED SOME OF
THE ACT THINGS BUT ALSO THE
HEAVY AND MEDIUM DUTY DUTY
VEHICLES. ARM AND ARE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND THE
REASON I RAISE IT IS BECAUSE
NOT ONLY ARE THOSE AREAS STILL
HUGE CONTRIBUTORS TO OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS PROBLEMS. THEY
ARE THE AREAS THAT MAKE ART
HERE THE MOST UNHEALTHY AND WE
STILL HAVE IN CALIFORNIA IF WE
TAKE THE TEN CITIES ACROSS THE
US WITH THE WORST AIR POLLUTION
SEVEN OF THEM ARE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT REDUCTIONS IN
THE G. G. R. F. THAT ARE THAT
WILL ALSO HURT OUR OUTCOMES
FROM AIR QUALITY- AND THEN
LASTLY ON THE HOMELESSNESS. YOU
KNOW RIGHT NOW MOST OF IT. IT'S
NOT JUST ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS WHO ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ALREADY HOMELESS BUT ALSO
IT IS KEEPING OUR CALIFORNIANS
HOUSED WHO MIGHT BE ON THE
BRINK BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THAT
INVESTMENT AND I'M VERY GLAD
GOVERNOR RECOGNIZED IT AND THAT
THE- COMMITTEE THAT. OF MAYOR
STEINBERG AND- THE LA COUNTY
YES A RIDLEY THOMAS ARE TEARING
HAVE ALSO RECOGNIZED THAT
INVESTMENTS IN KEEPING FOLKS
HOUSE IS REALLY SMART REALLY
WISE. BUT I KNOW THAT MOST OF
IT IN THIS BUDGET IS ONE TIME.
WE'RE NOT GONNA SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM IN THIS YEAR THAT MAY
BE AN AREA THAT NEEDS TO BE ON
GOING SO I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT.
THREE IN THE EXPECTATION ABOUT
A RESPONSE- SKINNER FROM IF
THEY WANT TO BUT OTHERWISE IT'S
A MORE A MORE. MY OVERVIEW.
ALRIGHT WE WILL TAKE ALL THAT
FEEDBACK BACK TO OUR IS
DEPENDING- THE COMMON AND SEEMS
WHETHER IT WOULD BE OKAY IF THE
LA- FELT LIKE THEY COULD DO THE
KIND OF. THAT KIND OF EXERCISE.
YES SENATOR SKINNER I THINK
WHAT YOU ARE RAISING IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT- CONCEPT. AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I MAY NOT
IN- YOU KNOW RETICULATED WELL
ENOUGH BUT THAT WE- WE DO THINK
THAT MANY OF THESE PROPOSALS
HAVE MERIT. MANY OF THEM HAVE-
PROBABLY AN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
GOALS OF THE LEGISLATURE IS
EXPRESSED PREVIOUSLY AND EVEN.
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA AND
THAT DID CALIFORNIANS AS WE SEE
IT TOO. I THINK WHAT. I WAS
JUST RACINE IS THAT. THERE IS
KIND OF A WIDE RANGE OF
PROPOSALS MANY OF THEM I THINK
WE'RE STILL AWAITING SOME OF
THE DETAILS ABOUT HOW THEY
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED AND SO
WE'RE JUST RAISING THE QUESTION
OR THAT THE POINT TO KEEP IN
MIND THAT WOULD USE THEM LOOK
AT THE ESTIMATES BEFORE YOU
THEY DON'T TAKE ANY OF THAT
INTO ACCOUNT YET. AND TO THE
EXTENT WE HAVE THE DATA THAT
COULD SUPPORT IT SOME OF THE
TYPES OF NEAR TERM SPENDING
THAT GENERATE LONG TERM SAVINGS
SOME OF THOSE ARE VERY HARD TO.
IT IS YOU KNOW VALIDATE- IN IN
DATA BUT BUT TO THE EXTENT WE
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT WE WILL BE
HAPPY TO TRADE INCORPORATED SO.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN. I THANK
YOU SO MUCH A MADAM CHAIR AND
AGAIN OUR THANKS- BOTH OF YOU
FOR BEING HERE. I THINK. SPREAD
ECCA I THINK YOU'RE STAFF IF
THEY HAVE BEEN RE TOLD YOU KNOW
THAT I ASKED THIS VERY QUESTION
ALL THE TIME LIKE OKAY WHAT
HAPPENS IF WE MAKE THE
INVESTMENT WHAT'S THE OUT YEARS
WHAT HAPPENS WE DON'T MAKE THE
INVESTMENT THE OUT YEAR AND- I
AGREE WITH YOU CAN BE DIFFICULT
TO SOMEONE WHO DOES HEALTH
SERVICES RESEARCH BY SAID EVEN
THAT'S BUT EVEN HOLDING A VERY
HIGH STANDARD FOR THE QUALITY
OF DATA RIGHT AND SAY- THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE
SAVINGS THROUGH INVESTMENT SO
WE THINK ABOUT- HOW DO WE
PREPARE FOR THE NEXT ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN CERTAINLY AND I'VE
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF IN A
MANY OF US. AND WE HAVE A RAINY
DAY FUND SO FORTH BUT ALSO THIS
IS THE TIME YOU WANT TO INVEST
IN MAKING THE KIND OF CHANGES
THAT THAT LEAD TO LOWER
EXPENDITURES LATER ON THAT'S
ANOTHER WAY OF TRYING TO-
PREPARE FOR DOWNTURN AS WELL-
NOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE SEVERAL
BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARINGS ON
VERY SPECIFIC TOPICS LIKE
HOMELESS SO FORTH SO I WHY WHY
FOCUS MY COMMENTS AND ACTUALLY
QUESTIONS ON- HERE TODAY IS
REALLY SORT OF THE OUT YEARS
pBUDGET PROCESS WERE MAINLY
LOOKING AT. THE PROPOSED BUDGET
FOR THIS COMING YEAR BUT- YOU
KNOW ALSO COVERING BEHIND THAT
IS THE OUT YEARS AND SOMETIMES
IT USES AN ARGUMENT FOR AGAINST
A PARTICULAR BUDGET PROPOSAL
SO- I THINK- AGAIN I KNOW THAT
MY GOOD FRIEND- CENTER SKINNER
I MENTIONED THE HOMELESSNESS I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR PUTTING
THAT INVESTMENT LOOKING FORWARD
TO HEARING THE DETAILS WE'LL
TALK ABOUT BUT THAT MORE HERE-
FUTURE COMMITTEE HEARING BUT.
THE IDEA THAT IT'S GONNA BE A
ONE YEAR. I THINK IS THAT AND
SAYING THAT AS PROJECT A BUDGET
OUT YOU. THAT WOULD GO DO THIS
IS A ONE YEAR THING IS. I'M NOT
SURE THAT'S A REALLY A
REALISTIC ASSUMPTION RIGHT IF
WE ACTUALLY GO OUT TO COMMUTING
SAID. HERE'S ONE YEAR FUNDING.
AND THERE'S NO COMMITMENT TO
FURTHER YEARS I DON'T THINK
WE'RE GONNA BE EFFECTIVELY EVEN
USE THE MONEY. NOT TO SAY- IS
THAT TRULY REALISTIC PROJECTION
ON HOW WE AND SPEND DRAPED. SO
AS WE LOOK AT THAT. I KNOW
THAT. IN THE PROPOSAL THERE'S
OFFICIALLY EIGHTEEN MONTH.
EXTENSION OF THESE AUTOMATIC
SUSPENSIONS. YOU KNOW I EIGHT I
JUST THINK THAT SURE WE CAN I
MEAN AND WE DID VOTE FOR- ON
EXPENSES LAST YEAR THAT'S
SOMETHING THE GOVERNOR PUSHED
FOR AND WE EXCEEDED BUT I'D
REALLY YOU KNOW WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT WHAT THE IMPACT OF THAT
AUTOMATIC SUSPENSION BE IF WE
TRULY CARRY IT OUT. IS IT
SOMETHING WE REALLY WANT TO BE
TELLING PEOPLE THAT. YOU KNOW I
MEAN LOOKS GREAT ON THE GRAPH
AND WE HAVE THIS LITTLE POP UP
HERE AND TWENTY THREE YOU KNOW.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. BUT I DON'T THINK WE'RE
BEING. ENTIRELY FORTHRIGHT WITH
PEOPLE INCLUDING OURSELVES IF
WE THINK THAT'S REALLY HOW WE
WANT TO DO THINGS RIGHT. SO AND
OF COURSE MOST OF OUR FOCUS
ACTION HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES- AGAIN SO IS THAT WHAT
WE REALLY WANT TO TELL PEOPLE-
INCLUDING PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DISABILITIES PEOPLE WHO NEED
SOCIAL SERVICES THAT OH BY THE
WAY AND- TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WERE YES THINGS AREN'T GOOD
WE'RE JUST GONNA AUTOMATICALLY
WITHOUT ANY ACTIVE ACTOR
DESCRIPTIO BY THE LEGISLATURE
JUST AUTOMATICALLY LET THOSE
THINGS FALL OFF THAT CLIFF. AND
THEN IT SO I THINK IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO LOOK AT OUT YEARS. I
YOU KNOW I JUST WANNA RAISE MY
CONCERN ABOUT EVEN IF IT'S
QUOTE N THE BUDGET THAT WE
HAVE A GRASS AND IT SHOWS THAT
AND I GUESS LEGALLY TECHNICALLY
THAT'S WHAT'S SUPPOSED TO
HAPPEN IS THAT REALLY HOW WE
WANT TO LOOK AT THINGS IS THAT
REALLY WHAT OUR TRUE INTENTION
IS AND- MAYBE WE SHOULD BE A
LITTLE MORE. I MAYBE ON IS TO
THROW BUT YOU KNOW I'M CELL
ABOUT WHAT WE REALLY WHAT WOULD
ACTUALLY WANT TO DO IS THAT
REALLY ARE PRIORITY THAT WE
WOULD JUST AUTOMATICALLY LET
THESE THINGS HAPPEN. SO I JUST
WANT TO RAISE THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE AND THEN. AS WE GET AND
THINK ABOUT OUT YEARS- I THINK
A CENTER STERN MENTIONED
YESTERDAY WE HAD A HEARING
ABOUT. DD AND THE RATE STUDY
AND AFTER ALWAYS SPENT THREE
YEARS SAYING WELL WAIT FOR THE
RIGHT SO YOU WAIT FOR THE RATE
STUDY APPRECIATE THAT THE PART
IN THE AGENCIES WORKING HARD TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THE APPLICATION.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT- YOU KNOW
I ASSN THE AGENCY SAID WHEN
THEY COME BACK IN A BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL. PRESENT A
TIME LINE. BUT I ALSO ASKED
FINANCE- SO. IN THE OUT YOUR
PROJECTION WHAT DID YOU DECIDE
TO DO AND WHAT THEY SAID IS YES
AND I AGREE AND I WANNA THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR PUTTING IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET TO
ESSENTIALLY A BILLION DOLLARS
OVER SIX HUNDRED MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND- TO INCREASE. THAT
PAYMENTS FOR DD SOMEONE'S
CASELOAD CENTER I WILL GET TO
THE DETAILS AND WE'LL LOOK AT
THAT ONE DEVICE OKAY. BUT IN
THE OUT YOUR PROJECTION THEY'RE
PROJECTING OUT YEAR NOTHING NO
INCREASE FOR THE FOR THE YEARS
SO THE PATENT THIS PROPOSED.
AND WE KNOW THERE OKAY IT'S A
ONE POINT TWO BILLION I GUESS
BECAUSE SOME OF THE MONEY WE'RE
CLOSING TO SOME OF THE GAPS. IS
THAT REALLY OUR INTENTION AGAIN
IN THE OUT YEARS. RIGHT TO
REALLY SO- AND I HOPE WE CAN
REVISIT THAT SO YES WE ARE FOR
MAILING ONLY FOCUSING ON NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET. BUT ALSO
THINKING ABOUT THOSE OUT YEARS.
I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT IN THE
OUT YEARS LAST YEAR WE TALKED
ABOUT TRYING TO. ADDRESS
EXTREME POVERTY RATE AND
GETTING FAMILIES OUT OF THAT-
AND YET. SO WE HAD A PATH BUT
WE DECIDED LOOKS LIKE IN THIS
YEAR'S PROPOSAL NOT THEM AT
BEGIN THE GOVERNOR. GIVE A COST
OF LIVING INCREASE BUT NOT
CONTINUING THAT PATH THAT THE
SAME DEGREE THAT WE HAD
ORIGINALLY. PROPOSED BEFORE. SO
OF COURSE THAT'S A MAYBE
CONSCIOUS DECISION WILL HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION IN OUR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT- AGAIN I. YOU
KNOW I THINK. IS WE'RE LOOKING
AT A OUT YEARS- NO WE- THINKING
ABOUT SOME THE COMMITMENTS WE
MADE AND THEN THE OTHER ONE
ACTUALLY APPRECIATE WE HAVE
THIS EARLY AT. CARE AND
EDUCATION OFFICE- INDIA WILL
HAVE SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT
THAT. BUT THAT EIGHT POINT ONE
MILLION IS THERE. PROJECTION
THERE FOR IN. OUT YEARS. TO SAY
THAT IN ADDITION TO CREAMY
OFFICE THE MORE WE ARE WE JUST
YOU OFF OKAY SO I MEAN THAT'S A
BE QUESTION GONNA WANNA KNOW
THE IN TO ACTUALLY ACTUALLY
OVER TO PUT MORE MONEY THIS
YEAR TOO BUT THAT IT BUT IN
ADDITION ARE YOU PUT MORE WHAT
KIND OF COMMITMENTS ARE WILLING
TO MAKE OUT TO THE FUTURE-
ANOTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS THAT
YOU GET OUT YOUR SO AGAIN THANK
YOU GOVERNOR FOR RECOGNIZING AS
WERETRYING TO COME UP THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING AND- YEAH
WE HAD A FOUR POINT 5%
INCREASE- FOR HSS- BUT WE
ACTUALLY HAD INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. LAST YEAR TALK ABOUT
WELL WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO IN
TERMS OF AGING SO I DON'T KNOW
IN YOUR OUT YOUR PROJECTIONS
EXACTLY WHAT RATE OF INCREASE
ARE YOU PLANNING YEAR BY YEAR
ON ICE SS AND OTHER LONG TERM
SUPPORT SERVICES- FOR SENIORS
OKAY IS THAT GOING TO CONTINUE
TO INCREASE WHAT THE
DEMOGRAPHICS- AND SO FORTH SO
AS AGAIN THAT'S THE OUT YOUR
PART THAT WE WANT TO BE SURE
WE'RE BUILDING IN INTO OUR OUR-
OUR BUDGET. THEN OF COURSE
OTHER RISKS E TALKED MC TAX WE
ARE GONNA HAVE AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING. LOOKING AT- WELL NOW
IT'S YOU SEE CAL AIM NOW IT'S-
WITH A HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA'S
FOR ALL. AND APPRECIATE THAT'S
A MAJOR INITIATIVE- EFFORT BY
THE GOVERNOR AND THAT-
GENERALLY SUPPORT OF THERE
STILL SOME DETAILS YOU WANT TO
KNOW. AND WE NEED TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT IN THE
WAIVERS ARE COMING UP AND WHAT
WE DO KNOW IS THAT RIGHT NOW.
FEDERAL YELL CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE MEDICAID SERVICES IS
PROPOSING A SET OF REGULATIONS.
THAT COULD COSTS CALIFORNIA.
BILLIONS MAYBE EVEN TENS OF
BILLIONS. OF MAYBE EVEN THAT
SIZE- SO. AGAIN THAT'S ANOTHER
RISK AND WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO HANDLE THAT
ASIDE FROM THE ALSO PUSHING
BACK ON THAT. SO JUST ONE OF
YOU KNOW IF THAT'S GOING TO BE
PART DISCUSSION AGAIN THINKING
ABOUT WHAT KIND OF RISK WE HAVE
TO DEAL WITH- THEN FOR. FIVE
SELL AND FIND I GUESS ONE OF
SECOND WHAT- MY GOOD FRIEND
THAT CENTER SKINNER MENTIONED
ABOUT THE CAP AND TRADE NINE OF
US ARE LIKE HOUSE KEY- YEAH WE
HAVE- FUNDS FOR ACTUALLY
INTERESTING ENOUGH WE TALK A
AIR POLLUTION- WHAT'S THE
RESULT- IF CUTTING BACK MONEY
FOR AIR POLLUTION BECAUSE WE
HAVE LESS MY AGE YEAR ACCESS MY
GUESS IS THAT WE'RE GONNA SEE A
LOT OF KIDS ON THAT ACCOUNT HE
MORE ASTHMA TREATMENTS AND
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS SO YOU
KNOW THIS IS BLOOM TO GET
SQUISHED HERE GETS OVER HERE
SO. I'M HOPING WE CAN THINK
ABOUT SOME REFORMS TO HOW WE'RE
HANDLING OR JEER AT FAST AND SO
FORTH IN A WAY THAT- BOTH GETS
US OR CARBON GOALS I THINK
THAT'S THE MAIN PURPOSE AND
THAT SHOULD BE THE MAIN PURPOSE
BUT MY GUESS IS THAT IF WE'RE
GOING TO GET THAT CURVE WOULD
PROBABLY MIGHT BRING IN LEX OR
REVENUE TO SO WE CAN SUSTAIN
OUR INVESTMENTS AND- THEIR
POLLUTION AND THEN FINALLY- WE
TALKED ABOUT OTHER TYPES OF
RISKS THE ALLOWED TO DEAL WITH
WILDFIRES- SO IMAGINE FLOODS
SACRAMENTO IS WHAT ABOUT
FLOODS- AND THEN I HAVE TO SAY
IS A PUBLIC HEALTH PERSON IS
THAT WE HAVE PUBLIC HEALTH
RISKS RIGHT SO ACTUALLY EVEN
TYPE THAT HOMELESSNESS AND I'D
BE CURIOUS- WE CAN. GET INTO
MORE DETAILS. IN A- FUTURE
HEARING. SO YOU KNOW WE HAD TO
HAVE THE- A. L. BECAUSE OF
HOMELESS RIGHT WE HAD. IN IN.
BUT SAN. RIGHT SO. WHAT INVEST
ARE WE MAKING ON THE POP.
HEALTH SO IN PREPARATION FOR
THESE TYPES BECAUSE THEY'RE
THEY'RE EXPENSIVE. IN THE END
RIGHT SAN DIEGO SPENT A LOT OF
MONEY TRYING TO. DEAL WITH
HEPATITIS A- AND THEN. YOU KNOW
WE- READ THE NEWS AND THERE'S
THIS. PANDEMIC THIS NEW MYSTERY
VIRUS FROM CHINA THAT. SHOWING
UP RATE AND DEAL WE HAD A
BULLET SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS SO. THE
OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
PREPAREDNESS FOR BOTH OUTBREAKS
IN OUR ONGOING ISSUES LIKE ARE.
VERY HIGH STD RATES AND SO
FORTH SO. AD SO WANT TO DELVE
INTO THAT BY JUST WHAT THE
MARKER ON THAT AS WELL- SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE- ISSUES-
BUT MAYBE PERHAPS YOU CAN JUST
COMMENT. BRIEFLY I. POINT OUT
ISSUES THAT MAYBE CAN CALM
ABOUT HOW FINANCE AND ALSO
ELLIE AS PERSPECTIVE ON HOW
WE'RE FIGURING OUT. EXACTLY
WATER OUT YEARS LOOKS LIKE
BECAUSE CERTAINLY WE ALL
TOGETHER. MUTUALLY WANT TO BE
SURE THAT WE MAKE INVESTMENTS
WE CAN SUSTAIN THEM THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE THE GOALS THAT WE WILL
ACHIEVE THAT USUALLY REQUIRES
MORE THAN. A SINGLE YEAR
DEPENDING. ARE HAVING A FUND
THAT WE CAN AND THEN OF COURSE
BE SURE THAT WE ARE. YOU KNOW
WE CAN. MITIGATE THE RISKS THAT
MIGHT BE BEFORE US. YES HE- SAW
ALL MAKE THREE BRIEF POINTS AND
ARE YOU COVERED A LOT OF GROUND
SO HI. THIS IT COVER THREE
POINTS IN THAT I KNOW AND THAT
YOU TO COMMITTEE HEARINGS CAN
DELVE INTO ALL THESE ISSUES
AND- WE HAD TO DEPART FINANCES
ALSO FOLLOW UP ON ANY OF THE
QUESTIONS. I THINK FIRST- MOST
IMPORTANT ON THE SUSPENSIONS-
CERTAINLY THE ADMINISTRATION IS
VERY CLEAR THAT THOSE WOULD BE
DIFFICULT TO ABSORB THERE'LL BE
PAINFUL FOR MANY MANY PEOPLE.
AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO DO
AND SO. YOU KNOW WE WERE
PLEASED THAT WITH THE
PROJECTIONS COMING IN THIS YEAR
WE CAN DELAY THEM BY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS BUT THE REASON THAT. WE
PROPOSED BUILDING THAT MAN AND
THEY WERE BUILT INTO THE
ENACTED BUDGET- IS SIMPLY
BECAUSE- AND WE- THIS CONTINUES
TO BE THE CASE WHEN WE LOOK AT
OUR YEAR OVER YEAR. PROJECTIONS
THE RATE OF GROWTH. AND
REVENUES IS LOWER EACH YEAR
THAN PRECEDING. SO INTO ONE TO
TWO THEN THE BUDGET YEAR. LOWER
TWENTY TWO TO THREE THAT'S TWO
AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
LOWER THE YAR AFTER THAT. AND
SO. I THINK THE FOR POINT IS
THAT. WE DON'T WANT TO MAY. AT
THE SUSPENSIONS YOU KNOW WE'D
LIKE TO COMMUTER PUSHING THEM
OUT OR IS. THE PICTURE CHANGES
OR THE REVENUE SYSTEM CHANGES
IN SOME WAY AT SOME POINT IN
THE FUTURE. THAT WE COULD DO
AWAY WITH THAT MANY OF CONTINUE
THOSE PROGRAMS ON THE PATH
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE LIKE TO
DO AS WELL. IT'S SIMPLY PLACING
A MARKER- SHOULD OUR REVENUE
PROJECTIONS AS THEY ARE RIGHT
NOW COME TRUE. THEN WE ARE
GOING TO BE IN A LITTLE BIT OF
A CRUNCH AND THEN OF COURSE AT
THAT TIME. THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE CAN WORK
THROUGH YOU KNOW WHICH OF THOSE
PROGRAMS SUSPEND MAYBE THEIR
PROGRAMS IN A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES THIS ASSEMBLY OUR
CURRENT. SPENDING PLAN THAT
WE'RE BUILDING INTO A MULTI
YEAR. BUDGET AND THAT LEADS TO
THE SECOND POINT WHICH IS THAT
I THINK YOU KNOW EVEN THIS MAY
BUT CERTAINLY. IN THE TIME
BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY TWENTY
THREE RIGHT THAT'S- MORE THAN
THREE YEARS AWAY. WILL HAVE
ADDITIONAL CLARITY BOTH IN
TERMS OF OUR REVENUE
PROJECTIONS AND ECONOMIC
PERFORMANCE. BUT ALSO TO THE
POINT YOU RAISED ABOUT ANY
FEDERAL CHANGES WITH MEDICAID-
FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY ROLE.
THERE'S OF COURSE ELECTION
COMING UP THIS FALL AND THERE
MIGHT BE CHANGES IN THE
CONGRESS AND OR THE WHITE
HOUSE. AND SHOULD GIVE US SOME
ADDITIONAL CLARITY IN TERMS OF
WHAT TYPES OF FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS. WE WOULD BE
EXPECTING AND THAT'S MAINLY ON
THE HEALTHCARE SIDE. BUT ALSO
ON THINGS WITH A YOU KNOW
FEDERAL WILD FIRES AND WE'VE
BEEN FORTUNATE SO FAR THAT THE
ASK. FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS-
RESPONDED TO OUR REQUESTS- BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'LL BE
KEEPING AN EYE ON BECAUSE THE
RAPPER THAT MONEY COMING IT IS
FUNGIBLE. WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
HOW MUCH MONEY THAT WE HAVE. A
AND THEN THE FINAL POINT ALL
NAY GOD JUST ON THREE OF THE
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THAT YOU
MENTIONED I KNOW THERE WILL BE
TIME TO GO INTO. SOME OF THE
OTHERS- BUT FOR EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE YOU MENTIONED EIGHT
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
CERTAINLY IT'S THAT. GOVERNOR'S
HOPE THAT WE CAN INVEST MORE IN
THERE THAT'S PART THE REASON
YOU WANT TO PUT TOGETHER THIS
OVERALL MASTER PLAN AND I
BELIEVE THAT THAT MASTER PLAN.
SHOULD BE BEING RELEASED IN
OCTOBER OF THIS YEAR. IF I
RECALL CORRECTLY AND SHOULD
INCLUDE IN ADDITION TO ALL THE
DIFFERENT AREAS. SOME. SENSE OF
HOW. AVENUES WILL BE GENERATED
INVEST SOME EASIER. THAT
DOESN'T MEAN. THAT THEY- BE. OR
BY THE LEGISLATURE BUT WE'RE
H THERE THAT WE GET IS. OF
HOW CAN WE ASK. PUT IN. MONEY
BEYOND THE IN. TO WE'VE CURRENT.
MADE WHEN IT COMES TO H. THAT
IS MORE OF A CASELOAD
ENTITLEMENT ISSUES SO THAT.
MAKE GROWING THE NATURAL OF
COURSE OF THE ECONOMY TURNS AS
YOU KNOW. THINGS MAY BE
DIFFERENT BUT- THAT GROWTH THAT
WE CONTINUE TO BUILDINGS ARE
MULTI YEAR PROJECTION- AND THEN
FINALLY ON HOMELESSNESS- VERY
COGNIZANT OF YOUR POINT THAT
THIS CAN'T BE SOLVED. IN ONE
YEAR AND SO ONE YEAR OF
FINDING. IS NOT GOING TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM.I THINK OF WHAT
WE'RE SEEING BETWEEN WHAT WE
HAVE IN OUR BUDGET- WHAT THE
GOVERNOR WORKING WITH
LEGISLATURE'S. IS OUT ON HIS
TOWARD THIS YEAR AND THEN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AB MAYOR
STEINBERG AND- SUPERVISOR
RIDLEY THOMAS. IS THAT THERE IS
A LOT FLOWING IN THE SPACE- IN
TERMS OF NEW PROPOSAL SOME OF
WHICH WE PROPOSED ON OUR OWN.
SO I THINK IN THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
COME TOGETHER ON A STRATEGY
FOR. HOW TO ATTACK THIS BOTH IN
THE BUDGET BUT ALSO TAKING OVER
THE LONG TERM. A YES SO. THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN I THINK YOU YOU
MADE A LOT OF- GOOD
OBSERVATIONS- FOR US- BUT- AS
FOR THE L. YEAR. I THINK IT IS
PRUDENT TO PLAN FOR AN
OPERATING SURPLUS PARTICULARLY
IN A TIME WHEN REVENUE GROWTH
IS SLOWING. AND WE THINK THAT
THERE COULD BE SOME RISKS TO
THE- TO THE OUTLOOK AND
CERTAINLY THE- GOVERNOR'S PLAN
DOES SHOW THAT THERE WOULD BE-
AN OPERATING SURPLUS. ON PAPER.
BUT YOU KNOW AS YOU POINTED OUT
THAT IF THE SUSPENSIONS- DID
NOT TAKE EFFECT. THEN THE
LARGER SURPLUS IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR WOULD ACTUALLY BE
MORE. LIKE A TWO BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT. AND SO. ARE WE JUST
THINK THAT IT MIGHT BE. BETTER
IF THE LEGISLATURE CARES ABOUT
THE COMMITMENTS THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN THE SUSPENSION
PROGRAMS THAT. TO RECOGNIZE THE
FULL COST OF THEM UP FRONT AND
THEN DECIDE ON THE MERITS OF
THOSE OF THOSE COMMITMENTS
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
IT WANTS TO FUND THOSE ARE
OTHER PRIORITIES- KIND OF FROM
A CLEAR I PERSPECTIVE ABOUT
WHAT IT IMPLIES FOR THIS THE
STATE'S OUT YOUR PHYSICAL
CONDITION. YEAH THANK YOU AND I
JUST MAKE ONE LAST MARK- YOU
KNOW I THINK ONE OF THINGS WE
ALSO TO RECOGNIZE IS THAT
RECOGNIZING WE A WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH OUR ECONOMIC AND
OTHERS UNCERTAINTIES OTHER
RISKS THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH. SOME OF THE TECHNIQUES
THAT WERE USING BASICALLY YEARS
PUSHING THAT UNCERTAINTY ON TO
ALL THE PEOPLE INTERACTING WITH
THE STATE ALRIGHT PEOPLE
RECEIVE SERVICES PEOPLE
DELIVERING THE SERVICES. SO
THEY'RE LOOKING AT GOING OUT
THERE SUSPENSION IT'S GONNA
HAPPEN TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
WE HAVE A SON CUT WHAT DO I DO
RIGHT HOMELESSNESS MONEY WILL
AND AT THE END OF THE FISCAL
YEAR RIGHT SO I THINK WE NEED
TO BE CONSCIOUS OF HOW THAT
THAT AFFECTS HOW OTHER PEOPLE
MAKES DECISIONS AND- SOMETIMES.
BECAUSE SITUATION WHERE. WE MAY
BE LESS EFFECTIVE BECAUSE
PEOPLE MAKE CERTAIN DECISIONS.
BASED ON- BASICALLY TOLD THEM.
AND THAT MAY NOT BE WHAT WE
WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN IN TERMS OF
HOW THE END UP BEHAVING SO I
JUST WANNA SAY THAT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OUT COLLEAGUES WE
HAVE TO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS IN
Q. AND I JUST WANNA REMIND US
ALL THAT THIS FIRST OVERSIGHT
HEARING IS REALLY THE
OPPORTUNITY. FOR US TO ENGAGE
FINANCE AND A AND THE LA SHOW.
IN THE OVER ARCHING
ARCHITECTURE OF THE BUDGET ALL
OF YOU WILL HAVE PLENTY
OPPORTUNITY. IN YOUR NUMEROUS
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS IN MARCH
TO DELVE DEEPLY INTO THE
SPECIFICS OF TH BUDGET
PROPOSALS BUT I DON'T WANT US
TO LOSE SIGHT OF. THIS IS THE
ONE OPPORTUNITY WHERE WE GET TO
HAVE THE TEN THOUSAND FOOT.
ARCHITECTURE CONVERSATION
FORGOT TO ADDITIONAL PEOPLE ON
CUE. YOU KNOW I AS CHAIR TEND
TO GO LAST TO. AFFORD MY
COLLEAGUES AN OPPORTUNITY BUT
I'M GOING TO ASK THE QUESTION
AROUND REVENUE AND- A RECESSION
MITIGATION AND SPENDING
PROPOSALS I KNOW WE'RE LOSING
PEOPLE. BUT I JUST WANT TO KNOW
THAT I AM GOING TO BRING US
BACK THERE. SOMEONE ASKED MY
LAST TWO MEMBERS TO THINK ABOUT
THE CON THE POINT OF TODAY'S
HEARING- AND USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY ACCORDINGLY. WITH
THAT WE HAVE MISTER BAIL
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
INCIDENT TO NIELSEN HOUSE. AND
ADDITIONAL ENQUIRING SENATOR
BAIL. YEAH THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERS
AS CHAIR. AND THE FACT. THIS IS
THE ERROR THAT- IS A LOT
DIFERENT THAN BUDGET WE HAD-
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
MY FIRST YEARS IN THE SENATE
WHERE WE WERE CUTTING THIRTY
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS OF THE
BUDGET WE- REMOVE THE BUDGETS
NOW WE HAVE A BUDGET THAT WE
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF. SURPLUS
WERE- PROCEEDING AHEAD WITH A
NEW GOVERNOR AND WITH NEW
IDEAS- CHANGES THAT HE WANTS TO
ACHIEVE CERTAIN GOALS ERIC AND
I THINK IN TERMS OF OUR OVER
ARCHING ISSUE FOR ME IS.
SOMETIMES JUST A ADVICE
SOMETIMES IS A LITTLE EASIER TO
LOOK- THINGS LIKE ARE THESE
PROGRAMS WORKING WELL ARE THEY
PERFORMING WORKING WELL. DO YOU
FUNDAMENTALLY HAVE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE. OR AS EFFICIENT AS A
SHOULD. AND MAYBE IT'S TIME TO
SHARPEN THE PENCIL NOW ON SOME
OF THOSE PROGRAMS RATHER THAN
TRY TO DEAL WITH THOSE KINDS OF
PROBLEMS WHEN THE BUDGET CRISIS
IS WHEN YOU HAVE TO MAKE ALL
THE CUTS SO LITTLE EASIER TO.
COME UP WITH SOME EFFICIENCY
IMPROVEMENTS. IN THIS
SITUATION. SO I AGREE WITH
CENTER SKINNER SHE MAKES
REMARKS ABOUT OUR COMMITTEE AND
I'M CERTAIN- OTHER COMMITTEES-
WILL BE DOING THE SAME THING
BUT- OF WHEN WE WHEN WE WROTE
SP ONE. WE PUT IN THERE THAT-
CALTRANS SAID TO HAVE A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF EFFICIENCY
IN A REPORT EVERY YEAR OR SO
IT'S KILLER BUT NOW THEY'RE UP
TO. TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
FISH AND SEES THAT WE FORCED ON
THEM THROUGH A STATUTE THAT WE
PUT IN A STATUTE THAT WE'VE
FORCED ON THEM. AND THEY HAVE.
COME UP WITH THAT. NOW OVER
OVER A TEN YEAR PERIOD THE
LEVEL OF MONEY WE'RE GOING TO
SAVE IS IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND WE'LL HAVE THAT
MONEY REINVESTED IN PROJECTS.
OF THAT WE CAN BUT WHAT WE WANT
OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO FUN. SO I
THINK. THE A MINOR NIT YOU KNOW
I WANT TO ADMONISH YOU TO.
DON'T JUST FOCUS ON THE BUDGET
CHANGES THEIR PROPOSED BUT
FOCUS ON THE EXISTING BUDGET TO
TRY TO FIND WAYS THAT WE CAN
DO. THINGS BETTER MAKE
EFFICIENCY IMPROVEMENTS OF
BRING UP WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IN MY COMMITTEE WITH WE'RE
GONNA HAVE AN SP ONE MADAM
MADAM SURE WE'RE GONNA HAVE AN
SP ONE OVERSIGHT HEARING JUST
TO GET AN UPDATE ABOUT ALL
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THIS BE
ONE. AND HOW WE'RE TRYNG TO BE
EFFICIENT WITH THE USE OF THE
FUNDS- THE DMV- IT HAS- I
NOTICE- THEY DIDN'T REALLY ASK
FOR ANY MONEY CORRECT. SO I
THINK- YOU KNOW LIKE LIKE
CHANGING THE DAY OF THE TO BE
MORE EFFECTIVE EFFICIENT THAT
WAS BUILT ON NECESSITY FOR DIEM
WORRIED ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO
PERFORM- THEIR FUNCTION BY THE
TIME THE REAL ID DEADLINE OMES
IN OCTOBER. OF THIS NEXT YEAR
SO THAT'S GOING TO BE. A ISSUE
I THINK ON A IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT- THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO ONE BILLION ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION ONGOING
PROGRAMS. I LOOK AT LOOKING AT
THE SUFFICIENCY THING AS AN
EASY WAY TO CLOSE THAT GAP
BETWEEN THE TWO. OKAY SO MAYBE
IF YOU WORK TOGETHER AND FOUND
SOME AFFECTION SEES HERE AND
THERE THAT WE COULD. THE CHIEF
OF THAT WILL CLOSE THE GAP OF
HOUSE I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
HOUSING BECAUSE I'M I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT. THE FACT THAT
THIS BUDGET REPRESENTS- JUST A
ONE TIME MAINLY IN ALMOST ALL
THE MONEY IS ONE TIME NOT ON
GOING BUT WE HAVE A COMMITMENT
THAT WE HAVE TO DO AN
UNDERSTANDING I THINK WE WERE
ETTING FROM YOU IN THE IN THE
READING THE BUDGET. THAT WE
HAVE TO DO AN ONGOING- HOUSING
PROGRAM TO THE GEE WHAT WE WANT
TO ACHIEVE AND HOUSING. AND I
WOULD URGE YOU TO LOOK AT AN
ONGOING SOURCE OF FINDING. A
SUCH AS WE PROPOSED LAST YEAR
IN THE SENATE. AND THE GOVERNOR
VETOED WITH SAM ACQUIRE ANTHONY
PORTANTINO ME. PROPOSING A BILL
THAT ACTUALLY WORKED IN A
COLLABORATION WITH THE CITIES
AND COUNTIES. YOU'RE NOT GONNA
SOLVE THIS UNLESS YOU HAVE A
COLLABORATION WITH ALL THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES. YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GET THERE YOU'RE NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO HANDLE. THE
TYPES OF PEOPLE THERE HOMELESS
THE- WELL THAT IS- ALMOST
BECAUSE OF ECONOMIC REASONS.
BECAUSE OF THE RATE GOING UP
TOO MUCH OF THE SOCIAL REASONS
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
HAVE. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND-
OTHER TRAUMA. AND AS RESULTS-
HAD TO RUN AWAY FROM THAT KIND
OF SITUATION. AND THEY BECAME
HOMELESS SEVEN THERE'S- THERE'S
DIFFERENT REASONS- THERE'S-
PEOPLE THAT ARE DISABLED THERE
ARE- I THINK WE'RE WE'RE VERY
SCARED THAT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
DISABLED ARE LOSING THEIR GROUP
HOMES THEY'RE CLOSING GROUP
PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA I THINK
THAT'S CAUSING SOME
HOMELESSNESS. THAT'S KIND OF
SCARY THAT SOMEBODY IT CAN'T
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES AND WE
NEED TO TAKE CARE OF WE NEED TO
HAVE THAT SAFETY NET FOR THOSE
PEOPLE AND THEY'RE LOSING OF
WE'RE WE'RE LOSING GROUP HOMES
THAT THEY ARE CARED FOR IN. AND
THIS INCLUDES PEOPLE- THAT HAVE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. SO
I TAKE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
HOUSING. OF IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT- THIS KIND OF SAFETY NET
WITH THAT WE WANT TO ACHIEVE IS
VERY IMPORTANT I I'M I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS. I THINK
YOU SHOULD SET GOALS AND
NUMBERS OF HOW MANY PEOPLE YOU
WANNA HOUSE AND WHAT YOUR GOALS
ARE EACH YEAR TO ELIMINATE
HOMELESSNESS. AND REALLY GET
DOWN TO REFINING THAT AND
pCOMING UP WITH THE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
HOMELESS. I KNOW A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOMELESS BECAUSE- ONE MY
FAMILY WE HAD A FIRE OUR HOUSE
BURNED DOWN AND THE TWELVE OF
US BECAME HOMELESS SO I HAD
EXPERIENCE YOU KNOW IT IT AND
THAT'S A TEPER THAT WAS A
TEMPORARY A YEAR AND A HALF WE
IN A PLACE TO LIVE WE KIND OF
CANCER THE FAMILY ALL OVER THE
PLACE- BUT IT DISRUPTED THE
FAMILY AND WE FINALLY KIND OF.
BECAUSE OF THE HARD WORK OF MY
FATHER AND MOTHER. WE TOOK CARE
THAT AND WE BOUNCE BACK BUT I
THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE TAKE A
LONGER TIME IT'S HARDER- THEY
HAVE VARIOUS BARRIERS. THERE
THERE THERE ARE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS THE COMPLICATED
PROBLEMS IT'S NOT JUST ONE
ANSWER IS THAT THE HOMELESS IS
NOT JUST PEOPLE THAT HAVE
MENTALLY ILL AND DRUG ABUSE. I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PEOPLE THERE
HOMELESS SAY THE- IF YOU GO TO
THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY COUNT
THE HOMELESS YOU'LL FIND OUT. I
THINK WE UNDERESTIMATE FOR
EXAMPLE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN THE PEOPLE
IN THE SHELTERS. WE WORK ON
MENTAL HEALTH I WANT TO. I I'M
A LITTLE CONCERNED I DON'T WANT
TO FOCUS ON THE QT BECAUSE I
THINK WE LEARNED THROUGH A LOT
OF STUDIES ON MENTAL HEALTH
THAT WE HAVE TO. FOCUS ON.
EARLY INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION WHERE AND- THERE
UNDER EIGHTEEN- YOUNG KIDS EVEN
THE PRE K. THE TRUMP YOU KNOW
THE TRUMP DRAMATIC EXPERTS IS
THAT KIDS GO THROUGH WHEN
THEY'RE TO AFFECT THE NOT THEIR
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
I THINK THE SURGEON GENERAL'S
CORRECT WE SHOULD FOCUS ON THAT.
I THINK THE EARLY- ALL THESE
PROGRAMS THAT THE CHAIR IN THE
CENTER PAN AND OTHERS HAVE
ADVOCATED FOR. A CHILD CARE-
THAT'S THAT'S ACTUALLY
PREVENTING A CUTIE AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH CARE. IF YOU WANT
TO BE HONEST ABOUT IT YOU'LL
HAVE LESS SPECIAL ED KIDS OF
YOU TAKE CARE OF THEM. EARLY AT
THE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THE
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS. BUT WE'LL
WE'LL TO PICK UP EARLIER THE
FAMILIES SO NEEDS IN TERMS OF A
KID DO WITH DISABILITIES- THOSE
KINDS OF ISSUES AND SOME
FAMILIES DON'T GET DISCERN
UNTIL IT SO. LIKE FOR PHYSICS
GREATER EVEN LATER NOT AND
THAT'S THAT'S WRONG THAT'S
THAT'S THE DISPARITY RACIAL
ETHNIC DISPARITIES IN THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. HAVE TO BE
ELIMINATED THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE
TO HAVE THOSE KINDS OF PROGRAMS
FOR SPECIAL IT MIGHT MY- A
MENTOR MY MOTHER MY MOTHER. AND
I STILL HAVE IT IF YOU WANT TO
LOOK AT IT I THINK I SHOWED YOU
THIS MY MOTHER DID UP. I ASKED
HER I SAID WHAT DO YOU THINK WE
OUGHT TO DO WITH EDUCATION SHE
SAID. TRAINED AS TEACHERS AND
GIVE THEM EXTRA AFTER TAKING
CARE OF. KIDS AND- KIDS IN
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE HARDER.
TO TEACH AND- HELP THE SPECIAL
ED TEACHERS. WITH BENEFITS IN
TRAINING. AND THE GOVERNOR I
SHOW THE GOVERNOR. ABOUT THIS
TIME LAST YEAR MY MOTHER'S.
VIDEOTAPE I GUESS YOU LISTEN TO
MAMA. AND HE PUT SOME MONEY IN
THE BUDGET SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
I THINK THE GOVERNOR'S LISTEN
TO MY MAMA SHE'S NINETY THREE
YEARS OLD RIGHT AND SHE STOPPED
TO CHEN WHEN SHE WAS ABOUT
EIGHTY SIX. SO SHE TALKED TO
SHE WAS ABOUT EIGHTY SIX SO I
APPRECIATE. DEALING WITH THE
SPECIAL ED. PROGRAM IN AND MORE
OF A STRATEGIC VIEW I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT. ESPECIALLY
FOR MAYOR OF COURSE- A DAD OF
SOMEBODY THAT WENT THROUGH THE
SPECIAL ED SYSTEM. WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES SO.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO RAISE
MIDDLEMAN CHURN I THINK. YOU'VE
HEARD FROM ME BEFORE. YOU'RE
NOT GONNA YOU'RE NOT GONNA.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO UNDERSTAND
HOMELESS AND LESS YOU
UNDERSTAND SSI. THERE'S ALL
THERE'S ONE POINT TWO MILLION
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA ON SSI.
GIVING THEM A HAIR CUT IN TERMS
OF. THE INCREASED S. ASIDE IS
NOT A GOOD IDEA IF YOU WANT TO
SOLVE YOUR HOMELESS PROBLEM.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE PEOPLE
THAT FALL INTO PRO HOMELESS
ACTUALLY ARE PEOPLE. THAT
EITHER ELIGIBLE. FOR MORE ON
SSI AND ARE LOSING THEIR GROUP
HOMES THEY'RE LOSING THEIR
HOUSING THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY FOR THE HOUSING VOUCHER-
THEY MAY BE DISABLED AND NOT
GETTING PROPER CARE. OF THEY
MAY BE AN ELDERLY PERSON THAT
BECAME HOMELESS WE'RE STARTING
TO SEE MORE ELDERLY. THAT ARE
HOMELESS. IT'S AMAZING HOW MANY
ELDERLY PEOPLE I SEE IN MY
COMMUNITY WHICH- SAN JOSE IS
THE ABOUT THE SECOND I THINK
WE'RE THE NUMBER TWO IN TERMS
OF HOMELESS. THE SAN JOSE
COMMUNITY IS A NUMBER TO
SECRETARY. IN TERMS OF THE
COUNTS. OF SO THERE'S A LOT OF
ELDERLY THAT HAVE BECOME
HOMELESS. AND I THINK WE HAVE
TO RECOGNIZE IT SSI BENEFITS
SHOULD BE INCREASED AND I THINK
THAT THIRTEEN DOLLARS. IS
PARSIMONIOUS AND SHOULD BE
LOOKED OUT. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S GOING TO BE AN EFFECTIVE
AMOUNT. AND NOT BE A HINDRANCE
IN SOLVING THE HOMELESS
PROBLEM. IS I THINK PEOPLE NEED
THE INCOME TO. PAY FOR THE NEXT
WEEK'S RANT THAT THEY NEED TO
SURVIVE AND I THINK THIRTEEN
DOLLARS. I DON'T THINK IT I
DON'T THINK IT'S ENOUGH I THINK
IT SHOULD BE INCREASED SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I APPRECIATE MY
INSURER- THE THOUGHTS I'M
ALWAYS GOING TO SPEAK UP OF THE
SAFETY NET. SO MY LAST BUDGET.
I HAVE TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT FOR
EVERYBODY THAT THE DAY CARES
ABOUT THIS AND- I THINK
GOVERNOR NEWSOME IS ON HIS WAY
TO SOME GOOD IDEAS HE JUST HAS
TO. FINALIZES STRATEGIES. AND
COME UP WITH SOME ONGOING WAYS
OF FINDING OUT I THINK THAT'S
THE BOTTOM LINE FOR HIM. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BYE THANK
YOU SIR- SENATOR REQUIRE YOUR
LAST UP. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WILL
BE BRIEF IN THREE QUICK POINTS
ON THE ISSUE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN WHICH- THE GOOD
CENTER FROM SAN JOSE DANCE AT
SOME SOLUTIONS I THINK THAT IS
VERY MUCH A VALUABLE TOOL. THAT
HE'S BEEN FOCUSING ON AND WOULD
HOPE THAT IS GONNA GET SOME
CONSIDERATION. UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE POINT OF
VIEW- IN POTENTIAL AVENUE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE BUT I THINK-
THE SINNERS HARD WORK- SHOULD
BE EVALUATED SERIOUSLY. TAKE A
LOOK AT A GLOBAL VIEW PRETTY
CHAIR ON TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
DECISION BE EIGHT CODE. I'D ALL
THOSE WHO ARE FOR AND OF WAS
NOT IN THE ROLE THAT YOU WERE
AT THIS POINT. BUT THAT IS-
TAKING EXCESS PROPERTY TAX
ALLOCATION THAT WAS DEDICATED
TO SCHOOLS AND THEN TAKING IT-
AND FINDING A TRIAL COURT'S. SO
I THINK LAST YEAR IT WAS
APPROXIMATELY NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS IN EXCESS PROPERTY TAX-
ALLOCATIONS EXCESS EDUCATION
FUNDING. WHICH IS FUNDING TRIAL
COURTS NOW UNDERSTAND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND I THINK IN A
TRAILER BILL IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN ADVANCE THAT. SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR I THINK THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE REVIEWED ESPECIALLY
IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT MOVING
THE BALL FORWARD ON EIGHTY
EIGHT- IN IMPACTS CITIES.
EXCUSE ME IMPACTS COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA AS WELL
SEVEN CALIFORNIA- AT
APPROXIMATELY NINETY MILLION A
KNOW THAT. AT SOME CHALLENGES
IN LAST ITEM ALL SAY. BEN CHAIR
IN THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
CENTER NIELSEN HAS BEEN
FOCUSING ON OF SEE SENATOR
STERN AND MANY WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY. WHILE AND FIRES
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ADVANCED LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT APPLICATIONS- IS TO BE
FOCUSED ON THE 200-017-2000
EIGHTEEN WHILE THEN FIRES- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I KNOW TREASURER
Mà IS LOOKING AT. AND LOOKING
AT THE INTERPRETATION ABOUT HOW
THESE TAX CREDITS ARE GOING TO
BE SPENT. THE INTERPRETATION AT
LEAST BY THOSE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS AND THEY'VE ALSO
SUBMITTED A LETTER ON THIS-
THAT TO SECURE THE TAX CREDITS.
IT WOULD BE FOCUS ON THE
COUNTIES THAT WERE IMPACTED IN
200-017-2000 EIGHTEEN BY THE
WHILE AND FIRES. ON THE STATE
HAS AT LEAST UP UNTIL THIS
POINT TAKING A MUCH BROADER
VIEW. IN FOCUSING UP
POTENTIALLY THERE'S BEEN NO
FINAL DECISION. ON USING X. TAX
CREDITS ON HOUSING THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THE COUNTIES THAT
WERE INTENDED WERE BUTTE LAKE
MENDOCINO NAPA NEVADA OR IN
CINEMA YUBA LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO SANTA BARBARA PRINTER AND
SHASTA ALL THE IN BEEN IMPACTED
BY WILD EMPIRES ALL OF SEEN
SIGNIFICANT HOUSING STOCK LOST
THAT IS SOMETHING I WOULD LIKE
TO GET A FOLLOW UP WITH
APARTMENT A FINANCES IN THE
WORLD TO WORKING WITH- TREASURE
MáS OFFICE. AS WELL- AT A
FURTHER DATE AND THAT IS ALL
FOR ME AND IF IT'S ALRIGHT TO
THE CHARITIES HEARING TO
RESPONSES FROM BOTH THE LEFT.
AND BACK THANK YOU. UPLOAD GO
AHEAD. HELLO WE WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU ON THAT FINALLY SHE IN
PARTICULAR. ANY COMMENT ON OR
HAVE BEEN HAPPY TO HAVE A OFTEN
CONVERSATION ON AND THE EXCESS
EDUCATION HAVE. ON THIS ISSUE
YES A MEMBER OF THE ISSUE YOUR
CURRENT BUDGET IS- CONSISTENT
WITH THE EXISTING EDUCATION
CODE SO WE HAVEN'T PROPOSED ANY
CHANGES SO IT'S NOT IN OUR
JANUARY BUDGET- BUT HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP ON MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF ALL THE
DETAILS. YEAH I THINK THE ISSUE
IS THE- THE POTENTIAL LEGALITY
OF THAT- AND PROP NINETY EIGHT.
YES TO OUR CURRENT VIEW IS
THAT- THE WAY THAT IT'S
ALLOCATED CURRENTLY IS A IN
ACCORDANCE WITH EXISTING LAW-
SO THAT CERTAINLY THAT
ADMINISTRATION'S VIEW- BUT WE
WILL FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR OFFICE
IN TERMS OF TALKING FOR SOME OF
THE DETAILS OF THAT WOULD BE
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ELIA INTO FLORA JUST LEAVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE TOO CAN ALL
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU SENATOR
WE'VE BEEN DOING A LOT OF WORK
IN THE SYRIAN AND PLAYED TO
ADVISE LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU
TO BOTH LA- IS WILL THE PRIME
IN FINANCE THANK YOU SO MUCH
VENTURE THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN YOUR FOLLOW UP. TWO
OBSERVATIONS NO QUESTION WE
WANT TO DEFER TO THE CHAIR. FOR
HER LAST THE INCREASE THE DD
ISSUE AND THE RATE SO I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THAT YOU SEE UP
VERY HIGH PRIORITY TO SEVERAL
OF US HERE AND WE'RE GOING TO
WANT TO SEE THAT ADDRESSED. IN
THE BUDGET. AND THEN I WANT TO
PUT ON YOUR RADAR SCREEN
FISCALE. I THINK WE'RE HEADED
TOWARDS ANOTHER DISASTER.
DISASTERS THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
A- CREDIBLE EXPENSIVE AND LONG
OVERDUE BUT OVER TIME. TECH THE-
IN CALIFORNIA WE JUST KEEP NOT
GETTING IN RIGHT. SO I'M GOING
TO BE REALLY THAT THE
INQUISITIVE AND ALL OVER THAT
FISH SCALE PROGRESS THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE
GENTLEMAN I HAVE FOR. QUESTIONS
ONE ON REVENUE SECOND RESET
RECESSION MITIGATION THIRD
SPENDING PROPOSALS AND FOR-
QUESTION ON THE- BSA THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT FIRST OF
ALL THE- BUDGET REVENUES ARE UP
APPROXIMATELY FIVE POINT EIGHT
BILLION FROM THE ADOPTED
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET AND FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES. A HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
POINT ONE BILLION IN GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURES WHICH IS AN
INCREASE OF ABOUT FIVE BILLION
FROM THE NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
ACT. I'M CURIOUS AS TO WHAT YOU
THINK THE PRIMARY DRIVING
FACTORS ARE ON THAT ARE DRIVING
THE REVENUE GROWTH AT IF YOU
ASSUME A SIMILAR LEVEL OF
GROWTH THROUGHOUT THE
FORECASTED PERIOD. SURE I'LL
MAKE TWO BRIEF POINTS I THINK
THE FIRST IS THAT- BOTH LAST
YEAR AND THIS YEAR WE HAVE SEEN
SEVEN ECONOMIC AND IN
PARTICULAR CAPITAL GAINS GROWS
ABOUT EXPECTATIONS SO- WHEN THE
GOVERNOR WAS COMING INTO OFFICE
IN DECEMBER OR JANUARY OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN. WE SAW A SIGNIFICANT
DROP IN THE STOCK MARKET- BUT
NOW THAT WE'RE IN TWENTY TWENTY
WE CAN LOOK BACK AND LOOK AT
THE TWENTY NINETEEN YEAR AND WE
SAW A PRETTY HISTORIC YEAR FOR
STOCK MARKET GROWTH YOU KNOW
WELL ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT. FROM
JANUARY TO DECEMBER- SO WE'RE
PROJECTING GENERALLY BOTH IN
CAPITAL GAINS SPECIFICALLY BUT
ALSO ECONOMIC GROWTH GENERALLY-
THE ECONOMY CONTINUING TO GROW
FOR TIME AND THAT'S WHY
REVENUES ARE GOING UP. AT THE
SAME TIME WE ARE PROJECTING
SLOWING GROWTH IN EACH OF THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS AND THAT'S
WHY EVEN THOUGH YOU DO SEE
EXPENDITURE GROWTH IN THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS- IT'S A SLOWING
RATE OF GROWTH AND IN FACT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE FIGURES. YOU
MENTIONED ASK FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS BETWEEN LAST YEAR AND
PROJECT FOR THIS YEAR BUT FOR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO WERE
PROJECTING ONLY ABOUT FOUR AND
A HALF BILLION DOLLARS- FOR THE
YEAR OF GROWTH FOR THE YEAR
AFTER THAT EXPENDITURE. GROWTH
I'M SORRY MILLION WRONG WHY BUT
ABOUT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS. AND
THEN THE YEAR AFTER THAT WE'RE
PROJECTING UNDER FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN AND THE YEAR AFTER
THAT WE'RE PROJECTING IN THE
RANGE OF THREE BILLION DOLLARS
CC IN EACH YEAR ALONGSIDE A
PROJECTION OF. SWUNG REVENUES
WE ARE PROTECTING OUR MULTI
YEAR SONG EXPENDITURES AND THEN
I THINK THE OTHER AND YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THOSE NUMBERS.
YES WE WOULD OF COURSE A LOT OF
THE REVENUES TO BE WE ARE
HOPING THEIR AVENUES WILL BE
HIGHER BUT THAT CERTAINLY THE
WAY THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IT.
RIGHT NOW AND THEN MYCOLOGY
CHAMBERLAIN WHO LEADS ARE
REVENUE UNIT. MAY WANT TO MAKE
AN ADDITIONAL COMMENT. I'M
ACTUALLY I THINK OKAY. YOU
COVER ALL COME TO THE LA WE
OFTEN OF TRIED YOU BOTH TO THIS
OVERSIGHT HERE IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW WHO'S PROJECTIONS ARE
HIGHER WHOSE LOWER WHO WAS
CLOSER TO REALITY THE YEAR
BEFORE. AND SO I DON'T
REMEMBER- MY NINE YEARS NOW IN
THE LEGISLATURE A TIME WHEN-
FINANCE AND ELLIE OWES
PROJECTIONS WERE SO CLOSE- IS
THAT TELL ME WHY YOU THINK THAT
IS THERE ARE YOU ENGAGE IN A
NEW. METHOD OF MODELING OR-
WELL EVERYBODY SHARING THE SAME
CRYSTAL BALL NOW HOW DO WE GET
THERE- WILL LET ME START WITH A
HIGH LEVEL COM IN THE MY
COLLEAGUE BRIAN CAN- WAY IN. WE
HAVE VERY SIMILAR REVENUES FOR
THE THREE YEARS THAT MAKE UP
THE BUDGET WINDOW AS I
MENTIONED IN THE OPENING. SO
THE ONE THING I WOULD SAY ABOUT
THAT THOUGH IS THAT THE
COMPONENTS OF OUR REVENUE
GROWTH ARE ACTUALLY A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT WE HAVE. MORE OF
OUR REVENUES IN THE PERSONAL
INCOME TAX AND I THINK
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES. SEEN
SOME MORE REVENUE IN THE
CORPORATION TAX AND THEN. I
THINK ONE IMPLICATION OF THAT
IS THAT WHEN YOU LOOK TO THE
OUT YEAR WITH OUR PERSONAL
INCOME TAX- HIM DRIVING IT
THERE IS. OUR OUR L. YOUR
REVENUES ARE SOMEWHAT HIGHER
THAN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PART OF THE REASON I DON'T KNOW
BRIAN IF YOU CAN. SETTLEMENT
YEAH I MEAN I THINK ONE FACTOR
THAT SOME PLAY HERE IS JUST THE
KIND OF THE POINT IN THE
ECONOMIC CYCLE OR AND I THINK
THAT A LOT OF THOSE EARLIER
YEARS AND WE WERE HAVING KIND
OF MORE TURBULENT BUDGETS IN
THE ECONOMY WAS. JUST COMING
OUT OF THE RECESSION AND IT WAS
A LITTLE HARDER TO KNOW YOU
KNOW WHERE IT WHAT'S THE PATH
IT'S GOING TO TAKE OVER THE
NEXT YEAR. AS THE RECOVERIES
YOU KNOW KIND OF MOVED ALONG
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN KIND OF
STEADILY TRENDING UPWARD IN A
WAY THAT. NOT JUST OUR OFFICES
BUT THE KIND OF THE CONSENSUS
ECONOMIC FORECAST SO WE BOTH
LOOK TO. YOU KNOW THEY'VE ALL
KIND OF TENDED TOWARDS TO
GATHER AROUND YOU KNOW A MORE.
TIGHT CONSENSUS AS YOU KNOW THE
STRAINS OF ALL KIND OF
CONTINUED ON GRADUALLY- YOU
KNOW I THINK AS AS AS GAVE IS
MENTIONED YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
THERE'S MAYBE SOME. SOME
GROWING RISKS THAT SOME OF THAT
TURBULENCE COULD BE COMING BACK
IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS YOU KNOW
WE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DON'T. FORECASTERS SESSIONS AND
SO THAT IS YOU KNOW PART OF WHY
WE CONTINUE ON THAT KIND OF
GRADUAL TREND- SO I THINK YOU
KNOW KIND OF THE- THAT'S
PROBABLY PART OF WHY. WE'RE
MAYBE A LITTLE CLOSER THAN WE
HAVE BEEN IN SOME OF THE PAST
YEARS. THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M
GONNA MOVE QUICKLY INTO OUR-
RECESSION MITIGATION TO THE LA
ALL. IN THE HANDOUT YOU GAVE US
TODAY YOU AGAIN ENCOURAGE A
LEGISLATURE DETERMINE WHETHER
IT WE'RE SATISFIED WITH THE
LEVEL THE LEVEL OF RESERVES
PROPOSED- IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET- I CONTINUE TO BE.
CURIOUS AS TO YOUR THOUGHTS ON
WHAT YOU THINK THE APPROPRIATE.
LEVEL OF RESERVE SHOULD BE. IF
YOU COULD FIND ON THAT YEAH
WELL. IT RELEASED THE TARGET
YES IT'S THE- KIND OF. SIXTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR QUESTION IT
IS. AGAINST OVERSIGHT- SO I
THINK. IT DEPENDS ON HOW YOU
VIEW THE WORLD IN CERTAIN WAYS
ONE IS WHAT KIND OF A RECESSION
ARE YOU CONTEMPLATING PREPARING
FOR- THE MORE SEVERE THE
RECESSION THAT OBVIOUSLY THEY
GREATER CUSHION THAT YOU WOULD
NEED. AND THEN ALSO WHAT IS THE
STATE'S CURRENT SPENDING
TRAJECTORY RELATIVE TO ITS
REVENUE GROWTH- IN THE
THROUGHOUT THE MULTI YEAR
PERIOD AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF SPACE
BETWEEN THOSE TWO- VARIABLES
THAN. THE SHORTFALL REVENUE
THAT WOULD OCCUR IN A RECESSION
AND WOOD MORE IMMEDIATELY NEED
TO BE OFFSET BY EITHER USE OF
RESERVES OR CUTS TO PROGRAMS OR
SOME KIND OF INCREASED REVENUES
SO WITH THAT I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU KNOW WE'VE DONE SOME SOME
ESTIMATING OF WHAT THE EFFECT
OF A RECESSION WOULD BE AND WE
TOOK WHEN WE DID OUR FISCAL
OUTLOOK IN THE FALL WE TOOK THE
AVERAGE- TYPE OF RECESSION
SINCE WORLD WAR TWO THERE BEEN
TWELVE RECESSIONS WE KIND OF
AVERAGE THE- THE METRICS THAT.
WITH THAT- THOSE REPRESENTED
AND WHEN YOU DID THAT AND YOU
COMPARED IT TO THE STATE'S
CURRENT RISEN PROJECTED
RESERVES AT THAT TIME PLUS WHAT
WE VENN PROJECTED THE- BUDGET
SURPLUS TO BE. ASSUMING NO NEW
COMMITMENTS ARE MADE OUR
OUTLOOK SAID WELL YOU WOULD
PROBABLY BE PRETTY CLOSE TO
HAVING ENOUGH TO WITHSTAND THAT
BUT OF COURSE IF YOU YEAH
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS MAKE
NEW COMMITMENTS- HEN THEN THAT
PICTURE COULD CHANGE AND THEN
WE ALSO POINTED OUT YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN TALKING TODAY ABOUT
THE OTHER RISKS THAT ARE OUT
THERE SO IF YOU HAD A RECESSION
IN ANY OF THOSE OTHER RHYS
HAPPEN AT THE SAME TIME. THEN
IT WOULD BE- EVEN MORE OF A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT YOU
HAVE AND WHAT YOU WOULD NEED
BUT I THINK- I THINK- IN
GENERAL THE STATE IS MADE GREAT
PROGRESS IN RECENT YEARS. AND
AT END OF THE DAY THIS THE
ANSWER ISN'T THE SADDEST
BECAUSE I THINK. TO SAY WHETHER
OR NOT THE STATE IS READY
REALLY DEPENDS ON THE
COLLECTIVE RISK TOLERANCE OF
THE KEY DECISION MAKERS. THANK
YOU- MISTER THIS ONE OFTEN WHAT
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE. KIND OF
WAYNE IN IN TERMS OF ON BEHALF
OF THE ADMINISTRATION- DO YOU
THINK YOUR PROPOSAL LEAVES THE
STATE AND OR OR WHERE DO YOU
STATE. IN A POSITION IN TERMS
OF BEING ABLE TO MINUTE
MITIGATE OUR MANAGE OUR WAY
THROUGH UP AT LEAST A MODERATE
RECESSION SCENARIO. YES SO ALL
MAKE A COUPLE OF BRIEF
COMMENTS- THE FIRST IS OUR
OVERALL RECESSION SCENARIO
WHICH WE RAN AGAIN IS SIMILAR
TO LAST YEAR WHICH IS WHERE IN
A RECESSION THAT IS. MAYBE NOT
QUITE AS SEVERE AS WHAT WE SAW
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION BUT
STILL PRETTY SEVERE WE COULD
EXPERIENCE REVENUE DROPS OF UP
TO TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN A SINGLE YEAR AND UP TO
NEARLY SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS.
OVER THREE YEARS TO SIR
CERTAINLY WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT WHEN IT COMES TO.
HOW PREPARED WE FEEL I THINK
THE FIRST POINT I MAKE IS ARE
PROJECTED RESERVES LEVEL OF
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE END OF THE BUDGET YEAR. IS
NOT ONLY- HI FOR CALIFORNIA BUT
IT'S ALSO IF YOU COMPARE TO
OTHER STATES AND YOU LOOK AT IT
AS A PERCENTAGE OF OVERALL
GENERAL FUND SPENDING- WORK
COMFORTABLY IN THE UPPER TIER
AT COMPARED TO OTHER STATES AND
I THINK THAT WAS REFLECTED. IN
THE RATINGS UPGRADE- THAT WE
RECEIVED- LAST YEAR AFTER THE
BUDGET WAS ENACTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IT DOESN'T MEAN WE
CAN REST EASY TWENTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IS NOT SEVENTY
BILLION DOLLARS OR FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS. BUT I THINK
THE ADMINISTRATION FEELS MORE
COMFORTABLE NOW THAT WERE IN
THIS POSITION. THE SECOND POINT
THAT I WANT TO MAKE IT SOME OF
THE INVESTMENTS MADE LAST YEAR
WERE AS YOU KNOW FOR SEVERAL
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE PENSION
PAY DOWN AS WELL AS TO PAY OFF
THE WALL JACK. AND SO THESE ARE
INVESTMENTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
COULD HAVE SAID HEY WE DON'T
WANT TODO THESE THINGS WE WANT
TO PUT THEM INTO RESERVES. AND
THAT WOULD HAVE MADE THE
RESERVES LEVEL EVEN HIGHER
MAYBE IT WOULD'VE BEEN TWENTY
FOUR OR TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS- BUT WE ALSO THOUGHT
THAT THESE OTHER PRIORITIES
BUILD FISCAL RESILIENCY AS WELL
AND OF COURSE THE DEBATE THAT
WE OFTEN HAD THESE. RESERVES
VERSUS. SPENDING ON ONE TIME OR
ONGOING PROGRAMS BUT IT'S ALSO
WE'RE THINKING A ABOUT RESERVES
PERSIST. ON PAID ARE PAN OFF
OTHER. I'M SO WEEKS UP A SLIGHT
LOWER. WHILE BUT WE DO THINK
THOSE. IN FACT THEY ALMOST
CERTAINLY WILL BENEFIT US OVER
THE LONGER TERM. AND THEN THE
LAST POINT I'LL MAKE IS THAT
WITH THAT BSA IN A YOU MENTION
THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT. WITH THE DEPOSIT
PROJECTED THIS YEAR WILL BE AT
NINE POINT 8% OF THAT. CONCERT
TOUR THE CONSTITUTIONAL 10%
CAP- AND THAT'S JUST WHAT THE
MANDATORY DEPOSIT SO WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT. MANDATORY FOR AB
PLUS DISCRETIONARY WERE ABOUT
13% OF GENERAL FUND. REVENUES
SO I THINK IT'S WORTH A
DISCUSSION I'M SURE THE LA- HAS
THOUGHTS ON THIS AS WELL. AS
WEATHER 10% IS ENOUGH OR
WHETHER WE SHOULD BE PUTTING
MONEY IN OTHER PLACES OF COURSE
LAST YEAR. WE PUT MONEY IN THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE WHICH IS
SEPARATE FROM THE BSA. BUT IT
IS WORTH NOTING THAT THE VOTERS
APPROVED AT THE ESSAY- WITH THE
HOPE THAT WOULD BE FILLED UP
210% AND WE'RE PROJECTING IF
ALL GOES WELL. IN THE BUDGET
YEAR PLUS ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE WILL
BE ATTHAT 10% LEVEL FOR
MANDATORY DEPOSITS. AND SPEAKER
THE BSA TO THE YOU THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE- THAT WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO GROW THE RESEARCH.
DEFINITELY EITHER THROUGH VIA.
LIKE THE SAFETY NET RESERVE
DEPOSITS ME TOO SO TO USE THE
BSA PROCESS IS THE PROPER THING
TO DO. SO THERE ARE DIFFERENT
RESERVES ACCOUNTS INCLUDING THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE VENDORS ALSO
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
RESERVE- SO I THINK THAT'S A
DISCUSSION- WE DEFINITELY. YOU
KNOW WOULD BE INTERESTED AND IN
TERMS OF. IF WE WANT TO BUILD
ADDITIONAL DESERVES WHAT WE
HAVE. RESERVES BEYOND WHAT WE
HAVE. HOW TO DO THAT- I THINK
IN AN ENVIRONMENT OF SLOWING
GROWTH AT THAT THAT DOES
ACTUALLY COME TO PASS- MOST OF
ANY AVAILABLE MONEY- MAY BE
ALLOCATED TO DISCRETIONARY
PROGRAMS RATHER THAN RESERVES-
BUT- YOU KNOW SHOULD THERE BE
ADDITIONAL REVENUES WE WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT WAYS TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD OUR
RESILIENCY. YES I AM FROM FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE. WE THINK THIS
IS ONE OF THE KEY QUESTIONS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER.
THAT ALMOST AS IF YOU KNOW THE
FIRST QUESTION BEFORE IT MIGHT
BE YOU KNOW WHETHER IT IS
COMFORTABLE WITH. THE LEVEL OF
DISCRETIONARY RESERVES AND-
JUST MAKING NOTE I AM ME AND
MENTIONED IT A LITTLE BIT AGO
BUT- JUST MAKING NOTE THAT
RECENT BUDGETS HAVE TAKEN PART
OF THE SURPLUS AND USED IT TO
BUILD UP LARGER STE-
DISCRETIONARY RESERVE SUCH AS
THE SAFETY NET RESERVE. AND
THAT THOSE WOULD BE- AT. THE
ALTERNATIVES THE YOU COULD
CONSIDER AND- AND WOULD
CERTAINLY- IT ADD TO THE
STATE'S BUDGET RESILIENCE. BUT
AGAIN- YOU KNOW. IF THE IF THAT
WASN'T THE CHOICE THAN WE THINK
YOU SHOULD ALSO CONSIDER.
MAINTAINING SOME DEGREE OF
OPERATINGSURPLUS- IN THE IN
THE MULTI YEAR PLAN- IT MAY BE
SOMEWHAT LARGER THAN WHAT THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES BECAUSE THAT
WOULD HAVE KIND OF THE SIMILAR
EFFECT. IN A WAY YOU COULD
THINK OF THE- OPERATING
SURPLUSES KIND OF YOUR FIRST
LINE OF DEFENSE AGAINST THE
EFFECTS OF A RECESSION IT WOULD
BE THE FIRST THING TO ABSORB.
THE SHORTFALL SO THAT WOULD BE
ONE ALTERNATIVE IF YOU DIDN'T
WANT TO USE YOU KNOW MAKE A- A
DISCRETE DEPOSIT. LAST FOR ME.
MY COLLEAGUES DELF QUITE DEEPLY
INTO MANY THE SPENDING PROPOSAL
SO I WILL JUST. ASK ONE
QUESTION ONE IS REALLY KIND OF
PROCEDURAL. WE'RE CLEAR THAT A
NUMBER OF YOUR PROPOSALS WILL
REQUIRE STATUTORY CHANGES.
THREE ONE OF THE LEGISLATURE BE
RECEIVING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
FOR ALL YOUR PROPOSALS IN
FEBRUARY IF NOT IF YOU COULD
LET US KNOW WHEN WE CAN EXPECT
TO GET THAT LANGUAGE BECAUSE
IT'S ME THE STUFF IT'S NOT JUST
DOLLARS AND SUSAN COLLINS IT'S
REAL. STATUTORY WE'LL HAVE THAT
STORY IMPACTS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO
PROCESS ALL OF THAT FLOWS
FEBRUARY REASONABLE OR NOT YES
SO WE'RE TRYING TO GET AS MANY
OF OUR PROPOSALS AT RELEASED ON
FEBRUARY FIRST AS POSSIBLE AND
YOU I'M SURE AT THE CONCLUSION
OF THE HEARING MY COLLEAGUES
AND I WERE ALL GONNA RUN BACK
TO FINANCE AND- CONTINUE
PLUGGING AWAY ON THAT. THERE
ARE CERTAIN NUMBER PROPOSALS-
INCLUDING SOME OF THAT VERY NEW
CONCEPTS OF THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED WHERE WE HAVE- WE DO
NEED ADDITIONAL TIME- AND WHAT
LOOKING MORE TOWARD A SPRING
RELEASE OF THAT LANGUAGE IN THE
PROPOSAL BUT WE'RE VERY
COGNIZANT OF THE FACT THAT THE
WAY TO RE RELEASE THOSE
PROPOSALS THE LAST TIME THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TO CONSIDER
THEM- SO WE ARE WORKING TO GET
THEM OUT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
AND WE WILL BE IN TOUCH WITH
BUDGET STAFF ON THE- SPRING AS
IN PRE MAY REVISE. PULSE MAY
REVISE EARLY SPRING. WHERE ARE
YOU. OR YOU BUT YOU KNOW IT'S
HARD TO SEE. PROPOSALS COMING
OUT MAY REFER. DOING A BUDGET
WINDOW BUT S. WE'LL BE IN CLOSE
TOUCH INTO OKAY WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF THE TIME WHEN THOSE
WILL BE. ONE MORE QUESTION- FOR
ME ON SPIN PROPOSALS THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS FOR NEW
DEPARTMENT TORE
REORGANIZATIONS OR NEW NAMES I
THINK. MY BONE OF CONTENTION IS
THE NEW NAMES. BECAUSE BECAUSE
IT JUST RENAME THE DEPARTMENT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY YOU KNOW
CANNELLA CULTURE SHIFT. I DON'T
THINK THE NAME OF THE
DEPARTMENT NECESSARILY ASK THE
YOU KNOW. REFLECT WHAT EVER
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGES THAT
THE- ADMINISTRATION SEEMS
APPROPRIATE AND SO WHAT'S THE
COST ESTIMATE. FOR CHANGING THE
NAME OF AN ORGANIZATION. SO
I'LL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
OKAY I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT.
ALL RIGHT THINK ANY OF CLOSING
REMARKS FROM EVEN IF YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND YOUR
PATIENCE AND YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO- HAVE LENGTHY CONVERSATION
NOT IN THE OVERSIGHT HEARING
ANY. CLOSING COMMENTS YOU'D
LIKE TO SHARE WITH ANY OF US.
BEFORE I OPENED IT UP TO-
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT'S ALREADY
QUEUING UP ANYTHING FROM THE
GENTLEMAN. ALL RIGHT OF PUBLIC
COMMENT WITH THE OUR OF A
QUARTER TO ONE HAVING ARRIVED
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU ALL TO BE
PROBABLY A LITTLE MORE SO THINK
THAT MANY OF US HAVE BEEN ALL
MORNING. ADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BRENDAN TO ACHE. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS THAT SEE
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS FROM ALL
THIRTY FIVE LOCAL THEIR
DISTRICTS. WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS REGARDING THE- EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY YEAR
PROTECTION. LOCAL
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING CUTS- I
DID WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THERE WAS FIFTY MILLION FOR
LOCAL IMPLEMENTATION IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET AND THE YEAR
BEFORE- AND THE BREAKDOWN WAS
IT WAS TWENTY MILLION FROM THE-
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
AND THIRTY MILLION FROM THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL FUND. SO THIS
BUDGET- PROVIDES A BOMB OF. OF
THE GREENHOUSE GAS MONEY FROM
TWENTY MILLION UP TO TWENTY
FIVE SO THAT'S THE CAP AND
TRADE MONEY. BUT ON THE OTHER
SIDE IT COMPLETELY ZEROS OUT
THE THIRTY MILLION. IN AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL FUNDING OF
IT'S GOING TO HAVE A DRAMATIC
AT AND NEGATIVE IMPACT. ON THE
PROGRAM- AIRED AT COMMUNITIES
AND AIR DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
WORKING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL- TO
REDUCE. EMISSIONS WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS VERY WORTHY
IMPORTANT. COMMUNITY FOCUS
PROGRAM- IT WILL REDUCE OUR
SCOPE AND EFFECTIVENESS.
THERE'S REAL PUBLIC HEALTH ****
CONSEQUENCES ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
THIS CUT IS NOW OCCURRING AT A
TIME. WHEN YOU'RE EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM FROM TEN COMMUNITIES TO
THIRTEEN. SO AND THE OTHER
THING IS I DID WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT. OF THE PROGRAM
FRANKLY HAS ALWAYS BEEN UNDER
FUNDED SO. IT WE SEE THE REAL
COST AT CLOSER TO A HUNDRED
MILLION. ANNUALLY WHEN YOU
FACTOR IN THAT THE ADDITION OF
NEW COMMUNITIES AND SO IN ORDER
TO DO THE WORK WELL IN ORDER TO
KEEP THE PROMISE OF AB SIX
SEVENTEEN. IT REQUIRES
INTENSIVE RESOURCES AND SO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE ALSO
WOULD LOOK FOR INCREASED
INCENTIVES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PRORAM AS WELL AND OF COURSE
WE'LL DELVE INTO THIS MORE IN
THE SUBCOMMITTEE CAPSULE HAS
YOU AS YOU RECALL YOU'LL HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU
THANK YOU I'M GOING TO ASK.
MEMBERS TO THAT MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO HELP KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS WITH IN A TWO MINUTE
TIME FRAME NEXT WITNESS THANK
YOU REMEMBER FROST BUCKLEY ON
BEHALF OF SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT I
KEEP MY COUNTRY FREE
ASSOCIATES. ARE CAUGHT TO THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER ABOUT THE DISH
ONLY FOR SIX SEVENTEEN FUNDING
AND PICKERS RELATES TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION CENTER DOLLARS
THANKS. ALLEN ABS WITH THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT- IS BURNED INTO A
NOTED- RIGHT NOW WE'VE WERE UP
TO THIRTEEN COMMUNITIES IN THE
AB SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM FOR
THE BAY AREA- SPECIFICALLY WE
HAVE THE WEST OAKLAND IN THE
RICHMOND SAN PABLO AREA.
HOWEVER WE'VE ALSO BEEN WORKING
WITH COMMUNITIES IN THERE'S
PROMISES THAT- WE COMMUNITIES
OF VALLEJO- SOUTH SAN JOSE-
SOUTH OF SAN FRANCISCO- TRI
VALLEY AREA AND OTHER PARTS OF
THE BAY AREA CAN BE ADDED TO
THE SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM AND
SO IT'S- REALLY DISCONCERTING
TO SEE THAT WE'RE GETTING A 50%
CUT. IN AB SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENT IMPLEMENTATION AT THE
SAME TIME WE'RE EXPANDING
COMMUNITIES- THE MEMBERS MAY
HAVE SEEN THAT- IT ONE OF THE
UNIQUE THINGS WE'VE DONE IN THE
SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM IN THE
BAY AREA. IS WERE CURRENTLY-
DRIVING- ELECTRIC VEHICLES WITH
SENSORS ON EVERY ROAD IN THE
BAY AREA- FOR THE NEXT YEAR
TWENTY TIMES. TO GET A HEAT MAP
OF ALL THE AIR POLLUTION
SOURCES- AND THEN BEING ABLE TO
WORK WITH THE COMMUNITY TO FIND
OUT. US WAYS THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE OUR PUBLIC HEALTH IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND SO IT'S
JUST ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
DOING. A CULT LIKE THIS WILL BE
DEVASTATING TO NOT ONLY THAT
PROGRAM BUT TO PROGRAMS IN
FUTURE COMMUNITIES. I HOPE THE
COMMITTEE- WILL SEE FIT TO
CONTINUE THIS PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS TWO
MINUTES. GOOD AFTER GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S BRIAN
BEVERAGE ON THE CO DIRECTOR OF
THE WEST OAKLAND ENVIRONMENTAL
INDICATORS PROJECT AND WE WERE
THE COMMUNITY PARTNER WITH THE-
BAY AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT ON THE- R. A. B. SIX
ONE SEVEN AIR PLAN. THE FIRST
OF THE STATE- SO WE WERE KIND
OF THE GUINEA PIGS. AND I
WANNA- I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM SENATOR BALANCE
AND SKINNER- PARTICULAR
COMMENTS AROUND. FINDING
PROGRAMS THAT WORK IN
CONTINUING TO FUND THEM. A
COMMON- TO YEAH I THINK WE-
WENT TO THE POINT OF. WE NEED-
POPULATIONS THAT ARE IMPACTED
BY ISSUES TO BE- TO BRING FORTH
THEIR THEIR PERSPECTIVE. SO
THAT WE GET GOOD SOLUTIONS THAT
ACTUALLY WORK FOR THE PEOPLE ON
THE GROUND. AND ULTIMATELY WE
NEED TO CUT ACROSS AGENCY
SILOS. SO THAT WE GET-
COLLABORATION BETWEEN AGENCIES
AND WE'RE- WE'RE ONLY A MONTH
INTO OUR IMPLEMENTATION. AND
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING THE CITY
OF OAKLAND THE PORT OF OAKLAND
THE AIR DISTRICT. AND LOCAL
DEVELOPERS. TO FIGURE OUT HOW
CAN WE USE MULTIPLES RESOURCE-
MULTIPLE SOURCES OF RESOURCES
TO BRING ABOUT THIS PLAN TO
REDUCE THE IMPACTS. OF AIR
QUALITY POLLUTION IN OUR
COMMUNITY TO THIS REALLY IS A
PROGRAM THAT'S TURNING OUT THAT
IT WORKS. HAND WASH IT WOULD BE
A BUT IT WOULD BE A SAD TIME AT
THIS MOMENT WHEN THERE'S SO
MUCH WORK TO BE DONE AND I
THINK THIS COULD ACTUALLY BE
DUPLICATED ACROSS OTHERS OTHER-
SITUATIONS AND OTHER SOCIAL
CONDITIONS SO. THANK YOU FOR
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI
WITH NOTES TO KNOW. HI IT'S
NANCY. MY NAME IS MISS MARGARET
GORDON I'M THE ONE THE FOUNDERS
OF THE CODE OF THE WAY OAKLAND
IN PROJECT THIS IS MY SIXTH
GENERATION A WEST OAKLAND
RESIDENT- I DO NOT WANT TO SEE
TWENTY FIVE MORE YEARS. OF
POLLUTION BEEN IMPACTED ON HER
I WANNA FOR BECAUSE OF LACK OF
SB SIX ONE SEVEN LIKE BROWN TO
SAY WE WAS THE FIRST COMMUNITY
OBLIGATE THE DOING THE STEERING
COMMITTEE PROCESS OF UP WE ARE
CALLING BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
DOING OUR OWN THEIR MONITORING
OF ALMOST TWENTY YEARS I HAVE
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF MY LIFE
INVESTED. IN THIS PROCESS AND
MY LEGACY IS ALSO BEHIND SB SIX
ONE SEVEN. I DO NOT WANT TO BE
SET UP FOR FAILURE BECAUSE THE
COMMUNITY DON'T TRUST
GOVERNMENT ALREADY WE HAVE. HAD
TO GO TO A LOT OF TRIALS AND
TRIBULATIONS TO GET THE
RESIDENTS TO WANT TO BE ON THE
STEERING COMMITTEE BECAUSE OF
OUR ISSUES WITH IN WEST LOCAL
RAP POLLUTION SO IS NOT THIS IS
NOT TIME TO DO IN THE CUTTING.
THIS I TIME TO TRY TO REALLY
GO TO ANOTHER LEVEL THIS IS A
TIME TO PUT THIS ON A NATIONAL
PLATFORM THAT YOU HAVE THIS
PROCESS GOING AND. DAHLE SET US
UP FOR FAILURE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS TWO MEN. HI
MY NAME'S WILLIAM. I'M A RE YOU
BERKELEY MEAN BOTH THE CITY PER
AND PUBLIC HEALTH. SO I'VE BEEN
RESEARCHING SB SIX ONE SEVEN
GOING ALONG WITH WHAT WAS SAID
BEFORE AND IT'S THE TOPIC MY
MASTER'S THESIS. SO MY RESEARCH
SO FAR SHOWS THAT THIS IS BEEN
TREMENDOUSLY SUCCESSFUL
PROCESS. THE BAY AREA- DISTRICT
HAS WORKED IN THE SPIRIT THE
REAL SPIRIT OF EIGHTY SIX AND
SEVEN TO MAKE THE PROCESS TRULY
COMMUNITY DRIVEN AND COMMUNITY
LEAD. WHICH IS AMAZING. AND
PRESIDENT SETTING THE WEST
OAKLAND PLAN GENERATED- IS
STANCE REDUCE KEY HEALTH
BURDENS IN THE COMMUNITY SUCH
AS THE HIGH RATE OF ASTHMA IN
CHILDREN AS YOU JUST SAW- MISS
MARKETS GREAT DAN
GRANDDAUGHTER. AND INCREASE
CANCER RISK MY RESEARCH ALSO
INDICATES THAT AB SIX ONE SEVEN
CAN IMPROVE THESE HEALTH
IMPACTS BUT FUNDING MUST
CONTINUE AT THE CURRENT LEVEL.
NOT REDUCED OR INCREASE TO MEET
THESE HEALTH GOALS- THE PLAN
ALSO OFFERS CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
TO LONG STANDING POLLUTION
ISSUES. BY AS BRIAN SAID TO
BRING TOGETHER NOT ONLY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS BUT THE PORT
THE CITY THE HEALTH. AUTHORITY
ALL WORKING TOGETHER FOR THESE
GOALS AND BREAKING DOWN SILOS
SO IT GOES BEYOND A
PARTICIPATORY MODEL INTO AN
INTEGRATED PLANNING MODEL WHICH
ME AND MY PROFESSOR BELIEVE. IS
TRULY CUTTING EDGE IN PLANNING.
A I ALSO SAY THAT BUT CUTS
STAND IF THEY HAPPEN STAND TO
REPLICATE HISTORIC PATTERNS OF
POLICY VOLATILITY. AND THAT
FAILED TO DELIVER CHANGES
PROMISES LEGISLATION AND STAND
TO GRADE COMMUNITIES TRUST IN
GOVERNMENT. WE NEED TO FIND SB
SIX ONE SEVEN. TWO RIGHT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE SEEN
HISTORIC- ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
IS TO REALLY HEAL THEMSELVES
FROM THESE ISSUES THAT THEY DID
NOT BECAUSE SO I SAY PLEASE.
CONTINUE TO FUND THIS BECAUSE
OTHER STATES AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE LOOKING AT A. B.
SIX AND SEVEN AS A MODEL. FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
LEGISLATION AND CLIMATE
LEGISLATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS TWO MINUTES.
MADAM CHAIRMAN TOMIC TOMORROW
HERE BEHALF OF THE SACRAMENTO
METROPOLITAN AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. I WOULD
ALSO SINCE HE MY COMMENTS HEY
WITH THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
RELATIVE TO. A BE SIX ONE SEVEN
AND ITS EFFECT ON THE COMMUNITY
HIGHLIGHTING THESE ISSUES ONE
THE COLLABORATION. BETWEEN VERY
DIFFERENT GROUPS ACROSS THE
BOARD IN IMPLEMETING SIX ONE
SEVEN HAS BEEN REMARKABLE AND
THE AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT HERE'S SEEN GREAT.
STRIDES IN THE COLLABORATION
WORKING WITH A PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT DISADVANTAGED AREAS
HIS SECOND ISSUE WOULD BE MORE
MONEY IS BETTER THAN LESS. AND
THE THIRD ISSUE IS I WAS DRAWN
TO THE DOCTOR PANTS COMMENTS
EARLIER WHERE HE SAID THAT IF
WE'RE NOT DEALING WITH THEIR
QUALITY THAN WE'RE DEALING WITH
ASTHMA IN CHILDREN. WE'RE GOING
TO BE PAYING FOR THIS ONE WAY
OR THE OTHER I BELIEVE THAT MY
CLIENT'S POSITION WOULD BE
LET'S PAY FOR IT ON THE FRONT
END. AND NOT DEAL WITH THE
ASTHMA IN THE LONG RUN AND
THEREFORE FUND THESE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVEN'T SO PROMISING AND
JUST GETTING STARTED. SO
THEREFORE I GUESS SAID I'D HOW
WE SUPPORT MORE FUNDING RATHER
THAN LESSEN THE SIR THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON
ANY ON. DIRECTOR BRIGHT LINE
DEFENSE WHICH IS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
SERVING LOW INCOME TENANTS AS
WELL AS VERY LOW INCOME
TENANTS. AROUND AIR QUALITY
ISSUES AND WE ALSO BUILD UP
YOUTH LEADERSHIP COHORTS IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AS WELL. AND WOULD
LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE PRIOR
SPEAKERS BUT ALSO ONE MORE
THING TO ADD IS THAT. THIS
PROGRAM EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
ALLOWS US TO TEST OUT
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES ON A
VERY LOCALIZED SCALE ALLOWS US
TO MOVE QUICKLY ON
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES AND ALLOWS
US TO SCALE THEM UP. IF THEY
ARE SUCCESSFUL A COUPLE
POLICIES TO RATTLE OFF WOULD BE
THINGS LIKE KERR FREE STREETS
BUSTLE EDUCATION CLEAN ROOM
INFRASTRUCTURE AND STUDYING
WILDFIRE IMPACTS. TO LOCAL
BUILDING HOUSING STOCK
INSERTING LAND USE POLICY THESE
ARE ALL THINGS WE CAN TEST OUT
UNDER EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN. AND
THAT'S WHY WE BELIEVE IN THIS
PROGRAM SO MUCH AND THAT
CUTTING AWAY THE FUNDING RIGHT
NOW CUTS AWAY AT THE EQUITY
ISSUES THAT SHOULD BE A
CENTERPIECE OF CAP AND TRADE
FUNDING TO BEGIN WITH. SO WOULD
IMPLORE YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS NOT ONLY RESTORED BUT
HOPEFULLY UP MORE BECAUSE THIS
IS A SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED
PROGRAM TO BEGIN WITH. AND
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE OF
COURSE SENATOR SKINNER SENATOR
PENN CENTER LEYVA FOR THEIR
COMMENTS AROUND EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. ON TALKING ABOUT
HOW POTENTIALLY THIS COMPLETE
ACOSTA UP. IN THE LONG TERM FOR
IN SHOULD DO IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M GOING
TO ASK IF IN THE OTHER PUBLIC
WITNESSES ARE- A HERE TO SPEAK
ABOUT SB SIX SEVENTEEN THAT YOU
SIMPLY SAY DITTO. ONE EXCELLENT
NEXT BUT AFTER AND HERE ON
MONDAY PARTIAL WITH THE USE
STUDENT SO WE WANT TO QUICKLY
TALK ABOUT THE HIGHER EDUCATION
BUDGET PARTICULARLY FOR YOU SEE
WE APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE AND ALSO
APPRECIATE TO SEE THAT THE
TUITION BOARD WAS DELAYED
YESTERDAY- SO WITH THAT THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF PRIORITIES THAT
STUDENTS HAVE AGREED WITH THAT
REALLY LIKE YOU SEE IN THESE
ARE PARTICULARLY AROUND-
OUTRAGE AND RETENTION PROGRAMS
SO ON THE OUTER SIDE- WE HAD
PUT IN A REQUEST FOR ALL FUND
INCREASED FUNDING FOR SAY
PROGRAMS THESE ARE PROGRAMS
THAT GO TOWARDS. EXPANDING
ACCESS TO MARGINALIZE AND
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS- AT
THE YOU SEE AND THEN ON THE
RETENTION SIDE AND TRYING TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND
INCREASE GRADUATION- WE HAD PUT
IN A BUDGET REQUEST FOR ALL THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR ASKED
TOWARDS SUPPORTING UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS FOSTER YOUTH AND
FORMALLY CONCERT STUDENTS AND
THESE BOB PROGRAMS ARE
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT US SOME OF
THE HIGHEST NEEDS OUR
POPULATIONS AT THE YOU SEE THAT
ARE HISTORICALLY HAVE
EXPERIENCED OUR LOWEST LEVELS
OF RETENTION AND GRADUATION. AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH- BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO TRY TO SECURITIES
ADDITIONAL UNNECESSARY. FUNDING
I THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. CAN
LIVE AS REPRESENTING. CO FOR
YOU AND ONE OF THE LEDGE. FOR
THEIR TARGETED SET ASIDE FOR
YOU THE- HOMELESSNESS. YEAR AND
THE TIME FOR AND ARE EAGER TO
SEE THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL
FOR THAT SHARE ON THAT SEVEN
AND FIFTY MILLION AND HOPE THAT
THERE IS A SET ASIDE FOR YOUTH.
WITHIN THAT AS WELL AND WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT I'M SHAPING HALL
THROUGH THEIR VOICES OF YOUTH
COUNTERPARTY DONE EXTENSIVE
WORK LOOKING INTO THE CAUSES OF
HOMELESSNESS FOR YOUTH
SPECIFICALLY. AND EVEN LOOKING
AT SOME THE SUBPOPULATIONS
WHETHER IT'S LGBT Q. YEAR-
PREGNANT AND PARENTING AND
RURAL AND SO I JUST WANTED TO
BRING THAT TO YOUR ATTENTION
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. HI ANDREA SAN MIGUEL
ON THE HAVE A PLAN PARA
PHILLIES OF CALIFORNIA- I JUST
WANT TO MENTION ON AS A FOLLOW
UP TO THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
WITH YOU ALL AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON PROP FIFTY
SIX. SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS ON
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. JUST
LAST YEAR- ALLOCATING A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL HEALTH-
WELL THAT'S ALL STILL BEING
IMPLEMENTED I WANTED TO SHARE
TODAY A COUPLE OF- WAYS THAT
THAT'S IMPROVING THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. FOR EXAMPLE THE HEALTH
CENTERS- THROUGHOUT THE MORE
MONTY AFFILIATE WHICH IS THE
LARGEST IN THE COUNTRY. HAVE
NOW INCREASED THEIR WEEKEND
HOURS FOR PATIENTS. IN LA- JUST
ANNOUNCED LAST MONTH THEY WILL
BE ROLLING OUT FIFTY WELLNESS
CENTERS ON HIGH SCHOOL
CAMPUSES. AND ADDITIONALLY
YESTERDAY. ON THE ANNIVERSARY
OF ROE V. WADE. WE HAVE THE WE
WERE ABLE TO SEE THE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD OF PASADENA AND SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY. CELEBRATE THE
OPENING OF A NEW HEALTH CENTER
WHICH WILL BE THE ONLY ABORTION
PROVIDER IN THE AREA. SO JUST
WANT TO BE ABLE TO SAY THAT WE
STAND TRONG SUPPORT WITH
INCREASING- WITH CONTINUING TO
INCREASE FOR THE EIGHTEEN
MONTHS UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE- BUT ALSO- ECHO DR PM
COMMENTS ABOUT. HOW THAT CLIFF
ACCRETED TEN. CAN GO AHEAD AND
IMPACTS- WHAT HAPPENS WITH
PROVIDERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS TWO MINUTES
PLEASE. HI ALYSSA SO HIGH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE OVER ONE.
THOUSAND MEMBERS THAT WE HAVE
THAT PROVIDE CRITICAL SERVICES
TO CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES SUCH
AS WATER WASTEWATER AND FIRE
PROTECTION. WE APPRECIATE ITS
INTERNAL SINCE COMMENTS IN
QUESTION. AS SEEKING
CLARIFICATION ON OUR
ELIGIBILITY FOR THAT FIFTY
MILLION COMMUTER RESILIENCE
FUNDING AND ALSO APPRECIATED
FINANCES. BUDGET CHAIN PROPOSAL
LANGUAGE SPECIFICALLY CALLING
US OUT AND WE ALSO ARE
GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CLIMATE
BUDGET AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY AS
THESE. ISSUES BEFORE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN ANIEL
SANCHEZ I BEHALF OF THE- BE
OFFICER OF. I HERE AT IN
SUPPORT AND APPRECIATIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S INVESTMENTS IN SB
SIX SEVENTY EIGHT- AND RELATED
PROPOSALS TO REALLY INVEST IN
THE FRONT END OF THE SYSTEM AND
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES FOR OURCLIENTS- WE- WE KNOW THAT
INVESTING IMPROVING PRACTICES
LIKE THIS CAN- HAVE VERY
POSITIVE OUTCOMES- AND RETURNS
BOTH ON. THOSE INVESTMENTS-
FROM A QUALITY OF LIFE AND FOR
THOSE THAT WE WORK WITH DAY IN
AND DAY OUT. I WOULD ALSO JUST
HIGHLIGHT TO THAT WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENTS IN
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM
IMPLEMENTATION FAR FOSTER
YOUTH- IN OUR IN OUR STATE AS
WELL AS A DISCUSSION ON MENTAL
HEALTH AN ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES SO. WE KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF DETAILS TO BE WORKED
THROUGH WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND BEING A
PART OF THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FINAL WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON TYLER INTO WITH THE
KIND OF BEHAVIOR HOW TRACTORS
ASSOCIATION- APPRECIATIVE THE
GOVERNOR'S FOCUS ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND ALL OF THE
INITIATIVES- SURROUNDING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INCLUDING
THE- MEDI CAL HEALTHIER
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL- BE-
PROPOSALS FOR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS WITH A FOCUS ON
BOARDING CARE FACILITIES- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED PHAM TASK
FORCE ON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AND
PARITY ENFORCEMENT- WE'RE
LOOKING FOR TO ENGAGE IN MORE
DISCUSSIONS AND ALL OF THESE
PRIORITIES AND TOPIC AREAS. AND
THEN AND WOULD LIKE TO RAISE A
LITTLE BIT OF. SOME OF OUR
PRIORITIES INCLUDING ON PRE
TRIAL MENTAL HEALTH THE VIRGIN.
PUBLIC GUARDIAN IN PUBLIC
CONSERVATIVE FUNDING- BOY I'D
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS AROUND
BOARDING CARE FACILITIES. AND
THEN PEER SUPPORT CERTIFICATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
OUR NEXT FULL BUDGET HEARING
WILL BE FEBRUARY THIRTEENTH
THIS COMMITTEE MEETING STANDS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.